foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
let's go
[Music]
foreign
come
on
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
come on
[Music]
let's go
I do love chess since we're winning boys
why don't we celebrate with a glass of
wine nine o'clock somewhere in the world
am I right
[Music]
that was amazing I loved that
wow
yes he's garbage at chess it needs to
uninstall forever I will pick you up in
real life are we gonna allow him to
embarrass production like this
you're not serious can't wait to see you
Dallas
it's POG Champs five what better day to
start your Monday Better Way what better
way to start your week than with an
international Master called Levy Rosman
he's Gotham chest hey there Levy big fan
happy you're here for POG Champs
I'm I'm super happy to be here uh and uh
may I remind you you are also and I am
they got two IMS for the price of one
Danny double the IMs double the fun it's
gonna be a great day we've got bracket
chess now we've been in pool play but
now Levy it's winner go home and if you
win you go all the way to La so I I'm
excited to see what kind of chess the
players bring today let's Dive Right In
without any further Ado and start
talking about the championship bracket
Levy art I'm gonna ask you are you
surprised by anything so far not just
Frank having already punched his ticket
to the next round
no no I'm surprised by nothing here uh
Frank and Gastly went down to the wire
it was back and forth I think mostly
everybody who was expected to qualify
into the championship did in fact
qualify into the championship uh and now
we need to pit them against each other
uh for memes and for dreams and for good
content chess and otherwise uh and then
we got to give him a lot of money and
also take them to La which we'll tell
you about in a second yeah well we're
going to keep talking about all day
because that is something that is
different than POG Champs previous POG
Champs the fact that we're all going to
be in La I don't know if you called
Andrea bochas reminding her that your
your student Frank beat her student yet
if you want we can maybe call her right
now and just kind of rub it in if you're
into that I don't I'm not a sore winner
Danny it doesn't happen to me very often
so like I just I just live in the moment
and uh yeah it was it was a big win but
I like Gastly a lot too and uh we're
gonna play some chess when he's in New
York so all right good good stuff well
the uh the winning didn't happen as
often as the next list of players wanted
that's why they're in the consolation
bracket but as we've already mentioned a
few times the live Final in La will be
for the two players competing in the
championship but also the two players
competing for the consolation bracket
Championship so still a lot on the line
half these players might even not even
want to win they'd maybe rather stay
home and they come comfort of their
creator home but um Levy I'm gonna ask
you on the spot if you were to Circle
one player right now with the best
chances to go all the way to La who is
it in the consolation bracket
uh well that it would be two right it
wouldn't just be going to La it would
just be it would be winning in L.A I
mean I I think it's it'll probably be
virtual versus uh versus daily dose uh
because daily dose is reinvigorated you
know he was in a really tough group and
his score did not reflect the quality of
his play or his level and virtual was
supposed to win Group B and like Anna
kramling flew to Norway to give him IRL
lessons I mean it was like a Rocky movie
and my man got third in the group like
that was a crazy group and the winner of
that group is now out so he's looking
for Redemption and you're right Danny
daily those did say it La is beautiful
we're about to show the the audience are
real of it but he doesn't even want to
go he wants to play online he's too I
don't know maybe it's the nerves it's
very different playing live in LA or
live anywhere right it is no playing
live IRL chess is uh is its own
experience that the the players are
gonna have there's that beautiful La
skyline no no smog taking it the perfect
time of day just before that Sunset hits
but anyway La is going to be great we're
excited to be there yeah no you made a
good point that group was insane in
hindsight right with virtual sapnap
ghastly what what a wild what a wild one
that was but either way we are here and
we'll see who gets there to La Levy
let's talk about the schedule there's a
whole schedule going up to La the live
final will be August 18th let's break
down today's schedule because we kicked
things off with Papa Platt versus xqc
it's hard to start that day because I
think that's going to be pretty lit and
maybe maybe hard to live up to as the
day goes on but the chess will be will
be great no matter what after that we
have virtual and Sky Kuno following the
papa plot xqc and then we still have
three more matches after that that's
right cutie Cinderella will play Ginny I
did a thing versus Tyler I think I did a
thing is also showing to be a little bit
of a dark horse for those who haven't
watched Alex play that matchup with
Tyler that's going to be crazy and then
we have Sea Dog and sapnap Levy we have
five matchups today what are you most
looking forward to which matchup are you
most amped to see yeah I'm not sure we
even like fully addressed this point but
there are no more quarter finalists
after today there it's all we're just
immediate the next day is semi-finalists
and then pending the schedule of all of
our participants some of them can play
some of them are uh pool cleaners and
some of them are are businessmen and
women like they got different things to
do we got to reschedule with them but
like today we're just coming through
this field completely in half yeah
um I'm I'm gonna steal uh I'm gonna
steal the one at the end I'm super
pumped to see sea dog versus sapnap
sapnap super motivated uh beat virtual
that was a big like
that was a big career moment for him and
he really wants to win and he's a
competitor but Sea Dog is a I mean he's
the king right he's the king of the
whole tournament so uh will he be the up
and coming sapnap I don't know we'll
find out
Sea Dogs Abnet might be a preview of
who's going to win the whole thing of
course Felix xuc would like have
something to say about that but I'm
going to circle a different matchup
before we talk about Papa plot and xqc
that is I can't wait to see tyler1 again
not just because I'm trying to build up
all these things just to really motivate
him to really want to kick my ass if we
meet in person but Tyler Jokes Aside
Tyler's been great it's been awesome
content shout out to all the league fans
out there
um moving on from their coloring books
to playing some League before watching
the show so appreciate that
um and uh we're gonna Dive Right In but
all right Levy how impressive have you
been with Felix let's talk about him
what he's been doing in pogchamps five
so far
very impressed but he hasn't played
somebody at his level just yet he he is
the only player uh who has not uh lost
or drawn a game in this POG Champs and I
I've been impressed with his whole chess
Arc I mean chess is just something that
he's added to his uh toolbox
uh and uh he plays it all the time he
kills time on stream 30 minutes one hour
just playing chess so very curious to
see if he's able to put it all together
for this particular event Danny but uh I
don't know Papa Plata is an OG he's also
stuck to chess and and I don't think the
ELO difference tells the whole story
here I totally agree I think that
obviously regardless of how it worked
out clearly there were some bracket or
some pool disparity xqc wasn't in as
strong of a pool as you could say sapnap
gasoline the crew were but he's still
been playing really well and he's still
been super motivated or he wouldn't have
been undefeated but he hasn't played
anyone as tough as Papa plot yet I uh
anyway this is gonna be epic right
they're both already streaming here we
go let's do our first thing where we
look in and was that chessable he was
looking at I don't know what Papa plot
was doing there
but look at that
he's watching the German pre-show is
that what he's doing I guess so yeah and
I somebody told me uh I I read uh was it
was it staff I just saw the sentence it
was either staffer in the chat but yeah
they said that he was preparing against
the xqc bot which yeah
you know uh listen I've played my bot
he's trash I'm not that trash uh so I
don't know we will see uh we'll see if
the training pays off he's he's grinding
though that's good risky play though I
agree with you because you don't want to
get false hope by playing a bot who may
not be as good as X UC himself but all
right here we see him he's one of
Germany's largest streamers you know it
this is his second POG Champs appearance
coming all the way back from the first
ever POG Champs in June 2020 but he
clearly played a lot more chess than
maybe some of the other competitors over
that time right Papa plot didn't
disappear Levy or he wouldn't have 900
chess games on his chess.com account
yeah I think I I don't know how many xqc
has but the these uh these guys they
they all play chess for fun during the
day uh they obviously take it a bit more
seriously during the tournament he's
definitely an underdog like don't get it
twisted uh that is Papa Plata but now we
see xqc on the screen he xucc's 2 000
that puzzles
yeah dude oh my dude is grinding he said
he's solving like 100 puzzles a day and
he also has I won't reveal it but he
also has an anonymous account Levy
that's a that's a horrible move right
there I mean he just hung his Queen so
he just hung his Queen two different
ways but that's what happens when you
when you when you get a puzzle wrong
you're like what how dare you how how
dare you think it's wrong and then like
you try to you know you just yeah so he
had to take the bishop there with check
and then get out with his Queen uh
anyway this is his player card Danny
I'll let you I've read this so many
times they gotta change these bullet
points like yeah you know I mean I don't
think OverWatch is the main thing X UC
is known for these days he's known for
reacting to content like crazy but
because that was how he burst into I
guess the streaming Esports scene he'll
forever be known as a former
professional OverWatch player but for
those who don't know this is his fourth
pod James appearance he has played in
more than more than any of them more
than any of them I guess meaning
streamers when I'm saying that and to
answer your question Levy we see it
right there he's played over 2500 games
on chess.com along with having an
anonymous account I can tell you like
like the guy is a grinder he
legitimately loves chess and it has been
pretty cool to see his Arc since since
June of 2020. I love that that he just
Jiggles I know it's peace I know like
Hikaru does it after he makes a move and
I started doing that too but he just he
just gives each one a pat on the back
before he decides where to move Bishop
E6 sorry I shouldn't okay no let's let's
do it no it is funny because he he has
his xqc Unique Style Bing Bang Boom
we're gonna see it today and he likes to
touch every single piece along the way
thank God for him it's not touch move by
the way that would be interesting if if
he's playing live Levy and he learns
that the rules are touch move that is
going to be its own content experience
right there I cannot win Danny actually
uh yeah are they playing like how we've
always done it with computers or is it a
physical board are you on no it's a
physical board we're bringing in dgts
the whole works we're gonna give him the
Grand Master experience so they feel
really you know special playing on big
nice wooden chessboards dude do they
know that do they know it's not there's
no computer screen like I'm not sure
they'll function like that's how they
operate that's a fair question
um I know Ludwig knows that because
we've been talking about it so I don't
think we've told anybody what it's going
to be like all right well that's my
advice because listen I'm not sure I
mean I'm not sure these folk these
people have been to like a bank
physically you know I have to go to a
bank to wire money I'm not sure they
know how to do that laughs oh man the
world of being a streamer and Creator
Levy can say it right because he's
because he's a Creator so he's allowed
to say it
um all right Levy let's remind everybody
what's at stake because we've said it
before we're talking about La as the the
prize I guess at the end but the the
other flip side of that coin is that if
you if you don't win today you go home
we are now in uh in elimination time
right so it's winner go home of course
even if you lose you're still taking
home some cash
um you know not necessarily the kind of
cash that these creators need but still
cash for your time gonna be a lot of fun
and Levy that's it it's winner go home
you would you win you advance otherwise
you're out
super exciting uh The Knockouts are the
best part I feel like they the the very
first round of them we had a great time
like some of the closest matches they
they would go into these playoffs uh
Gastly was a member of a double overtime
which doesn't happen a lot so we're
gonna see we're gonna see everything
from xqc and if he can continue his
undefeated streak to if sapnap can
overcome the dragon so if tyler1 is
going to become a professional chess
player and everything in between we have
five matches today that's wild matches
bro they lined us up they're giving us
the work man as if you don't got
anything else to do neither do I
apparently so let's do five matches uh
let's remind everybody as well as the
format just because they know it they
love it it's not like we're doing
anything new now that we're in the
elimination stage it's a best of two
rapid ten minutes plus five second per
move time control it's first to one and
a half points as Levy just said we've
already had one match go to double
overtime tiebreaker which was pretty
epic uh too bad for gasly but uh if
we're tied of course we will go into
Blitz Whoever has the most accurate
chess gets the first game with white but
if we have a draw then we just switch
colors and do it again so uh that's it
that's the format you know it you love
it it's pogchamps it is uh it's Creator
driven chess
it's wild and it's game time
I think it's gameplay it is it is game
time the players are ready the fans are
ready Benji in the background is ready
uh it's funny if they if they pan my
camera just a little bit he he's taking
a nap he he likes that corner of the
room so if at any point you know what we
should do today we should do if the
underdog wins in any matchup they should
just Benji should just sit with me and
commentate a game super professional
commentary people uh commentary great
you got a bot on or he had a bot during
dog month
um Benji was uh was a welcome a welcome
guest to the bot page I know we had fun
with that
um anyway Levy
um one of our participants is no longer
on screen hopefully he comes back in
time
he's gone the games will begin we've
already got about 60 000 of you on xqc's
channel almost 30 000 of you on Papa
plots uh wherever you are thanks for
being with us it's pogchamps five
someone needs to tell uh Felix that it's
time to stop solving puzzles and to log
in to the live chess Arena
there you go
uh now all right it's a big moment
Knight C2 check don't take that he's
gonna oh oh oh oh this is a tough puzzle
yeah this is a full
a full meeting net here actually wait
Danny I think it's Knight C2 Knight D4
yeah you just go for the queen I was
just gonna say there is no sack on B1
Knight C2 Knight D4 would win the queen
um I'm gonna guess that we're gonna be
here for a minute watching Felix do this
because there's no way he's gonna check
his DMS we have told him it's game time
but we might as well just stay right
here
you want to listen can we can we
I got it the time for the first to win
the whole thing not he's won he's won a
lot of games got it but seriously and I
know and I know he definitely was in an
easier bracket Levy but remember this is
the guy who was I I said it in the last
show with Andrea and I didn't
necessarily mean offense by it but she
pointed out it was a backhanded
compliment this is the guy who was the
meme of pogchamps one right this is the
guy that lost in six moves to Charlie we
all remember it because it's been seen
millions of times and now he is one of
the better players and that's a pretty
cool thing and just in regards to the
whole POG Champs tournament Arc right
scripted
yeah uh but by the way that we do in
fact have game time uh we have a
a
we have a hedgehof defense xqc is
playing uh White
yep we can already we already know they
made some moves because we've got the uh
the stream delay fair play for those who
ever wonder why the look-in is a little
behind that is by Design don't yell at
us because for fair play reasons
um we already know that this is on the
board and it's a symmetrical Petrov
Danny my my eval bar shows percent win
percent draw percent law is that a new
thing yeah it's a new thing as long as
so so it's a feature that as long as we
are in the opening book rather than
showing the eval because what's the
point in showing the computer's opinion
about a position that's been played five
thousand times
um we show the percentages of the game
and then the moment we go out of book
um we we change to a traditional eval
like like we have there
oh yeah it was showing me the pers oh my
good that is a little sexy you like what
do you think yeah yeah Eric will be
happy now now it's now it's just showing
an equal position and the the players
are in a queenless position oh is xqc
gonna take in blunder on B2 uh oh uh oh
you called it he did take
he did take
but will he see B2
we're already in a big moment
I think Knight C3 is going to be played
all right well we can analyze we can
listen into Felix you're called you want
to see what he's thinking for the first
time today yeah let's do it let's do it
let's do it oh my goodness he's giving
me a a heart attack
all right Felix what do you got talk to
us baby
doesn't have to take my pawns out okay
at least he sees it
let me think please okay
[Music]
by the way Libby I don't know if you saw
this yet I'm drinking I'm drinking from
your head
I appreciate it like that okay yeah
that's the he played Pawn to C3 huh okay
that is not a big fan of this episode
[Music]
I am not a fan of this developments
neither
let me think let me think let me think
let me think
this is not a good development
good position for Papa plot too I know
we're listening to Felix because that's
because uh Kevin is speaking German over
there but uh
Castle
am I at rest with the pawns not really
could you just give her a good
development he kind of like gives me
anxiety the way he touches every piece
that's so bad you know this is this
tough match
it's like anti-hikaru Levy when Hikaru
draws arrows you feel more secure
because you realize he's calculating the
future when when Felix touches every
piece it literally gives my heart like
palpitation still good I
let
I'm trying to talk but he talks too and
I want to hear what he wants to say
and Corner him and a little bit
uh yeah that works
what do you just do
I just asked that question
um yeah it also make uh it gives a
little bit of room something from my uh
Bishop
we got metal could have been pretty good
too though
I'm gonna get my Knights out of this
right okay yeah I got I got this as well
yeah
um down the line but hey we gotta move
we gotta move chat we gotta move
good plan oh my horse are stuck at home
uh what
I was
not for free
for free
paper
Levy
I don't know if you want to instant
replay that show with Papa plot did with
Bishop H4 that was a bad idea going
after the pawn he he had an accuracy of
98 before he did that like he was just
playing like Magnus Carlson and then he
just went
here
hey double question mark that's why he's
2 000 puzzles Danny because for free and
he's not wrong he is not wrong that is
oh my goodness
there you go
pop a plot off track with that bishop
move as Levy showed and there you see
our explanation in case you ever wonder
what those symbols mean double question
mark is blunder I think that's pretty
intuitive I think people see double
question mark and that doesn't look good
red means bad yeah that's good to know
it it definitely means bad and uh
that that was uh I was definitely not
recommended and I like how xqc is just
going back to the same plan uh yep he
can trade the Rooks
he can take the Knight
we'll see how good he is at uh
converting
one thing he was yelling at himself
about Levy which is one area he's
improved has been time he's like Chad we
got a move we gotta move overall like
he's just very aware of the clock and
now he's down a minute but
again I know he's been in an easy
bracket but I have been super impressed
with his play and and here he's getting
free rewards from Papa plot with that
Bishop
listen his journey to Los Angeles is
going to be pretty easy uh if the
players just give away
a uh
a bishop after 15 moves in the opening
I'm really I'm I'm a little bit I'm a
little disappointed because it had such
a great start now the problem for black
is you're down a piece but you also just
you have not you have nothing you have
no targets at all
and let's
Let's uh let's go see what Papa plots
just so I can practice my German I have
been using the Duolingo app you know not
necessarily practicing German but what's
Kevin talking about over there
by the way I love his arcade mode you
gotta love that love the animations on
the board
yes me too
it didn't stop him from giving up the
bishop
gotta take with the root there
nice nice
it's it's this is POG Champs of bull
though right he's okay he owns the file
Levy right he's in an okay
couldn't have said it better myself
obviously it's over about
um obvious the match is over
foreign
I agree with that chat arcade mode does
not get the respect it deserves oh he
said not over okay very important
this is why I I
speak my three languages and not this I
I guess he said nine or not in some
capacity that's a very big difference
Danny there you go there you go
um I I don't speak German good
yeah
yeah I like German food every time we
have Papa planta I tell everybody my
awareness of German culture I'm like I
love bratwurst you know I love uh yeah
now King here and Rook here is the end
of the fun for black because you trade
and then uh oops I just I I there was a
chessboard and I was drawing on Papa
Plata's chessboard sorry it's been
you're supposed to go here and then
trade the Rooks but we'll see if we'll
see if
that's what I was saying this is a Pog
champs-able game and what I mean by that
is this is not outside of the world
where where where ex you see blunders
this away because the open file Levy we
can talk about that in a game like this
where yes you're up a night but Knights
are some of the hardest pieces for
amateurs to coordinate he owns the only
open file if he plays rookie two or
rookie three here I forget what the eval
Bar says I think this is actually way
closer than it looks okay he's not
playing it unfortunately he's helping it
he's helping yeah rookie two is a is a
very high level conceptual move just
understanding that you should be very
active with your Rooks uh yeah and Felix
will probably play Knight F3 black okay
goes forward that also makes sense
yep and then
yeah okay
you're right rookie two is is uh is a
high level move to just understand why
the Rook is better there than where it
sits now
um and every move that goes by and he
doesn't play it increases the chances
that uh that Felix finds your idea Levy
this King D2 and rookie one trade up
nope now he's given useless checks
that's a good sign yep it's a good sign
for a papa plot to come back because
black will go here and then you will
just go here I mean Knight H6 is is
pretty short-sighted because you you
just attacked the king and you think
it's a good move and you never thought
what if they go here there was never
that extra thought so we need the Rook
yeah so we need and x2c is not using it
or maybe you don't need it depends who
you're cheering for
yep well also I guess we're speaking
we're speaking uh the the purpose of a
check the usefulness of it there's also
a chance that Papa puts his King on the
H file here an xqc looks like a genius
it just takes the pawn I mean King f8
Rook F1 Rook F7 is literally Checkmate
so
now you're speaking POG Champs now
you're speaking POG Champs Quebec school
of Chess you know like give the check
and then and then good things happen
um Place King G7 best move okay
I'm gonna give it a brilliant move
oh look at that look at you you can can
I put the face of my favorite YouTuber
on the board
let's do it what are they gonna do we
control the show what are they gonna go
to go to break
there it is there it is
I bet I know I got a god mature was
watching oh wait it switched to Danny
that was accidental
Levy how many levies can I get on the
board before they automatically
disappear I'm like as fast as I can whoa
this is awesome awesome I think it was
like 10 yeah 10 or this is good stuff
well we while we wait to see the xqc
endgame School of conversion
um
and uh yeah players can access that by
hovering to the top right during the
game and clicking the little Emoji
palette
um Heroes of Pierce's fish
love it like look Danny you could say
that when Papa Plato played Bishop H4 it
was a present
oh wow a gift a gift I'm telling you
this is the future of Gotham chess
videos right here little emojis at it
listen when when I when 10 years from
now when I'm averaging 11 000 views on
all my videos and my career has fallen
off I'm it's gonna be a Resurgence with
with Emojis on the chessboard that's
what's gonna happen I love it all right
let's see what Felix is saying see how
he's talking about converting this and
uh crawling the mind
of executing sideways
contest
wow then take take
move
that's pretty good
wow I can't believe you saw that it's
pretty good
Levy he's been watching videos
that only been a brilliant move for the
agenda
[Music]
modern brilliant
oh but that's a great move too B6
pushing him back
no
oh wait a minute honestly if you take
back Bishop H4 it's coming it's good
wait honey why not Knight A6 Rook C8
Fork oh he sees it this way too
it's over I win
one two
it's over right one fork attack trident
back to back
thing
[Music]
this game is over
his pawns are sideways beaked that's so
that's so bad that's like chat
this is a rookie mistake
it's not even more information that is
bad bad doesn't he have that too to the
center yuck
yeah
although F6 is a good move by Papa plot
yeah it was a great move
does he remember the Rook contest that's
a good move
sideways beaked
I look I haven't heard the Trident maybe
he said trident's foreign
I've never heard of sideways beaked
that's I can't the things that these
streamers say is like Sensational I I
the spawns are weird very weird Pawns
pretty weird they're pretty weird
he sees the fork
see if Kevin blunders this or keeps the
game going oh he did look at that good
move oh tonight tonight
does he see the night is hanging
[Music]
oh wow
good game if he plays King D2
freaking development
wow that was good
okay
the final piece is on the white pieces
that never go on the white pieces
ever
oh what is he doing
I could just do pawn up then right
sometimes I think he's just yeah he's
not really thinking about it like at all
it's not about not thinking he just
doesn't have much he can move he just
take take
huh
oh back to the fork oh he's he's crazy
too
one
yeah bro
killing you three four
this guy is not the uh not the xqc we've
seen in many other product Champs
his arrows are sharp his moves are
sharper
paper plate you got he's sideways beat
Danny yeah sideways beaked that's like
five head what will he do now with
Mega juicer I'm trying to I'm trying to
speak like I know what I'm talking about
I don't know it was good that was good
it was very convincing that was quite
okay cool yeah one of the other ones
his accuracy is 93 over 40 moves
do I go fancy nah no fanciness
he's on the black pieces too so it
doesn't matter
what snacking on these sideways
are very good you think oh well you
could just stick in this nah I'm good
brother
yeah
[Music]
talk so fast
dude he's he's on another level like
honestly like this is
Planet X let's let's hope we get a
stalemate just not just because I'm I'm
looking for some content I will back
protect my pieces
that's right
that's crazy
eat the pawn eat the pawn to guard the
horse
okay that's fine too what will he do
not much
only thing we look forward to now is a
potential stalemate
check
yep he's getting a little bit is he
gonna he doesn't see that he should
protect the pawn take he's gonna trade
okay
make sense good enough check yep or
check
check is good because I I get upon event
since he's probably gonna go he's
probably gonna go get on my pond but I
don't think it matters I don't think he
can um stop the Palm March anymore
yeah he can I haven't seen the twerking
hamster yet on the board I don't need to
take the pawn one of the things that his
stream has is a twerking hamster have
you seen that I have I have not I have
not
I feel like this is like golf commentary
over an xqc chess game this is
trying to stop he's gonna make a big
decision GG paper plate is what it is
man it is what it is paper plate
paper plates I already calculated it
okay
cool some paper plates
dude right
oh my God
I don't know that is Sensational I'm
happy to be seven in the pawns get got
an escort and it can't go back can't go
top can go sideways he's gotta go yeah
first of all that's pretty good I
haven't heard an English accent from you
of all the ones you bust out regularly
that's not that's not on the top of your
list no no that's kind of a sleeper one
I I don't do a great one I just kind of
if I whisper it it sounds good I mean
yeah I've noticed
if you have a UK accent it's just like
an English accent you
everything you say has more gravitas I
agree I agree you sound smart right
right it just makes it feel like the
moment matters more this is gonna lower
my accuracy chat
look at him
yeah go ahead no I was gonna say what's
this
is just weird
he's worried about stalemate um
they're okay that's not the twerk that's
something else
I wish I could wish I could twerk I wish
I could twerk half as good as the
hamster someone someone who's watching
his channel do the thing that makes the
hamster come on
what is it doing oh oh God Danny it's
speaking of which can we get in trouble
for reacting to content right now is
that like is that a you know are we
reacting to stillmate Stevens we're
reacting to him we're we're all we're
all good Steven plus I think xqc won
that part of the argument most people
agree oh there's the they're they're
watching there's the haters to look it's
the Torches
that is one of the look at that that's
one of the best things I've ever seen
right there
I like I said I'm gonna take lessons
from that hamster I haven't worked as I
haven't worked that well since the 90s
got it you know
you got it oh
the scariest moment for any chess player
find the stalemate for black for Life am
I doing it I'm not even paying attention
there's no way what am I doing there it
is he's gonna he's gonna get it done oh
oh
yeah just keep checking oh he's got a
king G7 Queen H6 made
sniper yeah boom boom wow wow
Donna
the accident won't be very good
the at the accuracy will not be very
good no problem I think
. he's so happy with himself and he
should be he gets another dub Levy again
I know I know the strongest players in
the field have not played xqc yet they
are your snaps your Sea Dogs maybe one
more they went home in ghastly but the
dude is playing well he's I mean it's
it's how it's how he's finishing these
games too Levy that uh that has me has
me impressed with Felix's chess
yes on the other hand I'm going to take
I'm going to take the other approach
which is um
I feel like right now he's a little bit
like a UFC fighter and they they don't
want to throw him in there against the
Sea Dog yet like they they want him they
want him to get a little confidence a
little bit of momentum he's he's
definitely he's definitely got the
highest puzzle rating in the field but
he he's he is melting the opposition but
we need to see a super confident xqc if
he does make it to the semifinals this
match is not over but that was a very
convincing first who does he play in the
next round if he wins I haven't looked
at the bracket I didn't pay that much
attention when we had the championship
racket up earlier but
not that he's not that it's over yet he
still has to beat Papa plot but
the winner of this match I I I I don't
know and I don't want to say because
they I it was one way and then they
flipped it and then I I don't know but
he plays uh I think he might play Sea
Dog
okay that that's gonna be that'll be
tough well that's assuming Sea Dog beat
sapnap either way Frank the winner of
this match plays Frank see that's why I
didn't want to say anything
got it okay Franktown are you still
working with Frank what's that like over
there it you helping I'm like the
trainer that that calls every now and
then and he doesn't really call me like
I try to like you know he he's Danny
he's famous he's like the fourth most
popular person in England you know they
got KSI uh they got uh uh they got the
king
you know they got it at the Royal Family
yeah uh they got I don't know who else
they got over there they got they got
KSI they got the king maybe he's the
third most popular he's the he's right
now everybody wants him you know
that's wild they got Piers Morgan and
then Frank yeah
what about what about James Bond
age yeah Daniel Craig he was great in
the Glass Onion that was that was a fun
movie that was a great movie but which
one the first one or the second oh the
side the Glass Onion is the second one
that's right Knives Out Glass Onion yeah
did you see the first one the first
night no no I I didn't know I just was
scrolling on my Netflix and I saw it it
was better I recommend I recommend
seeing the first Knives Out
have you watched White Lotus
I have good show do you like season one
or two more
uh Hawaii or Sicily probably I like
season one more they were both good
though
okay
uh yeah a lot of people like season one
more but I I like I like season two a
lot
um
I I we have a game speaking of something
yeah we got a game we have liftoff
pop a plot with white I'm gonna I'm
gonna guess that we've been
overestimating Felix's path to the next
round let's see what let's see what
Kevin can do with the white pieces I
think he's I think he's gonna because
again Levy you take back Bishop H4
and papa plop played great last yeah
honestly yep yeah he it was just one of
those mistakes where there was
absolutely nothing you could do after it
uh yeah I don't know it was like
injuring yourself in a sport that was it
that he had no chance after that uh but
you know I will see we have an Italian I
I'm really worried about what xuc is
thinking about I I get very nervous when
these players start thinking on move
three right well I I think if I had to
guess he's worried about the fried liver
right he knows if he plays Knight F6 he
has to because that's what most of them
are worried about at this level anyway
if we want to highlight what that is
Knight F6 Knight G5 is the is the worry
that a lot of them have so I wouldn't be
surprised if you see like an H6 Levy
just something to avoid that by by this
level
yeah I could
that's that's
kind of what I was thinking right I mean
let's
let's obvious that's a very not good
move because you weakened your light
squares forever more but that's what
happens when they face the Italian they
get nervous about Knight G5
yeah I mean my goodness
um
F6 is definitely not a move but now
they're in a brand new territory yeah
they're in uh
they're in whatever this is they're in
the uh the langel variation of the of
the Italian opening
whatever it is yeah the chess.com
opening book Let's listen into Papa plot
just one because I want to see arcade
mode I love I love it two I want to see
if he realizes how good his position is
because okay if you find C3 Levy does he
play Queen
it's foreign
he just said Levy's wrong Checkers is a
great name for a burger restaurant
in German
okay
oh a move oh
fuckenson
Victorious
the stream seems back
all right keep developing we still got a
game going we I mean
the foreign
and the internet
the Tale As Old As Time
bam boom bam boom bam
bam boom bam
okay
looking good
again I just love arcade mode I'm like a
kid in candy store right now
we should lose
okay
in trouble
oh he sees it oh I'm gonna die him but
yeah
set it up set it up cover the Escape
score with the Knight or the queen and
then before X will never see it coming
yeah
agreed down yeah
look at that oh
oh that's nothing oh that's a cheeky
little move
he's not gonna see it he's gonna there's
no way the only move now for black is
Pawn to be six no way
you'll see it I agree
you even no Queen A4 doesn't work yeah
because C6 and the queen guards it but
he didn't see it suck oh huge
this is it oh it's already on the board
he played B4 oh Levy amazing we could
have we could have tiebreakers here pop
a plot with the white pieces that's
amazing wow yeah from the top rope and I
mean he he you know why he got all of
that he got all of that because he took
on G8 I have no evidence of that
whatsoever but the Knight is just
stopped yeah
well again this has been a bad game for
for X from the start for those who
aren't uh
who uh calling it like they see it F6
was a bad move and papa plot is in
control
yep he takes the Knight and now now he
has the same situation that xqc had but
the difference in my opinion is that
White's Knight Advantage here isn't as
easy to convert because the position is
so asymmetrical last game it was
completely symmetrical this game
xqc could go here he could do something
on the B file he could
I don't know but it's not as easy okay
that I'm not crazy about that move
though because that's making it more
symmetrical
yeah and those are bad poems the big
thing I want to come back to is that
King for xcc because you highlighted it
earlier Levy I mean queen H5 check is
just staring you in the face right now
like this game could fall apart fast for
black
uh and by the way it's on the board
yep
amazing Queen H5 is an excellent move
I think Felix is about to suffer his
first loss in pogchamps five boys and
girls buckle up we're headed to overtime
I'm calling it
come on I always want to do some
dramatic when I call it Levy like I want
to look for something to drop calling it
just take something and just throw it
just yeah
just throw it
yeah there you go
doing it going to overtime
the craziest thing is Danny I'm looking
at this there's not much he can do all
his pieces are stuck on the back rank
his position has uh seven pawns out of
eight
on on dark squares and he's gonna lose
the only Pawn that's a light squared
Pawn I mean he has a nightmare position
for a night to take advantage of that
night's gonna get there or there or
there
or there
it's gonna be real bad for black
speaking of checkers all those pawns on
dark squares not feeling too hot the uh
the board game that nobody plays anymore
all right let's see what Felix is
talking about because this is about to
be his first real negative experience in
fog Champs
wait that's actually a good move what
the fudge is going on on
um up yeah
agree oh my God
what in the actual fudge
move take
the only chance he has as a Checkmate
down the H file which could happen
because it's POG Champs oh my goodness
I like that premonition right there
well POG Champs prediction
if I take
oh no take
came forward
Queen tape he's in trouble man also look
at the clock I don't know how much of
that he lost on disconnect Levy but this
is this is not good
no no it's not this happens
wait
no I can't do that
the emote
he sees your idea at least at least he
sees that he needs to protect the G7
phone before working wait a minute
King sideways check
I thought this was music from Papa
Plata's stream and then I realized that
it's X's music
it's amazing honest I'm just hearing
music and I need like medical attention
there is music right
stuck in a wait something just happened
behind us you see like a door fell I
could just I'm sensing
I I don't know I'm I'm having a good
time there's a giraffe in the background
that's pretty cool there's a giraffe but
that door was previously closed now it's
like the top half of it has been opened
you notice that uh those are Papa
Plata's goons man they're he's got he's
taking on the whole uh the whole Squad
Rook Hape by the way on the board I
predicted this I I thought there could
be some problems here you know you got
to go back
and gotta go back
yeah apparently his door's been open the
whole time and I'm just an idiot just
FYI chat in case you're wondering all
right anyway
um
I like your idea Levy the pro but this
is one of the decisions you highlighted
before where like sometimes you lose a
piece and you've still got chances other
times you lose a piece and it's like
even worse than it like this is so hard
for black to coordinate okay G6 is a
good one but it also comes at the price
of weakening the F6 Pawn right so
there's
all kinds of problems here for x and
he's down to two minutes oh my god he
has like no time at all yeah
the only way that that white could mess
this up is if he just go if he just runs
head first into a wall basically and
just thinks that he's winning and then
accidentally loses loses the game uh
what a twist ending that would be by the
way if Papa plot takes this to Blitz
Blitz Anything Can Happen man these are
these are not professional chess players
right this isn't Hikaru Nakamura forcing
things into a blitz tiebreaker where he
knows he beats everyone
Levy this could be the end of a of a
really a really shocking POG Champs uh
campaign for xqc I love how we just went
from who is xuc playing in the final in
LA to pop up
D5 is
if okay we should probably listen to
Papa plot stream if he sees that it's
over yeah let's see that's it
let's see if Kevin finds Knight takes E5
that's that's a pretty fast
Rook D1 is brilliant by the way
if he sees that pin why doesn't he
see the other pin I was just gonna say
that
it's an incredible move
oh
great move
um
so 1 000 ELO move right there
yeah
almost okay it's not as good as Knights
C5 but it's almost better it shows he's
using all of his pieces seize the pin
this makes it makes it so hard to see
how xqc doesn't lose this
yeah I mean
as you see I I can see the reaction is
probably dumbfounded though he's like
what like I can't take the Knight he's
just pin my Pawn to my Queen that's
ridiculous and he's threatening to take
the pawn one
and he's down on time
look at it he's under a minute it's gone
red red means dead
I mean I just said that I see dead
people I see it I actually see I mean
Haley Joe Osmond what happened to your
career love you shout out
I I didn't understand the road
I just let you say all that I got no
idea what's going on
um D4 is not yeah yeah the the the pox
Champs commentary you did with Robert
Hess you guys kept reference it wasn't
Nickelback
oh yeah yeah that's right Nickelback
dude I wasn't even podcast what was it
it was um what was the last event I did
before POG Champs
Danny it was ridiculous because the
bullet Championship I know so much about
Nickelback like I had their albums
growing up I I was listening to you guys
I was like man I'm missing out on this
discussion I never got the Nickelback
slander too
they're not that bad of a band they're
not that bad of a band I never got it
they became a meme they became like uh
at least they're not Nickelback kind of
joke and I don't know why
schools
okay by the way he still doesn't if he
trades Queens xqc still has a chance
remember Levy he only has to draw like
this is not yeah that's not a good idea
don't drink this don't do it no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
that's super dangerous
even with low time Felix has a very good
chance to draw this game now I think
uh all right let's bring it back to the
analysis report to show why we don't
like that move in Chelsea we like to say
there's a good reason to trade
especially when you're winning but in
this case I would not have done this
because the attack was more powerful
than the other Concepts you have two
different concepts clashing and one
supersedes use your knight and your
queen get in here right Daniel show how
dumb that was show him 95 like show them
how quickly it's over I mean like if he
finds this move right yeah Knight E5
either this and then you can win the The
Rook if this you can win The Rook uh oh
this there's also a queen
and if this there's Queen E6 and I I
just assumed there was a Checkmate
somewhere here I mean you can just
um
yeah but this
now you gotta find Knight E5 check and
hope for this and then two different
forks and
this is a good oh oh Rook G4 Rook G4 in
here he's got it okay
no I feel like look at Felix he's he
didn't fall for that sorry go ahead no I
was gonna say oh but that's a great move
we'll pop a plot to play Rook F2
foreign
I love how you pointed out the competing
Concepts that is instructor for everyone
sometimes you want to trade when you're
winning but not when your opponent's
king is about to be checkmated so here
okay he does find him he does find it
Levy Papa plot converting converting
yeah we said it wasn't a great idea but
if he manages to get it done then he
will have the last laugh but does he
know the the winning kind of idea here
use the d-pawn as a battering ram get in
attack this or is he gonna get lost in
the weeds wow
what wow does he take with the Knight
because it's a check yes he does he does
now it's still okay for black or you
know it's losing for black but not not
clear
oh totally not clear Knight E4 you gotta
find Rook D6
like is he gonna go yes he he's then
there's like back rank problems with the
king is always safe that's the good
thing the king is always safe on G2
the other thing is the Knight is like
accidentally or purposely depending on
Papa plot's point of view look at that
it owns E8 you were look at that we
should complete each other's
uh sandwich what is your favorites what
is your favorite sandwich by the way
like are you a PB J kind of guy no I'll
tell you right now I'll tell you right
now outside right now first of all like
sometimes I'm in the mood for a
beautiful Cheesesteak right everybody's
gotta like like you gotta eat a nice
Cheesesteak sometimes right but
if I go to like a
oh they've made us talk about the job
this is why I was the top YouTuber
Cheesesteak I didn't even think
cheesesteaks were sandwiches Levy you're
a genius of course that cheese steak is
the best sandwich but that's not that's
okay well let's talk about this then
we'll talk about sandwiches I feel bad I
don't want him to go back and look at it
we're talking about sandwiches I feel
like that's pretty disrespectful
but yes uh cheesesteaks are unironically
busting as the kids say Yes
um A4 uh
is coming next and I I just think he's
gonna push the pawns
he's doing good and and next you see is
down to seconds on the clock look at
that 20 20 seconds
yeah and he just doesn't have a lot of
pieces the only chance he has is to
somehow push his Pawn to F3 and
Checkmate but it's just never gonna
happen
yeah
like x2c's next move is going to be F4
he's all in
gambling
yeah I mean
Apple Plaza should just say he shouldn't
push he should not push
he should take should take because it's
free so he's ignoring it which I don't
like
yeah okay I agree his nerves are showing
oh don't go
to H2 you're gonna get yourself mated I
don't even know how like he's still it's
not possible but it might happen
that one's not right but that's all it's
like Sudoku it's all covered so just go
King H2 yeah
yeah worked out
yeah I say we go listen to Felix soon
here get some get some English streaming
not that I don't love guessing what
Kevin's saying in German but yeah does
does Felix see a comeback at all there
there are ladder mate comebacks there
there's uh H file made comebacks xqc is
laser focused he is laser focused right
now okay we're about to pull up his
stream
but he is running out of time
yep
but Danny he might win both pawns Pawn
takes pawn and then he gets the whole
pawns I can still win it
yeah he's not even thinking about saving
it he wants to win it gives me a lot of
options
I could have just checked back I could
just check wait a second
right there
right
you didn't have them
he said he needs to take the eight point
don't go for the checkmate
check
the pawn no good okay he gives a check
this is crazy is he gonna get is he
gonna get distracted by the mate leather
or is he gonna take the pawns no no I
think he's I don't know I think he's
gonna try to mate him not realizing he
has no mate
or maybe maybe the god gamer will clutch
it out
oh he's got 15 seconds to make a
decision he's looking he's trying to get
in
what's he gonna do
10 seconds oh
wow he does play The Right Move
it's crazy oh my gosh it was funny that
was the right move yes he's saying sorry
but that was it that's it he's gonna
stop the pawn Danny 13 seconds
that's insane all he needs is a draw
[Music]
you're saying he's stressed yet but he's
he's clutching it if he draws this game
that's it he moves on
oh my goodness uh Papa Plata has no way
to guard the pawn
you can't move this guy right here at
all if he moves this if he moves this
rock it's GD for him
he can't do it
yeah papa platter now just has to go for
eggs
wait who am I talking to he's done
I got him
no no
I don't care
I got him
oh my God if you're watching X's if
you're watching sqc stream I could use
the guy in the Hawaiian shirts working
again give that to me along with the
hamster I gotta see that again oh
which is so good for me this is Levy
yeah it's crazy this is crazy yeah he's
doing it he's clutching it
oh my goodness
[Music]
my Rooks are so powerful by now he's
plus three my Rooks are so powerful
wow Rook F7 is a crazy move because he's
abandoning his King wait oh
he could walk his King to G4 and get
mated
[Music]
this is crazy
oh my goodness what a comeback
by the way pop a plot now almost under a
minute oh he is so nervous papa plaza
he's Frozen on his stream he's
calculating and
it popped up lots and moves top left
with the King he loses if he goes to the
middle he's still may be winning huge
moment 50 50. oh no what's he
calculating oh he sees it the wrong way
oh wow
guard The Rook insane he saw that wow he
might win the game now he might win the
game yeah xqc's all in on the mating net
that's not there
yep
he's winning he's going to run as king
all right we've gone back to excuses
right there yep it's crazy they're both
under a minute Danny
dude the drama the drama is real if xqc
draws he knocks out Papa plot if Papa
plot wins we go to overtime everyone
no no
oh now he can make a queen that's fine
whatever oh
my God he didn't see it
he's foldable Last Chance Danny's
stalemate It's Not Over
you're right it's not over oh it's mate
Ricochet was mate in one oh it still
made one right now
excuses mated rookie Checkmate on the
board right now oh he's missing oh he's
winning his Rook oh
but dude it's not over as long as he's
alive there's a chance for stalemate Yep
this is like freaking heart attack
territory yeah cause the Knight is
covering some weird squares too he's
gotta like do this in a way where he's
gonna seal it yeah that's it right there
right there put it down on F1 it's a
ladder make just Rooks give
he's so nervous
oh my God he's so nervous
oh my God oh my God Danny I can't but
he's on it he's got it he's got a skater
he's ice skating the ice skater
he's done it
he has done it borderline pre-move he's
not gonna do it he's that nervous yep
oh my goodness
this is the outside of strength
Excellence
thought I haven't already type bro
oh God I saw it
again Sticky
the BM from xqc oh my god oh my god
wow he's just gonna let his time run out
oh my god well oh he doesn't want his
opponent to feel the glory of checkmate
could be
wow all right ladies and gentlemen I am
highly good schweiser
wow
Levy we have overtime we have tie
Breakers that was absolutely Wild
I don't even know what to say
The Unbelievable clutch play from from
Papa Plata who who earned it he earned
it this game he he trapped X's knight uh
he he did his best in converting and
dude X's come back from Hit 50 seconds
versus seven minutes and there was a
draw on the board and he was just not
able to convert it at the end with seven
seconds on the clock what a matchup and
now they got now they got to play some
blades yeah
wow all right let's remind everybody the
format we'll continue to break that down
we're moving on to Blitz boys and girls
three minutes plus five seconds per move
this is like coin flip Chess at this
point whether xqc was the favorite or
not anything could happen in Blitz of
course if we're still tied after one
game we will swap colors and play again
and until we have a winner remember the
more accurate chess player from the
first two games will get white in the
first game we're gonna find out who that
is in a second but Levy back to that
point I agree with you papa plot earned
it but X you see right there at the end
he if he takes the A7 Pawn we're talking
about him already getting one step
closer to LA
yeah and let's not let's not forget he
also lost like four minutes of time
disconnecting so
but I think already by then it was it
was a tough position I actually no it
wasn't it was right before he blundered
so he he made a mistake right at that
moment where his computer had crashed
yeah it's not even an excuse it's a
really legitimate concern I mean you
know it's very distracting when you have
to play uh xqc gets white by the way for
everybody uh he had a ridiculous
accuracy in the first game yeah uh and
now it looks like we have a
for a night's thing ish they're just
playing fast they're just playing fast
both players are going to be super
nervous making the kind of Trades you
don't want to make bringing the queen
out for black but okay like you said I
mean it's not excuses for Felix because
it doesn't matter we're here in overtime
but he did have a disconnect he's got to
shake it off and focus and uh pop a plot
this is it he could send the uh the
highest viewed human on Twitch that
being Felix he could send him home
yeah the most famous chess player of all
time that's right XGC is probably the
most famous person to ever play chess
like
that's probably I don't know that's
actually a wild thing to say
because it weirdly true okay
um it could be like Messi or Ronaldo I
guess if they actually played it right
like if Messi actually played chess then
yeah it would be messy uh but we don't
know if they actually did I mean they
just took the photo and then it turned
out that it wasn't a real photo so yeah
uh Bishop D4 you got to take this you
got to take this guy you gotta take it
move your knight to safety
we got a lot of equal chests here still
nothing nothing huge for either player
pop a plot up by 20 seconds though
that's what I'm noticing
yeah
Knight takes D4 he is playing so fast
he's got over three minutes he has three
minutes and 20 seconds he gets five
seconds bonus for every move
and Danny I I don't mind this position
at all I think he's doing extremely well
here agreed he's playing fast he's
riding the momentum riding the high of
already having forced overtime I always
think it favors the person who won to
force overtime Levy not sure if you
agree with that but I feel like in the
game of momentum Papa plot is preferred
here
ah good question yeah I mean out of the
game I I it's tough to say maybe a
little bit but it also matters who wins
better with what color yeah so we we've
seen if you're dominant with white then
it suits you better to play White in the
Blitz
um Knight D5 by the way I I mean he
should just take that and
take that double the pawns you got a
good night in the center he does he
takes it
he laughs I don't know what he's
laughing about looks down don't know
what he's grabbing
they are locked in and the problem with
this position is they have eight pawns
each it's very difficult to make
decisions when you have eight pawns on
the board because you're just gonna push
a wrong Pawn you're gonna go like here
yep
right on cue all right let's take a look
at what Felix is saying
got to overcome that loss okay C3 is a
good move we'll see if he's getting some
momentum back no that doesn't matter
yes you see about to be a thousand rated
wow that actually
I don't know if that's true if he's been
there
there's more time it's okay
it's actually better not to trade the
Knight for the bishop here because the
bishop is so passive yeah
we'll see if Papa plot keeps the Knight
on the board that would be that would be
a good sign for the German fans oh wow
he does
that's crazy what a move the queen and
Knight are a dynamic duo over there it's
dangerous for xqc that sounds pretty
good right
that'd be a good move
pretty good
did he say I didn't hear
am I losing my mind
I'm leading it as ever as if it'll make
me hear better in my headphones
foreign
yeah pushing was the better move but
this is fine it's equal
the queen
take with the queen not the pawn
oh that's what you're cheering for push
take take yeah for a second I'm cheering
for the best move to be played by both
players on every move that's my that's
what I'm cheering for we are good wait a
minute we are good we this is solid this
is solid
does he see on passo wait what
a big moment does the French Canadian
see the own passion
okay or does he put the queen on a for
free Square botes give it take
you see I'm not a big fan of this oh
he's not even considering it
oh that's tragic
wait yeah he doesn't see it
wasting a lot of time here it's that
very very very very valuable right now
shout out to Papa plot for playing so
fast by the way
do you think that's nerves or that's uh
he's just trying to assert dominance I
don't know but I don't what matters is
he's up on the clock here I should have
thought that much
he's right he shouldn't have opened up
the file
that's a great move man oh my God
dude there's the guy in the Hawaiian
shirt guy's working on B1 sorry got
distracted
it takes he just said he didn't want to
take but then he told but then we just
passed one
he does have a pass deep one nah
he's got his feet up though
that's not a bad move I open myself up
for her back crank though
it's a good game but I'm low on time
this isn't like watching Hikaru Magnus
where we expect things
could do anything right now would be a
good moment to push the H Pawn so you
never get checkmated
good move keeping the tension yep
yep
somebody's got to free a back rank here
or someone else is going to get mated
I'm like giving me anxiety it's like
watching your kids wrestling no one's
about to get hurt someone's about to get
hurt
wow this is crazy it's actually going to
push us deep on just invest in deep on
Industries D6 there it is somebody free
your back rig please
someone is about to hit their head on
the couch kids are wrestling please free
your back range I'm freaking out as a
chest Dad I'll put the rook in front of
the pawn first and then do it
oh Danny it's gonna be like Rook d8
rookie one and then it's just gonna be a
mate it's gonna be a backbreak made on
E8 that decides POG Champs in this match
yep
bye bye
time even by the way we're back to even
yep a minute five each buck 50.
oh that's a good move wow that is a good
move centralize the queen for white Rook
D1 or queen D5 don't go there don't go
there because there's no mate there's no
mate at the end there's Queen f8 and and
accident no
no Stakes takes and he's not getting
mated Danny he's gonna he's gonna miss
it and then he's gonna block mate
oh my God possible checkmates
oh my God he's singing the wrong way
he's singing the wrong way don't do it
don't do it
oh no okay now we got some Pantry Queens
don't trade Queens you can't trade
Queens if xqc trades Queens he might not
even make it out of the quarterfinals oh
no this is Nazi's losing it's just math
easy losing it's just math it's six
pawns versus five they just gotta bring
their kings up and black is completely
winning
A4 is winning Pawn takes pawn and A4 and
it's just a square you're outside of the
square oh God
foreign
I was just gonna say Danny and even if
you do take the pawn is a decoy and your
King has to go take White's pawns but do
they know all of that
I'm I'm having anxiety just watching
this Kingdom Pawn ending again what is
going on here
now Papa Plata has to clutch it Danny he
has to completely forget about his Pawn
here and he has to go King E6 King F5
which which you can do you can do he's
smart enough to go he's gonna go get
this Pawn I'm gonna go get this Pawn
yeah but
yeah
ah we'll go check it out we'll go check
it out
what what no no he has to bring his King
he's got to stop using his Pawns oh my
God no no no no don't play your pawn
move
oh wait he already did it we saw it he
did he did he did he did he did he has
to bring his King he has to bring his
King
oh oh no no put the pawn down
oh he sees it oh my God he's gonna do it
he's gonna bring his King to the base of
whites Pawn chain and he's gonna just
bring what no
oh no that was the one move that draws
oh God he couldn't make up his mind now
excuse he's getting back in time to stop
White's King from infiltrating
it's almost impossible to lose it now
you just bring the king back you can't
even blunder it you could lose this with
black because you just because clearly
he's really nervous so he he might like
overextend any and then she'll he get
he's gonna get himself into which is a
German word and then he's going to lose
both of his pawns oh my God he actually
ironed the irony of Papa plot loses by
Zug swung over the irony by the way
that that gray bar means the table base
says it's a draw for those wondering on
the new feature that means this is a
drawn position with best play that's
what it means and table base is a is an
algorithm basically so chess is solved
with seven pieces on the borderless any
seven pieces on the board I think it
might be up to eight but it's like
thousands of terabytes of space
um
Danny this is this is losable for for
everybody involved but now it's like
King E5 and oh my God oh my God Danny oh
my God going the wrong way he's going
the wrong way this would be the ultimate
cause Champs game okay no okay no now
we're getting a trade xqc
dude they're both going the wrong way
they're both going they should have went
up and and yes this is still a draw oh
Levy if okay never mind if there's a
trade on G3 there was a chance Papa
could still win by getting the
opposition yeah King H3 oh my God
dude
everyone this is still a draw but we're
literally walking backward
s oh my God
oh my God that xqc's freaking out he's
like what all right let's go listen to
xqc see if he figures out that he might
have a winning chance let's do it yes
stalemate Stevens
still being stupid
if Papa Plata keeps going straight back
He will draw this game straight back
with the King when you're in front of
straight back just go straight back and
then follow the king wherever the King
goes you go King H6 meet the king lock
the pawn go straight back it's a draw
oh my God Danny he knows the defense wow
either that or he's accidentally
figuring it out doesn't matter
oh my God he did it that's the draw if
you go straight back you hold opposition
oh God but that but now XC is gonna
dance he's gonna dance there there and
back like will he keep oh no that's that
stuff isn't it move
block
move Summit
oh my God Danny the biggest moment of
the match right here King F5 will he go
straight back
yeah
straight back and it still drives uh
thinking isn't good thinking makes me
nervous he's thinking about king of
eight
okay move draw wow and actually King F6
King h8 is also a draw because of
stalemate
oh my God it's a drone no matter what
he has him it's Danny it doesn't even
matter both moves are a draw
unbelievable
you almost can't lose it as long as you
go straight back from the pawn no matter
what you're gonna get stalemated who's
there wow it was back to Hidden
yeah then if I move it I think he
realizes it
check
what a freaking wild game this has been
oh my gosh
wow
dude I still can't believe you played G3
oh my gosh heart attack
it's it is a draw
it's gonna be the last repetition I go
across
remember if the same position occurs
three times the server will
automatically declare it a draw so there
won't be any tomfoolery or trickery on
that level
I don't know what to do
there's nothing he can do it's not your
fault Felix it's not your fault
just like in uh uh Goodwill Hunting
that's right you knew it
hey hey lovey it's not your fault
no stop playing like this dude it's
weird
it's weird dude
move
it's weird
uh
uh more chess
more chests around the corner XGC is
still alive in POG Champs in shocking
fashion Papa plot had this game
unbelievable wow official draw
yeah
Wild
xuc is about to find out that he
actually got lucky
look at that look at that throw look at
that black is totally winning in the
middle of that game Arc and then it goes
the other way back to a draw we are tied
at one and a half games a piece
we already had this with Frank and gasly
this is the this is the year of double
overtime in pod Champs apparently
yeah double overtime is a lot of fun
uh except I don't know for the rest of
the schedule because uh everyone else is
waiting yeah everybody else is waiting I
mean listen when you when you plan when
you have to play in POG Champs uh you
you just have to
scrap everything else like all other
plans you have especially if you're the
fifth match of the day stop now but go
go go hang out you're gonna it's gonna
take a little while you're gonna be here
we have it the other way we've had
matches that are over in like what 10
minutes right you get some plungers so
this is high level chess you got to
applaud these guys obviously there's
been some wild blunders back and forth
but the fact that we're here means uh
we're deadlocked we're going to extra
chess 30 000 of you on Twitch just on
our channel here we got 8 000 of you on
YouTube thanks for being with us not
just for Levy's shirt oh hi hi Tyler
Tyler's watching Tyler I want to clear
up some clear up some of the air man I
know you're tuning in first of all
you've been grinding we've been watching
way to go
secondly it's not you it's me I just
don't like League okay we can work out
this relationship and thirdly I'm
actually rooting for you in the next
match so I hope you bring it Tyler and
um good talk there you go and and and I
I propose instead of playing Tyler in a
ten thousand dollar heads up chess match
because I'm I I'm I'm you know I got
enough money I'd love to do
a stream where he teaches me how to
weight lift and not be a noodle
pool boy
yeah it says real it's his full-time job
he's over 40 hours a week yeah wow
that's awesome
I guess that's how he keeps a good tan
right
I I think so well he'll be on later so
we'll okay we'll talk about it here we
go we're back to the Italian if xqc
plays the same blunder of F6 we are in
trouble
we are in trouble if we're if we're xqc
fans F6 is a bad move he already played
it once and pop a plot took him to the
cleaners
yeah oh Knight G oh I I didn't know if
if they if they knew about uh if they
knew about the fried liver but he looked
it up he looked it up maybe in the break
who knows and now he's no longer played
this bad F6 move
yeah this is definitely an improvement
uh and now castles D3 Bishop G5 is good
good beginner chess on display I would
say this is early intermediate chess for
sure by both sides I mean that end game
hold was really good high level uh high
level chess here
we knew this was going to be a good
match maybe not this good xqc's got an
itch scratching it scratching it himself
you know
take take I'm not a huge fan of giving
white just a free hand of two Bishops
but yep
all good the amount of times though in
pogchamps we've had a bishop on G5 Levy
and a white knight that could have gone
to D5 and they didn't play it right you
could you could you could build a house
with those bricks we need to show
everyone the trick of pinning the Knight
on F6 and putting a knight on D5
I mean not right now I'm just saying in
general yeah yeah right now D5 is a
great move to activate get the bishop
out
yep
also reversal of of what the last two
games have been for the first time in a
while xqc is up on the clock
big time yeah that's huge that's huge
blah blah has been playing super fast
confident
feels like
it feels like it's it's changing a
little bit fortunes were changing a bit
oh yeah
he just said I like Levy's shirt yeah
it's a nice shirt
I gotta turn on the air conditioner it's
way too hot in here I'm getting sweaty
looking at these games I'm too nervous
what's the bishop on B3
yeah what is X thinking about he's got
oh no that's not the right move
suck suck
that is definitely not the right whoa
Yep this is good for white now that's a
good move too I mean even if it lets
black take C3 that's a nice pin that's a
nice pin hey you it's a nice pin over
here
that oh there he hanged oh no
it's not
my Shuffle
all right let's remind everybody real
quick we are in tie breaks we are in tie
breaks right now which means we're in
Blitz we're actually in double tie
breaks if you're just tuning in Where
Have You Been we got Blitz if we're
still tied we're gonna keep rinse and
repeating but we still have four more
matches today Levy I just want to tell
everybody because we've got a lot of
viewers the day has only just begun
after this matchup I think we go right
to do we go right to cutie Cinderella
and Jenny or who goes up first who's
next
thank you producers there you go uh
Danny you keep calling him Sky Kuno oh
saikuno I'm sorry I don't re I don't
read the names that are in front of my
face I'm the anti one burgundy but but I
like it I I like the name Sky Kuno in
fact yeah
if we interview him I'm gonna ask him if
he wants to be Sky Kuno and yeah that
that that is a mismatched poor saikuno
yeah
by the way
uh
actually just just had a really great
position but he played B5 and gave the
C3 Pawn back and then just like that
we're back to the uh yeah if he had
played Knight D4 here this is just like
a fantastic position for black yeah
Bishop G4 is actually just even better
yeah yeah because that like this
position is not really minus four but
it's minus four for the computer because
it just immediately does this and then
it takes and opens up but uh yeah he
he's doing it now but uh and it's still
it's still a good move but
it was better before but now he has to
go Knight T2
and also he's back down he's back down
on the clock that's the one bad thing
here Felix is not managing his time well
in Blitz Papa plot doing the opposite
got 40 extra seconds
yep yeah xqc really really using the god
gamer strategy of getting the time as
low as possible just trying to be
exciting and dramatic but terrifying
yeah absolutely terrifying here and half
of us just got to make a move she's just
gotta go just just go
he's just not going you just have a
minute each now this is not moving
also there's a fork on E2 Levy highlight
it just so that just so the boys and
girls every girl that's uh that's a
working problem oh
oh oh it takes them this
oh but there's Knight D4 and that ends
the game that just ends the game because
White's king is too open
yeah
all right maybe let's let's go check out
Felix let's go see what he's talking
about if he sees Knight D4 we could be
over we could be heading home
all right let's check out Felix here
wait I get a nice secret here though
wait oh come on I gotta check it right
yeah bing bing he doesn't see it he's
not he doesn't see it Levy never mind oh
spoke to you soon
um
check
oh looks like he does see it now I think
that's better
right there oh man what am I doing
that's a move
there's a face down on the clock though
this isn't over
yep boy or check
wait no I I get possible mate here hold
up
check
move
across
uh I guess it only works if he goes
there right
this has been winning for black the page
you have to be subtle he's in the cage
he actually is though
you also have to play quickly okay
I think it's won the game
when he takes Pawn is over if he sees it
check he did
seven seconds oh my God yes I take the
pawn
okay oh he gives the pump a check no
oh no oh King H1
we have for his game over Queen F4 is
made Queen F4 is oh my god he has 13
seconds
oh my God
lovey hold me I know you can't but I'm
nervous
I'm so nervous you gotta move the king
out of the corner he has 40 seconds he
has to move his Queen out of
wow wow
sir
certified D juicer moment paper plate
eliminated it holy
wow wow
I don't know if Felix knows how much he
got away with one there but he was he
his back was literally against the wall
ladies and gentlemen should have gone
home in the last game
holds on and somehow is still surviving
in POG Champs 5.
that that was that was unbelievable he
he just held his nerves better he was he
was just Danny he was mathematically
eliminated he had Five Pawns versus six
that's all that was remaining at the end
of that first tiebreak game and he
clutched it defended himself
and not only did he save it he he won
and he's our he's a championship
semi-finalist now wow that was a double
overtime Thriller if you missed it you
where have you been we have xqc taken on
Frank now in the next round our first
semi-finals matchup is clear and I I
literally this this should have been
Papa plot there well it doesn't matter
it's Felix all I know is that was wild
and we still have a lot of Chess ahead
with four more matches to go Levy I'm
being told that we're gonna skip the
interview because we're already we're
already way behind schedule and we got a
whole bunch of creators who uh who uh
who are trying to hold us to it so we
start the next round
um yeah here it is there it is there it
is what a uh
is that a slow-mo what a slow-mo what a
giraffe in the background what a bunch
of skateboards
um unfortunately what a Pog Champs five
Papa plot had but he is going home we
are going to be right back in just a few
moments don't go anywhere four more
matches to go on this epic Monday for
podcast five
thank you
[Music]
let's go this right here is how I use
chessable and why I've been using it for
a long time I mean if you look up here
I've actually have my streak it says
1231 days right you're gonna forget a
lot of the things that are in the book
Jessica came around when I got on
adjustable it's literally I was already
doing that so this is now a game changer
because I can do it faster it's online
it's in front of me all of my books are
here if they're going to be folders now
so I can categorize my white black and
all tactics in-game but I literally have
everything in one area as you see I'm
scrolling here this is what I like to so
they're like how many testable books you
got I'm like all of them how are you
stressable is actually I do a lot for
the opening training I do tactics on
here I do calculation I do in-game I do
everything but the database all my
training on here all the time adjustable
is the wave this is why I like to use
child support actually helped me I
remember even online I was only like
tapping out at 23.50 almost 2400 and and
Blitz and bullet my chest com is 26 with
a high of 27.74 on bullet and I blame
all of this like success really is just
working on chessable just being honest
with you
because he still has really good chances
what oh no a full blunder
oh my gosh she just resigned Hikaru we
got a resignation it's going to the tie
break
take the pawn oh boy it's the winner he
won by the dirty flag the question is
does hafu take the Grand Master approach
here and just take the Perpetual for the
championship doesn't matter
we gotta listen and she's about to
deliver the goods
[Music]
hard work pays off but now King oh you
know
possible
[Music]
holy let's go
this hour
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone this is your daily dose
of Internet how
how dude I feel bad what's good Turtle
Squad it's your boy
[Music]
[Applause]
I would lose my mind are you
kidding me I don't understand this
goddamn game I don't get it oh baby I'm
playing chess
he has to move his brown man whoa whoa
you could do that I can't move your
crown man like that holy
is relieving leaving I saw the stalemate
I really saw him stay on it
now
hog Champs 5 continues Levy I don't know
what we're gonna do in this day we're
we're already a couple hours in we still
got four more matches to go we've had a
double overtime Thriller between X UC
and papa plot you bring your caffeine
are you ready for the rest of the day
yeah it just crossed that threshold
where if I drink another espresso to
make it through the show I won't sleep
so I got a nice little refreshing
coconut water here I got the emotional
support of my dog uh and I'm ready to go
these guys set a really high bar Danny I
don't know if we're gonna have another
double overtime but we'd better have we
better have some more bang and chess
yeah well we moved down to the
constellation bracket for our next two
matchups I think we both see virtual as
a big favorite over saikuno I will try
to say the name right but again Sky Kuno
would have been better we're gonna talk
about that and then we've got cutie
versus Ginny uh both of these matchups
in my opinion have a clear favorite
um but we'll see we'll see if psychuno
and Jenny can uh can prove prove us
wrong in the underdog spot there and uh
your thoughts on what they need to do
lovey
well it's tough because cutie very well
could be in the championship bracket uh
she uh she's a she's as good of a player
as the other two individuals that made
it out of group d uh and Ginny and
saikuno are on the are on the newer side
in fact Ginny I think is like was
literally Googling how to play chess
better before her next before her last
match yeah so Danny I just hope she's
gotten to practicing yeah well we've
been offering coaching I know Andrea has
I have I've covered I think
um I covered at least two of her matches
so far so we hope Jenny has a decent
experience here she gets four grand even
if she gets knocked out and sent home so
that she's got that going forward and
saikuno also pretty new to chess right
he played the bomb Cloud Levy I don't
know if you saw it where he Googled he
Googled and saw a Hikaru Speed Run where
Hikaru got it to 3000 with the bond
Cloud but no one gave him the tip that
that's because he's Hikaru not because
he played the bonecloud
yeah and that's the chassis elitists of
the world think that modern day chess
education on YouTube is flawed and is
failing our young audiences worldwide
because you know Danny one day you go to
chess YouTube and the next day you're
ripping you're ripping the bottle Cloud
yeah there you go
um both of them playing in their first
ball champs as you can see but a big
disparity in raiding there we know that
virtual has been working with Anna
krambling as Levy said at the top of the
show he's the highest rated player in
the entire consolation bracket
and uh saikuno is uh yet to get his
first step we hope he does we hope he
does but we we also know he's going up
against a tough opponent with a great
background that is a scene I'm told
taken directly from the movie Bambi just
before things get dark
I yeah can we just address the fact that
there's somebody who's 50 points lower
rated than Sea Dog in the consolation
bracket
yeah how did that happen
how does that happen
yeah I agree
I agree I agree virtual is clearly a
happy favorite saikuno streaming though
saikuno is streaming on YouTube that's
awesome I think that's the first time
he's been streaming most of the time
he's been on Zoom so shout out I'm gonna
go to there I'm gonna go to youtube.com
forward slash Sky Kuno I misspelled
right Psy Kuno
he is live getting smoked in chess
that's his title that's a stream title
okay that wasn't you I love it no it
says getting smoked in chess
um he's not smoking while playing chess
he's getting smoked in chess I the all
both activities both activities are
acceptable depending on where you are in
the world and how old you are you know
what I mean I mean anyway yeah
I think he's easily five six hundred
uh I actually think he has a chance but
he does have a tendency to just sort of
play 10 or 15 moves and then just sort
of quit on himself which I really hope
he doesn't do today uh because virtual
has a lot to prove I think if you run
back virtual's matchups Danny in the
group stage like I think he wins half of
them I mean I really just think he got a
bad break uh twice oh Mike virtual is
going for Scholars mate
come on saikuno punish him not because
I'm rooting for saikuno over virtual but
I'm but I I always wanted to be fun
don't play G6 ready don't let it stab it
stop doing what you're doing
okay that's a Gambit that's actually a
tricky Line This is the best move but
according to the computer black is
totally okay
as long as you play Bishop E7 don't
trade Queens Play Bishop E7 and you
actually get it maybe show them why
levia Bishop E7 black gets castled and
the e-file is is the reason the computer
says it's equal yep yep you have the
best line is Bishop E7 and for White 2
voluntarily walk to F4 to get out of the
way of the night which nobody is going
to do
uh because if you play something like
Bishop C4 uh black will go here and and
and and okay I can't trial moves and
then D5 is pretty vicious but we have
Queen E7
um now that's not a good move Danny
because you don't want to trade the
Queens uh when you're down upon yep
so shame on Virtual for playing for the
scholars mate but it looks like it's
working out
yeah I don't think this is what Anna
kramling taught him I saw a conspiracy
theory in the chat that said he threw in
the con uh Championship bracket because
he knew that he would win the
consolation he would get a free trip to
Los Angeles should we just make him pay
for his plane ticket that's a really
great idea especially because he's
coming from Norway I'm not sure we
budgeted him for that so virtual twist
ending you have to pay for half your
ticket to La yeah yeah
and and it's got to be business class so
yeah that's right you're not even
allowed to go economy you're paying for
half the ticket in his business class
that meets our budget
yeah hey Danny can I ask you a question
yeah
well what's the deal with airport
lounges I was in one for the first time
in my life and and they're full like
they're not they were supposed to be the
food is awful
I don't know man overhyped it's one of
the most overrated perks right you have
to stand in line now the line and then
they like they create all kinds of
levels of elite status so that you don't
even get in yeah when you get in the
food's bad
the Wi-Fi sucks
can someone clip this and send it
directly to Delta it's ridiculous like
like I thought I gotta you know I
thought I got a good credit card I walk
up there's 30 people in a line that paid
for the first class ticket on the plane
I mean and they're getting in first
I I don't know I have to spend eight
thousand dollars on a plane ticket I'm
just I'm going to like you know
Florida or something I don't anyway
um yeah Cyclone still doesn't have an
epon by the way uh can we can I add one
wait can I can I emote a Pawn on the
board that's a great idea look at maybe
there's a way
maybe there's a way to give back a pawn
I'll put you there you're his epon now
that was you right that was me that's
the Danny OMG face which I love I'd love
to say that was acting but it's not I
just typically suffer from PTSD every
time I see blunders and I freak out all
right okay let's get back to the Chester
because actually despite the blunder as
you're showing he's doing okay saikuno
is doing okay here we'll see how he
deals with this just kind of take with a
knight that's not a good move here
virtual
first we're not going to win no bracket
playing Bishop to D5 just giving up the
bishop like that for the night uh I
think we're gonna check in on saikuno
though and see yeah let's see what is
that what he thinks about airport
lounges well he flies private I mean
let's be serious you know these La boats
anyway
um
oh good move I like that
horse attack it is gonna horse attack it
and then I double juice you're doing
great man
but not
completely what is a Psy Kuno um what is
that
okay and now
for the important part a name like what
even is it a
how do we get rid of this bro this guy's
kind of annoying okay uh
I heard a great story about sapnap
okay
sapnap wanted to name himself sadnab
because it's pandas spelled backward but
the username was taken so he replaced
um the D with a p and here we have
sapnap that is that is
a very catchy very cashy you haven't
lost yet very very good I like it it
Rhymes I mean this this one game has
already gone on longer than my past two
games combined so that's not true no it
is true is it true no it is true
well maybe it hasn't gone on longer but
he's in a much better spot Levy this is
this is an improved saikuno I'm not just
saying that you know for the feel-good
story he's playing he's playing much
better Chef I'll just copy him again
just move another Pawn just move up a
little punt oh
I didn't realize that he lost he said
this this match last thing
was if he didn't block it I could go for
it for this all the way to there but
it's like a Defender how do I get rid of
the arrow how do I get rid of the Arrow
does anyone know Jesus
uh okay I'm just gonna hope it goes away
next round uh what is he trying to do
guard your Pawn just
um
thank God thank God it just went away on
its own okay
whoo
okay
first of all where has this bit All pod
Champion now a man he wasn't streaming
this is entertaining stuff
that's why he got the contract I mean
he's a he's a fun guy so here's what I'm
thinking
I have two options sort of
also I am so jealous of all these
people's microphones Knight D7 is a
great move it's just the worst move I
don't think so I think this is fine so
this is it's a great one how can we
can't get you one of those cool setups
where you pull the mic in like Ludwig
and yell boys how come we can't do that
because because I'm lazy I'm a creature
of habit Danny I can I tell you
something doing man he's doing something
I built off oh we took a pawns like it's
not even
psychuno is balling right now let's go
dosaiku knows about a beat virtual this
is nuts I mean it just dies
get rid of the arrow no one taught me
what but I have to do it now to get rid
of it this man doesn't even know how to
use the interface and he's cooking this
man is cooking he doesn't even know how
to turn the stove on and he's cooking
this is turning into the greatest day of
all time
Levy tell me how lazy you are oh wait by
the way stand yeah go ahead no no I was
I was just saying was minus one
according to the Eva like like night
before just wins a clean Pawn it's a
fork uh what I was gonna say is I built
a PC a year ago it's right here I
haven't changed PCS like I'm waiting for
this PC to die Danny I am a creature of
habit this microphone has been with me
for five years
all right I should get the Shure sm7
whatever and I should yell boys and and
I should sound as good as saikuno but I
don't want to all right because it's
going to lose the charm so uh I'm with
you man I totally get it and I'm like
I'm the guy he played Knight before Oh
my God
has a 20 uh 20 moves 81 accuracy and he
is beating virtual
how is this happening right now saikuno
where have you been you're 10x better
when you stream dude oh my this is this
this man is Unstoppable virtual
disrespected the boy he he he tried to
he tried to Scholars made him this is
like coming out to a boxing match with
his back turn to his opponent and this
man is gonna pay for it now Danny let's
not forget there is still a lot of Chess
to be played and this could have a very
tragic ending but I'm hype I like what
we're seeing
foreign I'm with you on every possible
level I was so nervous this was going to
be a route and saikuno was going to
leave with a bad POG Champs experience
but he might get his first dub right now
let's uh who want to listen to we can
listen into virtual or psychuno here we
go we're back to side I'd like to think
that means we're doing well
oh my God but then he's gonna win two
pawns Knight takes pawn and pawn six
Pawn okay
okay what's our next move what's what
are we winning no we're tired we're tied
right now
I didn't plan for that now what do we do
wait can't we just go here is this like
is safe or is this unsafe
I'm gonna blindly do it I don't know man
I've seen I sense no danger here I'm
thinking is this man's aesthetic like is
his charm pretending not to not know
what he's doing ever because he clearly
knows what he's doing dude this is this
is a much stronger play I know he's been
practicing so that's great but this is
an absolutely much stronger player than
we've seen in POG chips okay he's not
now he's making the first mistake he's
made in a while you're gonna take the
pawn he loses the position
I'll kill it
okay I killed it and then it's just even
but now this Pawn is fresh again
okay let's think let's think we have to
do this right I think
dude can we have to do this wow that's
fine that's fine this is so good this is
probably just gonna move this Pawn here
and we've just got to figure out a good
spot to put this little horse in this
man is not 100 get out of here with that
crap this man is not a hundred This Is A
Lie he probably has three burner
accounts I'm calling it right now this
is a nonsense
all this I don't know what I'm doing I
don't know how to undo the arrows he's
not fooling me Danny all right this man
is a 2 000 rated player sneaking into a
consolation bracket I'm done
um
okay which oh the question is
will white see that he can actually take
this Pawn because there is no back range
that's all he does okay
um there's no mate he's got a
so if I move my equal my duty up there
then and he's dead don't don't do that
um
I mean this ain't the worst move now is
it
the force them to move a little bit
I mean not the worst move I think
Levy I know this isn't the best chest
that he was playing but he's still in a
great spot this is yeah this is an
awesome game so here's the thing he
can't kill my horses because of my Fork
which means
honestly I don't know what to do now
like what's left
I feel like if I move any of these my
dude gets smoked so this is just such a
strange the opposite of my dude gets
smoked actually if he doesn't move one
of those his dude will get smoked
okay I have a bad feeling he's about to
move the Rook off the back rank I have a
really bad feeling yep that he's about
okay okay oh no crazy I'm crazy I tell
you I'm crazy oh my God
so here's what I'm thinking with this
if he trades this oh I'm an idiot
okay I I really thought he'd go for that
I think we lose now
um hey we live longer guys pretty close
game but that's a win
you were losing
myself I'm
so wow that
that was unbelievable
I'm sorry coach dude but it's a win okay
but saikuno I mean that's impressive
he does not play like a 100 ELO player
he didn't know the Wayward Queen which
is why I played it
and it is a lead but like
that was a very resilient defense okay
maybe this was a bit
like look at this star move star move
star move star move star move like five
in a row it's four on the eval for black
but then I finally got some counter play
like that's crazy he said he played like
a 700.
dude
to say the wheels came off there for
black would be under understanding that
went from one of the best games we've
seen by anybody in the event for saikuno
to checkmating himself in two moves
welcome to pogchamps
that was incredible and right before he
did it too he said I can't he can't take
my knight because my knight is defended
by my Fork which I'm pretty sure that's
what he called The Rook I might have
misheard and then he moved his Rook into
a trade which would therefore remove it
from the board and allow his Knight to
be captured and he did not want to move
upon which would prevent him from
getting background checkmated because he
said that his dude would get smoked but
then his dude got smoked anyway and that
is in fact James Danny dudes are getting
crazy Levy it brings us back to the
piece of advice that Andrea and I gave
saikuno and again it was relevant then
it's relevant now like he actually even
in the games he was losing Levy quickly
he was seeing a lot of good ideas but I
think some of these Gamers like are so
used to clicking fast right because in
other games the skill that translates
Levy is is mouse speed and so it's like
they're thinking with the mouse instead
of taking a Beat
to think about the position and he
literally went from playing great chess
to checkmating himself with that with
with those fast moves
foreign
did you see that what Knight G5 was
played
the queen was hanging the Knight could
have taken the queen in one move and
virtual played 97. is virtual playing
the cow opening because his coach is
Anna kremling and he's gonna play Knight
here and then
I hope saikuda plays Queen F3 here
please play Queen F3 please play Queen
F3
For the Love of All That is Holy please
play Queen of three and just to see what
happens
I think I think he's going to
please do it
and I I don't have a horse in this race
I just I I we were all saikudo last
round that was like fighting an older
sibling who was twice our size
oh moves have been made apologies
you were right we were all team saikuno
there I think he had to be team saikuno
it was a 100 versus 1100 player the
underdog drama was real and he was
completely outplaying him yep he didn't
play Queen F3 though ugh
yep not really sure if I'm honest with
you
just uh
uh I think we just move a pawn like
don't give up I'm just gonna I don't
know don't give up
super easy to give up follow me don't do
it this we're allowed to use this right
he's doing the French defense now guys
imagine if I didn't know how to play
which I don't but I just kept reading
this out and and like acted like I ah of
course this is a classic French defense
but the Knight variation uh of course he
moves the thing to D7 classic French
defense of the Knight variation I've
seen this a million times
um so typically what I'd like to do to
defend against this is uh next I'll move
this up like uh
sort of up here and the reason I'm doing
this is there are so many things
specific French defense when they rely
on the night that's a great move I I
really gotta get my pieces moving
um
and I don't want to move it there I
don't want to move it here wait do I
want to move it here
maybe I do one no no I don't no no
Bishop no I don't I don't
I'm gonna move it here I'll move it here
okay
he ends up accidentally defending the
bishop I'm not even sure if that's what
he was trying to do but of all the moves
he threw on the board yep not the worst
movie but
y'all for us a good move from virtual
yeah virtual is back to playing good
chess
looking good
let's take a listen into virtual we
haven't done a lot of that this match
we've been so excited to see saikudo
streaming
for I think the first time in POG Champs
but I think virtual lost rating for
winning the last game I think Chestnut
come punished them and was like why are
you playing someone a thousand points
yeah I think this is the move now
and then I'm threatening this next move
in Castle
yeah also threatening to win a person
who's a good player this is very good
for me
this feels good a lot of options
fair fair move
oh but if I put my Bishop in between
then
I cannot Castle anymore
uh like I mean I can't do the the the
full idea so
Pawn
is pawn move too crazy here
I think I like it
keeping this is an option
and this is still protected that's the
big thing
Castle likes move playlist
chaos this game is chaos
Fair
watch this he's gonna be like oh
actually didn't take the Knight
no you shouldn't
why should you not huh
that's that's an aggressive move there
from saikuno I kind of like it
I mean you might have seen I know
objectively it's not good for like an
eternity
yeah I like the move for sure but it
feels very passive
takes
takes threatening The Rook
if t
I want a twerking hamster I don't have
this Square anymore yeah where's our
twerking hamster where's our twerking
guy in a Hawaiian shirt here I'll twerk
for you in the chat
this is still what I want to play his
King has almost no safety anymore
I was gonna hold on to this Pawn here
this is one I don't want to lose
that's my Center
what's funny is ah normally
three piece
wow
feature chat
okay the night is gone
I was gonna say neither of them were
focused on the bishop H Port Shack Levy
that was certainly a possibility wait
for a discount at the supermarket and
then when you see the discount you just
go in immediately you Rush In
yeah
that was great
admittedly at the supermarket you can't
take anything out for free unless you're
in San Francisco
everything is free in Norway
oh yeah legally
okay legally everything is free
paying is optional
for things this almost traps the bishop
I gotta go to Norway one day
play here
oh wait you have a good time I was just
I was just in Norway I had a great time
everyone in Norway is better than you
move so just know that it's a country of
people that are better than you not you
in particular Levy I mean everybody yeah
I was like what what just life
Norway's great I was I embarrassed
myself in a lot of ways
Norway's a great place to visit can you
play night back and redefend it and
virtual is playing phenomenal chess not
just Norwegian was everybody
a lot of people are tall
but I still have
and we have to show everybody that
there's a way to trap a queen here with
Bishop to G4 which is very very
unfortunate because you played this move
with the intention of creating a threat
and you force your opponent into counter
threading you and actually trapping your
queen
yep
well said
nothing else to add to it I just I'm
sitting here really
bummed that saikuno didn't get that
victory in the last game what a great
chess game he played and I think he's
gonna leave his POG Champs five
tournament winless because virtual is
playing really well here Levy and in
fact as you're highlighting that Queen
has run out of squares
so my heart goes out to saikuno not just
because he made a typo when he made his
username and it should have been Sky
Kuno
skycuno would have been a clue I feel
like one of the interview questions if
we have time I don't know if we do
because
we like to get the mattress rolling but
uh we gotta I'll ask him for sure no
because like there's a lot of there's a
lot of even possible he's also drawing a
bunch of arrows
he sees that the queen
has no safety all right
um
yeah there's nothing I think we lose
uh yep yeah people are like how is
virtual in the constellation practice
he's only got himself to blame
okay I've got a string
if sometimes if you hit the draw button
they'll Miss click it now they didn't
tell me I'm not allowed to do this
50 chance per chance he will miss click
it
and if he doesn't then I'm out of ideas
[Laughter]
he's thinking
oh so good now there are only two
buttons I've missed clicked before in my
life everybody has
he just needs to do it man let's let's
go see what virtual says any Downs I
don't know if there's a downside to
accepting this but I can't accept it
like I win the match right
I think I win the match but is that
trolling
it's a trolling if I accept the draw
[Music]
okay well okay all right no time I
didn't have time to I I'm not sure but
um I probably could have
okay castles wow that's aggressive
uh all right I would have taken the draw
gives guy a half as high accuracy as
possible
um then the correct idea is to open
things up now for example this is
undefended so this seems like a good
move
try to attack here maybe he did to get
the constellation bracket we're going to
confront virtual about that
he should have accepted the draw so we
have at least five minutes to interview
him
good principles somebody go into his
chat and tell him to accept the draw so
we can have a launcher another way oh
there's things um he's got emote only he
actually listens to chess.com you know a
lot of these guys
attacking the pawn
[Music]
I want like as high accuracy this is
like leaving LeBron James in when
they're up 30. you know I don't know if
I've made a lot of mistakes oh except
you did it you know what not taking him
all the accuracy DD
um in the start
take the picture he's just not taking
him though he hates that Bishop just
take the bishop
attack his Queen and then get hit with
Queen E3 check
now let's try to send in the army
this movie I will give him credit on The
Vibes though the music is good Shaq made
in two here
all right music is Gone music was good
music is gone
you and I don't get to have like uh
this Checkmate on the board
oh my god I didn't even I don't know why
we don't get to have it but I'm glad
he's finished the game so we could
control this man
yes we have big things ahead in this
interview everybody
did saikuno make a typo when he created
his name
has played honestly Throne
that first game was stressful he put me
under a lot of pressure so
I'm impressed
and then here I finally find some found
some good moves so
there it is the result we expected
but not not in the fashion we we thought
we'd get
yeah at this point I'm supposed to talk
about the match and stuff but in the
interest of time can we just go to break
so we can see if we can get a virtual
interview we need to get him on the show
Danny it's like Dr Phil all right and we
gotta confront this man about his
intentions
we're definitely getting virtual and
saikuno on the show as long as they will
have us but real quick let's look at the
constellation bracket because virtual
does punch his ticket to take on squeaks
now squeaks is a squeaks is a baller I
know virtual has to be the favorite
against anybody in the consolation
bracket because you shouldn't be there
he has double his rating sorry no you're
right he shouldn't be there but tweaks
squeaks has a chance if saikuno almost
beat him then squeak has a chance
against virtual Levy yeah and squeaks
without a Redemption Arc for sure no I
mean listen everybody's been talking
trash on squeaks and squeaks just been
firing back he had a really good match
earlier in the week and uh listen if
there's a man to pull off the upside
Danny it's him but I'm I'm not happy
with what I saw today and I got some
Choice words
all right well we are gonna give these
two men our choice words in just a few
moments there is virtual he just took
the dub moves on to the next round in
the consolation bracket he defeated
saikuno they will both be joining us in
just a moment don't go anywhere
podchamps five returns in a few
[Music]
foreign
oh
kingy8 and then Queen C8 and there's
actually a staircase Checkmate oh man
watch it through maybe seven is made
Seven they're three mates here for white
oh my gosh oh what a huge throw let's go
hi I'm Grandmaster anushkiri and welcome
to Latin repair toys
[Music]
the so-called Latin Gambit is horrible
F5
Knight takes E5 this is not how chess
has played he played too many moves with
pawns and the Queen and didn't develop
his light pieces
and it's 94 this is a very important
trick to remember many people fall for
it actually Knight to B5 brilliant ID a
b and queen G7 Natural Cafe Bishop H6
Queen C5 and F3 and surprisingly Queen
F2 is almost Checkmate but it's not
heropant wants to be solid we go for uh
aggressive for the kill if your opponent
wants us to go for the kill we play
Simple chess and just use the fact that
they have more space in the center clear
cut plans and nothing to worry about
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
come on
[Music]
let's go
thank you
foreign
[Music]
come on
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we are back POG Champs 5 continues that
man just moved on to the next round in
the consolation bracket with a 2-0
victory over saikuno we're going to be
talking to him right now and it's a solo
interview virtual be honest how nervous
were you in that first game when saikuno
was bringing it
I was very nervous I was thinking like
this is this is a bluff like his ELO is
a bluff it's not 160 he's actually 1 000
on his Smurf account and he's gonna plow
me he's gonna destroy me
um but then I was like okay he started
to make some mistakes and and it turned
out all right but yeah I was really
nervous it did not go as I was hoping at
all
I've I've got a question
um might be a tough one uh and uh I I
but I do want your honest thoughts on
this
um did you lose deliberately in the
championship bracket so you could get a
free ticket to Los Angeles so you could
crush the constellation bracket what do
you have to say to that virtual I'd like
your thoughts
you know Gotham I was in the group you
guys keep calling the group of death and
it was really tough I'm not gonna
complain about a trip to La playing
chess and learning more about the game
but
I really would like to be in the
championship bracket I feel like I feel
like the constellation bracket is fun as
well but like the best chess games are
where you feel like you're playing in
someone your level and I felt that in
groupie and I didn't feel that too much
today but psychuno for being 160 put up
like a really good fight still
well I mean unfortunately twist ending
we didn't budget for flights from Norway
to La so I don't know if you guys
you gotta get me eliminated next round
how are you gonna do this Danny you
gotta get me out yeah
jokes jokes aside you you were in a
really hard bracket and and that is the
truth and I guess maybe Revenge would be
if you make it to La you find some
casual Blitz and get it streamed uh you
know Anna kramling style and show
everybody that you're better than the
people in the championship bracket right
yep
I mean that could be fun and I think uh
regardless like I've had some experience
playing over the board if I'm not
getting there it's very different from
online you can't draw arrows you can't
Mark the squares so it's like
but but it's it's an adventure you know
like
right now we're in the constellation
bracket can't change the past gotta make
the most of it uh where I am now yeah
maybe maybe next POG Champs I get
another chance and I could I could see
myself trying champions
yeah well how do you feel about uh your
next opponent I mean you know
specifically looking ahead are you uh
you see yourself as big of a favorite as
we do
uh well squeaks and I are are both
speedrunners I think we uh have a good
uh good understanding of games when we
started playing them and pick them up
quickly I don't know how much practice
he's put in I am probably the favorite I
hate being the favorite
[Laughter]
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna do my best
honestly and hope it's enough
it's uh the last hurdle before I late
how has your training been with with
Anna uh how serious was the training she
she was the only pop Champs coach who
flew to train her student like and
that's that's why not getting to the
champion bracket is a little extra sour
but the coach I mean that has been
amazing
um trained a lot specifically on
openings and like middle game tactics
and understanding like the concepts like
not breaking tension or not taking a
piece just because you can stuff like
that
and that I feel like has helped just a
general chess stuff but the one thing
that she can't really cure is the
beginner blunders like just blundering a
piece blundering a queen you know that's
that's the stuff that I have to be
responsible for and yeah is that is that
what she told me she tell you like okay
shout out to dinner
I cannot hear you right now Gotham
you can't hear Gotham can you hear me no
I can hear you yeah I can hear Levy
um okay well I I visited Norway recently
who would you rather date Peter Nortel
or Magnus Carlson I asked a lot of
Norwegians that
I mean they're both uh both formidable
formidable competitors and men who I'd
rather date
um
I I have to say pattern I think
I think the body has a better body more
athletic body yeah with that also also
Magnus has been really letting his hair
go and his facial hair he needs to pull
it together let's just let's just call
it like it is a little bit you're saying
if a man needs a cut they're just you're
just calling him out from the haircut
you got it
all right well you speak sign language
what'd you say we appreciate you
thank you so much for having me enjoy
the rest of Polish Champs but gonna be
great games and uh I look forward to
seeing the rest of the tournament
see ya maybe we'll see in LA
all right well that was virtual that was
awkward and uh we got a couple of
matches ahead with Judy and Ginny and
then I did a thing in Tyler Levy are you
back
foreign
's not back yet I'm talking don't call
it a comeback Levy's been here for years
um I'm gonna keep doing
um doing solo commentary and say that
cutie is maybe not as big a favorite as
virtual was against saikuno uh but she's
a pretty big favorite here and uh it
should be interesting to see how how her
and Jenny are able to match up
um we know that Ginny is uh playing her
first POG Champs and has been kind of
new to the game but but getting better
with every match so we'll see if she can
continue to improve against cutie here
winner of course takes on daily dose of
Internet who like virtual feels pretty
strongly that he was in a tough in a
tough pool and maybe could have been in
the championship bracket so
um
so yeah we're uh we're rolling on here
and I'm here flying solo hey everybody
it's me Dan uh never go never go full
screen Dan because that can lead to
awkward things on the interview and um
you never know what I'm capable of but
we're we're gonna wait here for Levy
Rosman hopefully we can uh pull some
magical tricks
to get him back on the show
um and uh and we're gonna be rolling so
I think everybody can hear me I haven't
heard from production or Levy in a while
it's been a minute and so we're about to
bring Levy back
um anyway this has been great I hope
everyone's having a good time and uh I
love that I love that virtual answered
my question honestly when I said who
would you rather date Peter nortog or
Magnus Carlson Magnus one in a landslide
when I interviewed people on that um
that kind of Boardwalk thing and a
Beautiful Day in Norway but today we had
a Peter North tug so a good um good for
Peter nortuck getting uh getting a nod
you know that he is an eligible bachelor
in Norway
um I also told I was told I was biased
and that if I had said if I had asked
people Magnus Carlson or Victor Holland
recent um obviously top performer in the
PGA Tour that maybe it maybe would have
been more um level shout out to AKA
nemsco there with the get the gifted sub
to Nemo by someone in the chat I'm just
going to keep calling it out maybe we
should preview cutie and uh Jenny what
do you think should we do that we've got
cutie coming up against Jenny as
everyone knows this is her third POG
Champs appearance that being cutie
Cinderella and most the time as we know
her her only real consistent flaw is
confidence cutie just consistently
doesn't believe in herself uh we'll see
if she can do that today Jenny like
saikuno is seeking her first win in POG
Champs
um and uh again
we hope that she can get that the winner
faces daily dose we've seen the
consolation bracket a few times and uh I
think that'll be interesting there there
she is she's live is cutie live she is
live she just went live and uh she's in
the POG Champs quarterfinals or
something that's her stream title and
there's Jenny uh well that's a that's a
tape of Ginny I think IRL tape I don't
know
Jenny's traveling the world and so she's
like often coming off of nine hours of
IRL streaming to play
and uh
and we're back
hi
you're back
I can hear you and I'm that was that was
super weird that was super weird maybe
it's time to hook up that new computer
that you've got sitting next to your
left leg below the desk yeah it's right
there and and right at that moment uh
wife came home from work and dog freaked
out started barking it was uh it was
wild time in this room
um but I I think it was the Norwegian
Mafia I think they just got upset I I
made fun of virtual but it was a great
interview I enjoyed waving at him
you you waved from the side and he
answered an honest question about Peter
versus Magnus we'll we'll clip and ship
that but anyway shout out to Virtual he
moves on we know he's a strong player
Anna kramling is happy we're always
happy when Anna's happy and Levy Rosman
is back and we have another matchup
cutie versus Ginny Levy
let's do it oh yeah uh super excited to
see what happens with this one uh
primarily from the standpoint of Ginny
can have a saikuno story and and have a
big comeback or if cutie can can can
deliver two more stalemates
yeah I mean honestly cutie is on a
record-setting pace right now for
stalemates delivered and she was born
blaming the queen promotion as I told
her it had nothing to do with the
promotion she just needs to give checks
um she's also she's she's wielding a
weapon can we all what is okay that's a
wine opener all right let's be let's be
nervous here everyone let's be nervous
together
yeah
that's unnerving it's unnerving she's
gonna go whine about it after this
um but I expect her to get the win um
although Ginny is again
um coming at this as the underdog we'll
see if she can get her first win in POG
Champs
where is her weapon of choice
yeah seriously
maybe maybe we should tell her that that
she should consider grabbing a weapon in
the room so she doesn't get intimidated
by cutie
you know and
Jenny travels a lot is she ever at a
home setup or is she just is her whole
thing just traveling the world and
streaming it yeah I have yet to see her
in a home setup I don't you know no one
knows what her home setup looks like
maybe it's a legend maybe it's the stuff
of Legend
um she's been in Hungary during pogchamp
she's been in
I actually don't know what the other
country I think was Poland
I think she was in
yeah anyway so she's been all over the
map literally in Europe uh she also
celebrated her birthday on the road so
uh Jenny's had a busy couple weeks here
at POG Champs
and we'll see what she can do against
cutie she she's been to more countries
than I feel like most Americans know
exist yeah that's actually probably Fair
that's probably Fair
there you go now hopefully she got her
openings down too hopefully she had been
grinding some openings and uh no better
way to spend an evening in a foreign
country than not to go outside but
rather just sit at home and learn chess
yeah that's uh that's what you want it's
what everyone wants uh we want this
match to start because I've been I've
been vamping here for a minute and we've
had some fun hopefully everyone's
enjoying we still have a lot of matchups
ahead and cutie is live so don't go
anywhere we got cutie and Jenny next
we've got Alex and Tyler and then
ultimately we have Connor and Seth I
don't know
there is a game we could pull it up
there is a game cutie has played a move
and and she has uh get a load of this
she has made a uh
tea tours look at that she's making her
own stream small
oh she her crop was I see her crop was
weird so we had to crop it too that's
funny we're letting her crop herself
into frame here this is pretty funny
is it still a thing where if cutie loses
her game she blames me I haven't chatted
with her since she got super famous and
like you know organized the streamer
Awards and stuff so I don't know is that
still her thing actually she's she's
mostly just giving you credit and saying
that she's a bad student
um although I did call you I did call
you out for teaching the Stonewall but I
don't know maybe that wasn't even you
did you teach her the Stonewall
yeah but that was like three years ago
you know she was supposed to learn
another opening you know I mean like I'm
with you on that
um obviously I was making a point about
the dangers of system openings but you
know it's fair that uh you don't you
gotta you gotta at some point evolve but
that's not on you as a coach and I'm not
just saying that because I love your
shirt
it's a really nice shirt by the way uh
it's uh I bet it feels good cotton like
I was gonna say does it feel good like
yeah it's a silk cotton blend feels nice
actually all of these are real gold this
is just real 24 it's all gold them that
you are talking dirty right now I when
you say silk cotton
I get a little hot over here a little
excited
um all right that's a bad check from
Jenny we'll see if cutie plays C3 nope
he doesn't yeah cutie was supposed to
play these two pawns before black can
play the move E5 but
um I both neither one of them are
addressing the center pawns which which
does happen
which does happen we talked about this
yeah I had a lot of cutie commentary
with Andrea we talked about exactly what
you're saying that uh people seem to be
ready for Cutie Stonewall they're
playing E5 but she doesn't seem ready to
take the pawn we've seen this we've seen
this pattern a few times now apoc chips
yep onto C3 would have hit that and then
she would have been able to take uh
we'll see we'll see if Ginny notices
because it's not just about putting the
pawn there it is
a thing that can continue moving
it doesn't just have to
see if it just needs to take take the
pawn
oop she goes for the center which again
objectively that's a nice idea but it's
not good here because because now Kitty
can take
yep
yeah we're all we're all playing for
stalemates here Living on a Prayer with
cutie Cinderella
on takes on E5
Knight E4 is the best move but night
night to G4 is also reasonable yeah
White's just gonna play here and here
and then slowly convert her advantage
and hopefully get a third still that was
crazy I can't believe I missed two still
mates oh Jenny no the night
no oh my goodness Danny Queen H5 she's
playing it cutie is uh well
she's not interested in stalemate we got
to get we gotta give that credit
oh we do we do we do that's fine if she
wins quickly more longer interview with
cutie we get to
yeah let's let's highlight what's about
to happen right
absolutely right it's just gonna it's
gonna be it's gonna be a bomb going off
yeah right
you've got to be cautious oh they've
moved the thing
you and I could just keep doing
different accents as we as we add a real
stall move right there the real star
player
by the way
we we might just be about to see the end
either Geniuses Checkmate or we've got
game one of the books
big moment here oh yeah
GG
profile photo is Ludwig I didn't even
it's amazing I didn't notice that either
well there you go that was smooth like
butter that's a stone she takes a uh a
Winner's stretch there
like Andrea she's sporting the the
massive jug of water
oh listen you take creatine you gotta
you gotta get that water too I I don't
know if she is but um she takes the one
to nothing lead that was a that was a
that was a solid of a start as you can
ask for yeah
well I got nothing that was that was
quick that was that was uh easy that was
yeah we gotta we gotta kill like two
three minutes now because the
production's gotta flip the colors make
sure everybody's good Chad how are you
guys doing how you doing Chad hey AMA
time with Levy Rosman I'm your host
Danny wrench bring the questions Gotham
chess is joining us everybody what do we
got for the man tell them Johnny
I I saw a question at the beginning of
the last game that said WTH Levy is here
like why isn't heavy here and I was like
I do I don't know I I asked like I
showed up people Bounce Around the
internet and go man Levy's here what's
going on with that
um somebody asking about my my net worth
I actually just just crossed 500 million
Danny 500 million dollars yes big big
moment in my life yeah was that
according to the Internet
it's just according to my you know I I
just think that's what it is I don't you
know I don't check I just say I think
that's a that's a good way to do it net
worth of 500 million every once in a
while I like Googling random questions
about that we should Google what is
Gotham chess net worth let's do that
let's see let's see what is I don't know
how kikaru's got to 45 million that was
a that was a cool one
yeah
how much money does Gotham chess make on
YouTube and twitch that's a good one
yeah okay
I don't know there's too many links I'm
not gonna go down that rabbit hole
um what else we got chat
chat
this is it this is your plan
does my stalling of upgrading my PC
happen in other parts of my life oh
absolutely I mean I mean I've had to
change the blinds of my of my new place
for like two months and I just every
morning I wake up and I go it's too
bright
so instead of changing the blinds Danny
I just sleep with a sleeping mask that I
got from a plane
it's just I get it that's how I live my
life man you know you know that you know
how it is you got something in the house
that takes three years
yep I'm with you uh on every level but
uh
we we're still in the process of moving
we moved over the last couple years I
know what you're thinking like Danny you
moved two years ago but that's how long
it takes to move when you have four kids
it takes two years to unpack every box
to get everything set up this last
weekend we had a massive we actually
knocked out a bunch of house stuff this
last weekend I'm I'm super pumped about
it I'm a brag on air you know we were
putting stuff away doing storage you
know organizing shelves
it was phenomenal
was it a was it a family effort
everybody was involved it was actually I
got my my lazy ass kids to help me you
know
um
I got I got my no my kids were great I
got a couple of teenage boys it is weird
Levy because my my oldest literally has
grown like a foot in the last year and a
half when he went from like five four to
like six one and so all of a sudden
having a full-grown man in the house who
can lift things higher than me is like a
mind-blowing experience it's so it's
it's super helpful yeah um I stopped
like halfway there I stopped at like
five nine I didn't get all the way to
six one uh yeah I was uh I was on summer
vacation with my brother who's 16 and
he's uh he's like six one six two and we
were just wrestling and I like I I
couldn't move him he was just a brick
wall and uh yeah I I you know now I
gotta become a dad so I get Dad strength
because I played basketball with with
dads and they're they're they're they're
too strong so that dad's strength is a
real thing although he's he's now he's
so he's been trying to arm wrestle me
for a while and now he's learned some
technique which is like this weird thing
where like you wrap your arm around like
the thumb and you do this and so like
the other day we we arm wrestled and for
the first time like we we went from me
just like pounding him to him like
almost winning I had to use everything
in the book and I think my my days are
numbered he'll be stronger than me soon
so beautiful stuff but but they're tall
and strong so they could help you with
the house they got no excuses yep
exactly I think we're about to start
more chess games people are tired of
hearing us about me and my kids and uh
Levy wrestling his brother but hey this
is a good you know it's a good day
it is a good day I I'm gonna team up
we're gonna we're gonna play soccer uh
football uh in uh you know some New York
City Parks hopefully so
uh I'll send him in he plays Goldie so
we'll we'll have a good okay
C6 cutie is going for her still wall
structure even as black she likes to she
likes to get c65 and E6
um does she play Karo Khan if she does
she's a levy Rosman student bro I
yeah but she used to just play whatever
but I I don't know if she actually plays
this now
I think she does she still says that
you're her coach
didn't you and Judy get pair you guys
prepared on one of the twitch Rivals and
you also worked with her for POG Champs
but yeah cutie Cutie can be kind of
scary to work with right I mean she's a
little intimidating
you intimidate to me that's what I well
that's that was the aesthetic a couple
years ago but then I feel like I feel I
feel sort of she that's not the thing
anymore and now she's just sort of like
a chill like a alpha business leader who
just puts on a ton of event like she's
I'm intimidated I saw her in person and
she was being surrounded by like 20
people and everybody wanted to talk to
her it was it was a beautiful moment so
the streamer Awards uh aren't you aren't
you the reigning streamer of the year
that's right 2023. yeah yeah not overall
yeah
by the way this is a good opening from
her I mean like jokes aside she played a
caracon she put the bishop outside the
pawn chain played Levy this is like you
literally couldn't teach a student to do
a better job in your Carol con yeah
we're gonna see the next three or four
moves if I can say the same exact
sentence but you know like she it's
never too late to play Queen F6 or
something for some reason
uh and and the thing about openings is
that sometimes people play all sorts of
weird stuff and you get thrown off but
uh if she just plays C5 and Knight C6
yeah she's just gonna be in good shape
like Knight A3 yeah H3 again you know
Ginny's just
six okay okay F6 is a little a little
risky to get the biskey here risk it to
get the biscuit but she knows she needs
to undermine the center I like H3 from
Ginny if she wants to go all in and
attack let's go
that's how you do it yup gets get spicy
don't mind F6 at all we'll see if she
even sees it right because it's she
might just develop something and uh then
cutie will take and then she will make
progress in her position
uh somebody in the chat said when does
xqc play that's
super tragic
yeah if you tuned in to see xqc that uh
that was a minute ago it was epic double
overtime victory over Papa plot
um unfortunately we didn't get an
interview but go ahead I don't think you
were supposed to spoil it uh that none
of that happened it was a double
all-time victory for for nobody nobody
nobody check it out the internet the
internet doesn't have any any evidence
of that okay Knight F3 from Jenny this
is good stuff holding the center down
um
I'm rooting for Jenny to get her first
win come on let's go to overtime
let's do it yeah seriously
night takes on takes let's go Ginny
fish uh castles
something
do we have our stream I guess we just
have our camera I don't know Jenny
Jenny's on Zoom but we can listen to
cutie let's do that let's see what uh
yeah let's see what she's talking about
she's talking a little bit either have
that be going for me
foreign
there we go okay yeah I just want to get
it developed
those glasses make me want to talk in a
British accent I don't know why
like I'll go get mine
yeah I got sunglasses too
I'm yeah I got legs
I got it I really don't like my night
placement
this is actually much better for the
record these these lights in the studio
are so bright another side instead uh
laughs
[Music]
how we doing
there we go in the house
you already know the Vibes
I don't
I I don't know I don't want this to come
out the wrong way but when you put on
sunglasses you kind of get this this
like
this feel of again like you just had an
all-night Bender right the shirt the
glasses you are recovering from a bender
like no other person you're a modern day
vampire she's gonna bring it with the
go-to you kind of got like the sexy
vampire look going
and then I'm gonna Castle I'll I'll take
hungover for 500. I'll take a look over
for 500 Alex
um yeah on vacation I I wore these a few
times because I
I mean we can do that we'll listen
okay her thought process here
is bingo I mean
[Music]
that maybe is she going for that trade
she goes for that trade she knows I
won't be able to bring this and then
I'll ruin my structure would she do that
I'm fine with this big analysis going on
we'd love to see it
maybe I'm being too crazy for my own
good but
I'm feeling pretty okay with that
decision
thank you
I'd love her to see Queen B6
Queen B6 would be really nice
[Music]
reason I can't take that is because of
that
she can't take this right now because of
how many people at home just put on
sunglasses be honest can't take that
because of that
I mean it does suck so long unless
they're wearing sunglasses if that
spreads out my pawns but it's like fine
let's have a moment
what are you doing this is Chill
we'll chill
H5 is a good move by the way let's just
bring it back real quick
who goes here
I just take this free night that's all I
do right
oh never mind it was the sunglasses I
did not realize that there was a night
hanging on D4
I would like to amend my previous
statement Queen H5 under normal
circumstances would have been a good
move but not in this case
uh Queen B6 Queen B2 mate Queen B6
Bishop takes Knight Queen B2 made Danny
that
that could be it
could be it if cutie sees it
yeah we we could be looking
you know I got these prescription
sunglasses yeah and Danny I have a
really weird phenomenon where one of my
monitors I can look at completely and
the other one turns black oh I had the
same thing right now whoa
black normal black normal you're right
what's going on that's super weird I
think it's the the higher res monitor I
have to look at an angle to see it under
my sunglass like the 4K
yeah
by the way she didn't see Queen B6 I
think the uh
yeah I think the higher resolution
monitor does better
yeah they're saying that it's
polarization Monitor and that they don't
know anything they they just write words
and they just Spam it like they you'd
listen to these people you think they're
the smartest people they think they're
Nobel winners with all this information
meanwhile they they they go and uh they
eat uh you know expired milk from two
weeks like Danny half of them half of
them are naked at home on a beanbag
chair eating Cheetos wiping Doritos dust
on their own skin don't okay well excuse
you I did that before I joined the show
today so you know like let's let's
I love me some flaming hot Cheetos you
don't
not anymore I I don't eat corn anymore
so I basically killed my junk food but
let's go listen to cutie and
see if see if she's got it
um actually
still she played H6
the queen being there is really
interesting
not super sure what to think of it but I
want to get this night out here so then
I can get my queen out and be fine with
these guys
um I kind of just want to go here and
get this check happening
she sees B2
um what pressure could I put on that
Queen
if I go back here to put pressure on
that Queen she takes I take like she
gets up a night
um okay I'm gonna move this out first
right here so then I can oh I can't do
that right now I can go here that's kind
of fun
push that pawn up
hmm that's interesting
it's a good move yeah this tension is
building though
she's gotta take the bishop
I offer you a trade or I get your
Rook madame
oh
slip into English accent
hello puppet
right
yeah yeah right
oh just laughing at chat I know that's
useless but sometimes they're funny
my control of the center that was stupid
she's actually makes a good point yeah
damaging her pawns was not great but
it's okay oh
no this is action oh big uh oh it's big
uh-ohs
big uh-oh moment
the bishop on E3 is accidentally holding
everything together for Jenny Levy yep
that's a big uh oh
I mean that's just a free piece
now we'll go glasses
that was a silly decision that's the end
of my commentary career can't see
anything anymore
oh you are we glasses off I thought we
were writing this out I mean I have to
do what you're doing so no I'm I'm going
back to my rights
it hurts my eyeballs to stare to monitor
in sunglasses
um I'm just laughing at Tommy here you
are holding it together the show Danny's
Danny's lost it
um look at that a giant Jenny just
played a ridiculous tactic by the way I
oh my God if she sees to take E5 she
took t7 I'm wondering whether she did it
to take E5 or just accidentally we're
gonna find out we're about to find out
and Bishop D4 is made after that I mean
not
wow wow there we go that's fine all's
Fair there wow
okay she's up three
all right all right I'm back gotta pay
attention Jenny is uh
Ginny is here
Rook takes D7 removing the knight from
the defense of this
that is otherworldly look at that Knight
to D5
damn Bishop here now maybe Rook maybe
maybe Pawn G5
this could get this could get crazy
yeah no joke that was a she dude she
just played Bishop D4
yeah yeah now unfortunately for her
that's not me yeah
yeah right
and nice
Queen C7 Queen E6 king h8 queen H6 H6
and queen G7
okay
this has suddenly become
a game where Jenny is going full saikuno
here
much better than her previous chess
games and if she plays H4 G5 or even
just G5 that could that would be
otherworldly
even Knight C4 Knight D6 right if she
sees that that night on the edge isn't
playing that would be rather spicy as
well yeah this is one of those moments
she's got to realize I can't do any more
with this so I got
yo
yo whose mans is this what yo like who
is who took over for Ginny here she's
only got a couple minutes but she's
playing phenomenal chess and again no
disrespect to Jenny we knew she had
potential but this is awesome
you still play positive under the park
don't play policy three don't play Pawn
C3
you can push anything go here oh my God
please don't Blaze C3
dude you might have you might have gone
POG Champs premonition like the prophet
never go full profit never go full
Tropic Thunder reference either talk
about a movie that no longer okay
hilarious though
I'm like I'm the master of predicting
these move C3 makes less sense because
it doesn't actually stop this so this
move makes more sense
but I'm so scared
yeah come on Jenny A3
okay okay that's a good move too
okay the big issue right now is time
yeah yep yep yep this is free but you
know not a big deal but then you can't
move the bishop but not a big deal we'll
play Knight D6
it's going to be great
I'll get King to B1 let's go Jenny's
talking on the zoom call she's not
streaming she's zooming
she was making a note to herself she I
think she was saying she needs to speed
up if my lip reading abilities haven't
failed me
yeah and cutie has to just play Knight
to B4 the best move according to the
computer is Queen D5 hitting the Knight
on C4 but that's not findable so she
goes here now does Jenny just remember
to just keep it moving she might go here
thinking that she's
oh second time around at least it
doesn't lose the queen though at least
it doesn't lose the queen oh we're about
to get spicy
here we go
cutie said watch your mouth attacking my
knight imma attack your knight
I mean are you kidding me
what's what's the crazy there's a
discovered attack what's going on I was
gonna ask what's the Taylor Swift song
with the move B5 like what would you
name a Taylor Swift song After the movie
five
um
I've got a I've got a Pawn on B5 baby
and I'll write your name huh ah come on
that's Blank Space reference
yeah
on the spot
Auntie here yeah I I don't know I'm just
I'm wondering because she she likes
she likes those you know when I was on
the plane to Creator Clash to Tampa
people were on the plane from New York
to Tampa just to watch Taylor Swift like
I did not realize people fly to concerts
it's so it's so wild
I'm I I don't I don't want to like I'm
not trying to change the direction of
this program I am not that big of a
Taylor Swift fan FYI okay so that's a
whole other discussion okay that's
that's bold I mean I I don't care either
way I'm I'm not pro or against but
that's a big claim so that's yeah okay
Knight D3 was a great move despite the
fact that I'm not a big T Swift guy I'm
more of a Miley Cyrus guy myself I
prefer like you know she's a little more
like raw to me I mean the music is a I
don't know I'm not a big Taylor Swift
guy I just
if I'm choosing female pop stars of a
generation I'm just being real
you're allowed to have an opinion okay
by the way Rook takes D3 was nice by
Jenny if she now takes the Rook there's
a chance
there's okay no never mind cutie sees it
yeah but but but you know you could play
F3 and go oh I hung a pawn and then
boink that would be that this is of
course the caution spot you know in the
position right there look at that guess
who's using emotes guess who's using
emotes I'm telling you coming to Gotham
chess videos near you I'm telling you
like that they're they're visually
appealing and they feel satisfying when
you use them
oh Jenny don't go Queenie one it's a
very common beginner mistake yeah I get
that just capture promotion
over here yep
okay good move nice move let's go
Ginny but this battery is is powerful
this is not an easy position for black
nope forget what the email Bar says
yeah it says it's minus five but that's
because the computer is like Rook here
Rook here kick out the queen take the
pawn okay
Jenny only has 10 seconds the chili is
one legal move like she
yeah let's go see what Cutie's thinking
but I'm I'm liking Jenny's chances right
now as long as she speeds up
so it whatever you gotta move Jenny
Jenny okay he has to take that there you
go
pinned that now
good move
Jenny you gotta move he's gonna lose on
time
okay let's go let's go let's go
Jenny move can you make a move make a
move Jenny
oh no
oh good
I definitely messed up a few times
writes a game review
my accuracy was so bad hers was really
good
what a phenomenal game that was though I
know the final score is as predicted
similar to Virtual we knew that he was a
big favorite when you cutie was a big
favorite both our consolation bracket
matches today kind of had kind of had um
clear underdogs but but still I think
Jenny played well Levy
I think so that second game was like
when you get on the bike and you start
biking and all of a sudden you're not
falling over on the side anymore that's
really what it felt like uh she played
really really well that game and I think
the game review would say the same I
think it would probably say that she
played like a six or seven hundred so
yeah she should be proud I mean it's
tough she has a ridiculous schedule and
we've seen with a couple of players in
this tournament it's not always so easy
to just learn the game especially as
you're doing your other career but
she should be proud of that last game
and that performance for sure
yep all right well let's take a look at
where that puts us in the bracket both
of our semi-final matchups in the
consolation at least are clear to us now
daily dose we'll take on cutie in the
next round virtual takes on squeaks that
is a much harder round for me to predict
winners I know virtual is the favorite
Levy but daily dose and cutie I think is
much closer to a coin flip so the next
set of matchups in the consolation
bracket should have us on the edge of
our seats
no I think so I think it's a tough match
tough matches
Checkmate I couldn't lose
apparently as a Taylor Swift lyric that
we missed an opportunity to use good for
me I don't listen to Taylor Swift songs
but I do watch chess on Twitch and if
I'm like anyone else right now I have an
event I have an opportunity to take
advantage of the twitch chess month use
the command drops for your opportunity
to get two weeks of diamond all you got
to do is watch two hours or more of
Chess and then use the command drops and
after you connect your Twitch and
chess.com accounts you can claim the
reward it's easy peasy make sure you do
it right away it's available for a
limited time so don't miss it use the
command drops to learn more I'm not
kidding there you go a lot of people in
chat using the command drops you've
probably already watched two hours of
Chess just today and there's cutie
Cinderella Rock in the shades this one
goes to 11. that's what she's thinking
inside her head right this one goes to
11. next time we're gonna interview
cutie right on the other side of break
don't go anywhere it's POG chimps five
when we return
ah
do you wish playing a chess game with a
friend was as easy as sending them a
text well good news now it is but
chess.com's new iMessage app you can
start and play a game directly in
iMessage your friend doesn't even need a
chest.com account it's just tap and play
head over to go.chess.com iMessage or
use the command iMessage in chat to
learn more
this August engage in a battle of Epic
Proportions against some of the most
Bodacious artists history hath ever seen
behold Raphael the prince of painters
doth seek a fresh Apprentice Dosh thou
possess the prowess to impress him
Michelangelo a true renaissance man
painter sculptor architect and poet doc
possess a myriad of artistic talents yet
one wonders can his creative genius
translate to Brilliance upon the board
of chess
prepare thyself for a game as dramatic
as the Baroque paintings of Artemisia
gentileschi one of the most expressive
artists of the 1600s
a renowned sculptor Donatello stands
tall as one of the most important
artists of the early Renaissance his
unique blend of creativity Aesthetics
adaptability and patience maketh him a
challenging foe Lo Leonardo da Vinci
known for his artistic talents
scientific curiosity and innovative
ideas is the very embodiment of the
Renaissance he is not only among the
greatest artists to ever live but also
one of the greatest thinkers May a
fortune smile upon thee create thy
Masterpiece on chess.com cowabunga
foreign
[Music]
Champs 5 rolls on this epic five match
Monday continues cutie Cinderella just
took a 2-0 victory to the next round of
the consolation bracket sporting the
sunglasses and the Taylor Swift
sweatshirt to go with it and Judy on
that note we have to start with a
serious question some idiot in chat said
that Taylor Swift overrated Miley Cyrus
underrated
your thoughts
uh
tukumen pitting women against each other
they're both good
oh I was just gonna ask Julia far less
controversial question which is um where
are you in the world right now because
we you've been traveling I think the
whole tournament
or is that wrong
yes so when I first joined the
tournament I was in Poland and then
second time I was in uh Hungary and now
I'm Croatia oh my God Jenny yeah crazy
that's all over this is really pretty
though it's really nice
yeah Kasparov lives there Gary Kasparov
the uh the many by many considered the
uh he's like the Taylor Swift of Chess
you know he's like the goat right right
I feel like that's pretty fair
or the Miley Cyrus again I'm not pitting
anyone against each other I'm just no no
pointing out I get it I get it they're
both great
um Jenny you played phenomenal chess
this second game was super close this
idea of the bishop and queen battery but
you ran out of time so what were you
well yeah no really you played you
played a really great game it was super
close so what were what were your
thoughts in this in this match today
um I guess it was not embarrassing like
previous few games but um uh I I think
um
yeah
I guess this was I mean I wasn't really
I was I wasn't really thinking
before that much but then when I try to
actually think that time goes so fast
and then I just run out of time probably
because I'm not used to uh playing chess
so it takes very very long time to like
think of good moves I guess so but um
I'm I'm happy with the uh chess game so
far yeah even though I lost everything
well
yeah a lot of it is uh pattern
recognition and just doing things like
100 200 times like I think cutie played
in
was it the first POG Champs the second
POG Champs actually my question to cutie
was gonna be how how much chess like do
you play is it a part of the daily
routine or is it just like you played on
stream sometimes or no I play chess
every day I have an ALT account that I
just grind on
oh wow that warms my heart
yeah I play every day
and you're playing the Carroll Khan is
that because you had a coach named
Gotham Chess at one point
yeah he taught me the caracon
yeah good job
you did you played great and Jenny you
played grade two back to that I really
want to ask what was your favorite match
overall I know your POG Champs five
tournament is over and obviously you
started new to chess you played
Fantastics yesterday overall what was
your what was your favorite matchup of
the entire event
um probably the probably all the way to
the last one because I think in the
beginning I don't know I think I
improved every match I think even though
I lost I think I improved like little by
little so probably the last one and uh
the first time when I did with Tyler I
think I almost won so maybe that one was
kind of like oh maybe but um yeah so
first one and the last one
question to cutie uh
uh first of all I got I got two they're
about the consolation bracket first of
all uh squeaks is making a comeback and
he said that you calling him trash was a
was a big motivator second question is
and second we can answer that first and
the second one was gonna be uh any
expectations and thoughts going into the
match against daily dose no freaking
squeaks isn't gonna beat virtual I don't
know what he's I don't know who he
thinks he is he's not beating Worthy
it's not an option for him I'm not gonna
see him it's not a problem I think I
think as long as my eye swelling goes
down I can beat daily dose but right now
I can barely see so I just have to hope
for the swelling to go down
I'm glad you I'm glad you see yourself
though as beating daily I was just going
to ask what do we have to do to give you
uh give you the confidence to see
yourself as the favorite against daily
dose because I think you're the favorite
I I have a special opening against him
so we'll see okay special just for him
okay I've studied his games so we'll see
that did win pretty fast I mean I'm not
spoiling any but that was anyway I don't
wanna you know I don't wanna
I've studied everything I've studied it
all and I like Jason but I don't like
him enough to let him win
I love it I love it all right well we
got cutie versus daily dose for those
who miss it Jenny this has been awesome
to have you for POG Champs maybe maybe
in the future when you're not IRL
streaming traveling the world
um we'll uh we'll we'll see you in some
more chess events and cutie congrats on
the day we hope you're feeling better
soon
thank you and uh we'll we'll see you
tomorrow
okay bye guys bye-bye bye
and there you go Levy Rosman with the
sunglasses on we're headed to a break
this is pogchamps five don't go anywhere
we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]
thank you
today
[Music]
come on I do love chess since we're
winning boys why don't we celebrate with
a glass of wine nine o'clock somewhere
in the world am I right
[Music]
let's go
that was amazing I loved that you play
with our emotions just for a second
wow yes let's go
[Music]
yes it's garbage at chess it needs to
uninstall forever I will pick you up in
real life we're gonna allow him to
embarrass production like this
dude you're not serious can't wait to
see you Tyler
back to the championship bracket we go
pogchamps five continues here and uh
we've still got two more matchups ahead
Levy I know it's been a long day and
we've had double overtime Thrillers and
and all kinds of POG Champs moments but
we still have two huge matchups to cover
and I know you're ready for Alex versus
Tyler I'm ready I'm nervous tyler1 is
back I'm I'm super nervous I was also
super hungry I managed to get a snack in
and now I'm I'm buckled up I'm ready to
go these were the this is like a UFC
fight card where the co-main and the
Mane are just banging I mean like like
the one that was you know uh the the one
pre previous ones Herrera and uh yeah
yeah many of which I was I was there
live for UFC 291 I don't know that I've
ever been to a more entertaining live
sporting event anyway back to the chess
show I did a thing takes on tyler1 if
you're with us you've seen Tyler one has
been streaming all day and grinding and
then of course we have Connor versus
sapnap I'm just gonna start calling him
Sad Panda because apparently these name
is supposed to be Panda but then the D
would have made it sad anyway it's gonna
I'm gonna give him all kinds of
nicknames it's gonna be fun
um we've got xqc and Frank already in
the semi-finals we have the two next
winners will join we'll join them in the
semi-final matchups Levy
I know that's amazing like it's it's
just completely empty we have Frank and
X you see taking care of business uh
tyler1's Arc has been ridiculous uh he
started at like one or two hundred he
had a he had a win rate of below 10 and
then he clutched this first match he
kept on clutching it okay he lost to
excuse me sure but uh he's been on the
grind Danny and I think we're gonna need
to pull it up later he's won a bunch of
games in a row he's practicing challenge
me to a ten thousand dollar cage chess
match not a cage match uh and uh I'm
pumped to see once again what's gonna
happen by the way I love his stream
title it says pressure exclamation point
overwhelm question mark never all caps
pressure overwhelm never tyler1 is ready
there he is flexing after the victory he
had over Ginny his next matchup is
versus I did a thing obviously there's
Alex who's also had a pretty good pot
Champs I think is a sleeper to be one of
the strongest players in the field and
there's Tyler letting everybody know
that he's pumped he's pumped to be here
he has been grinding let's talk about
this particular matchup between Alex and
Tyler because the rating disparity
really doesn't tell the story of how
close this is going to be lovey I can't
believe they used his like
this this card has to be old right I
mean it is it is but the reason is we
set the ratings at the start of the
championship bracket and in the last 24
hours tyler1 has played how many games
has he played like 30 games or something
he's been grinding yeah go ahead yeah he
no I think he's up to something like
500. uh this is their first POG Champs
appearance but they've they've both gone
up a lot I did a thing was was was
absolutely clutch and uh oh yeah we see
it there actually I didn't actually
realize that we have a live writing yeah
it's it's more than doubled and Danny if
he had more time to practice I think it
might have even tripled he could have
gotten up to seven eight hundred so no I
I'm with you and he's watching the
stream live so hey there Tyler we're
talking about you look at you grinding
through the night into the early
mornings apparently you don't feel
pressure that's a good thing you got to
be relaxed to take on Alex I think no
denying even with Tyler listening in
there's no denying Alex is the favorite
in this match it's just the truth even
with Tyler grinding Alex the higher
Raider disagree disagree because he's
going to pause it right there and he's
he's gonna I disagree I think Tyler is
the favorite all right I'm saying that
just so he's nice to you on Twitter I'm
speaking the truth whether he's nice to
me or not I think you can't put a number
on his courage bravery determination and
perseverance there is no ELO that can
quantify that Tyler is above chess ELO
and I'm looking forward to seeing him
prove it today I need a tyler1xqc
rematch that's what I need okay I hey I
want I want the Tyler xqc one the
tyler1xqc rematch I wanted more than
anything and I'm trying to give him
motivation he is the 2022 and 2023
League of Legends streamer of the Year
pretty sure that gets you a gift card to
Starbucks and a couple of extra coloring
books but he does have two and a half
million YouTube subscribers and uh
and he's the host of The Tiger one
championship series
I have I have a goal he's gonna help me
train my mental to get me to GM like he
can't train me he he's gonna help me get
to Grandmaster yeah uh and also train me
in a in a in in bench press and I want
to bench 400 pounds one day I think it's
a good trick I think it's a good I I do
not I Tyler would Tyler would kick my
ass at every on every level of physical
activity there's no denying it uh but he
has been a lot of fun having in the
event and all the jokes at the at the
expense of league league players coming
at you all right let's talk about Alex
because Alex is also in this match it's
not just Tyler I did a thing or Alex if
you want to talk about sexy accidents
from Down Under the Australian YouTuber
and comedian does Feats on camera for
laughs and giggles and walkabouts and
wallabies and he's currently taking
lessons from Jolie go ahead I was gonna
say that I've commentated one of his I
commentated the match that he played
against uh Papa Plata and after the
match he was talking to his friends
about going spear fishing that's just
the thing you do in Australia earlier
you go to a body of water with a pointed
stick and you kill fish you don't use
this wimpy thing that you
he probably eats jellyfish with his
mouth right they're built different in
Australia Danny this is the match-up of
the two most Macho men in this
tournament we could not ever ask for a
better playoff I mean the testosterone
doesn't even they would break the the
vial if they collected a blood sample
this is a crazy matchup I couldn't pay
to have that much testosterone honestly
and uh I wouldn't do it but anyway these
two guys I agree are probably the two
most Macho of the dudes and also two
very good chess players let's remind
everybody of what's at stake because all
hype aside we are past pool play right
now everybody it's win or go home and
they both want it big time uh and uh you
get four grand even if you're eliminated
but everybody wants to see these guys
continue I know I know you got the fan
favorites for tyler1 because you want to
see that that rematch with xqc but Alex
that guy is so strong
it's gonna be interesting
yes chess specific uh I did a thing is
is he's really good I watched a couple
of his matches he gets it's like he's
gotten better as the event has gone on
yeah but listen I think yeah yeah I was
gonna say uh is it a thing I think it's
coached by Andrea botas but tyler1 has
the best coach
which is himself
that's right he is his own motivational
speaker inside his head yelling at me
probably on his stream as we speak let's
remind everybody of the format as the
players are getting set you know it you
love it it's POG Champs we've been doing
it for years don't call it a comeback
it's 10 minutes plus five second
increment it means you get five seconds
bonus time added to the clock with every
move it's a two-game mini rapid match
for the first one and a half boys one
and a half points wins if we're tied we
go to Blitz tie Breakers and uh that's
where that's where the gloves really
come off so I would love I would love
another tiebreaker match today
Levy you think we're gonna get tie
Breakers I think if I had to well this
it's tough I mean sapnap is also a dog
he he could easily uh take one off Sea
Dog but yeah why not why not I mean
let's go why are we I do think Sea Dog
and sapnap have a very good I think
that's a very close matchup like
legitimately I think this one could also
go to tiebreakers even though I see Alex
as the favorite
um and um and yeah shout out to uh to
that to tyler1 and to all the fans
tuning in for the first time maybe
because you were watching Tyler grind
earlier he's played a lot of chess games
now you're watching us just so you can
get frustrated if we make it make any
any jokes about League let's go back to
the bracket one more time and just show
everybody what's at stake here Levy
because the next two matchups will
decide who is playing in the other
semi-final matchup here in POG five
we don't know we don't know at the very
top we have the winner of group a the
runner-up of Group B we have the winner
of Group D the runner-up of Group C and
then we mix them we get a B play DC we
don't know who's gonna emerge I mean we
still have both of these matchups to go
uh and and the best part is I have no
idea who's going to win in either of the
matchups that we're gonna watch that I
have no idea who's gonna win the
semi-finals I have no idea who's going
to win between Frank and xqc I have no
idea who's going to win in La like I
don't know a thing I I sure there's some
favorites Danny but it's so
unpredictable because it's pot Champs
agreed but if the other two matchups are
any indicator we might get more overtime
shots you saw the scores there it took
overtime for Frank to beat Gastly it
took double overtime there for xqc to
get to get by and to move on to the next
round versus Papa plot so if we continue
to see that level of Chess here in the
championship bracket we could get more
overtime games
Buckle in click it or ticket as they say
I've got a banana here from for when I'm
off camera you're a professional so you
ate when no one was looking I'll
probably just eat this in front of
everybody I I can't I can't eat because
I had like a bon me sandwich so it was
gonna be a mess and I was gonna be
chewing all over myself you know
um but uh yeah I uh
I ate a lot yesterday you know and then
like you don't want to eat breakfast and
then you don't want to eat lunch you
just feel gross all day so
I ate a lot I had a good meal last night
had a nice Greek salad I had the spreads
satziki you know hummus baba ganoush to
Pita got a little filet mignon kebab
something
we didn't get any but you know maybe
next time
Greek food yeah I mean it was it was it
was a feast my wife is Greek she makes
the best man of Cobra like no joke like
party in my house when when she's I mean
did you did you just eat that you just
ate the whole thing all right I'm still
mid-process I was checking my text
messages there my wife texted me earlier
but um anyway any anyway we're rolling I
also have a wife we're the most we're
the most married commentary Duo that
chess.com has that's true actually yeah
yeah yeah
that was big news right
um yes yes that was big but he doesn't
he doesn't do commentary I guess as much
but not anymore yeah that's true true
nobody
nobody marries chess players
we became businessmen
there's I did a thing
he's uh
he he this this guy this guy I I aspire
to be as tough as Australians man I mean
they they see like deadly spiders and
they don't they catch them they don't
run from them
yep there he is just picking his nose on
camera like a good Australian
right
I didn't I didn't there's Tyler one
Tyler one is focused he's like let's go
um I'm I'm it's I'm trying to be biased
the other way I have a theory that I can
jinx
Tyler won all the way to the live
finders and live finals in La I'm
secretly rooting for him which is why I
have to make so much fun of him
ruthlessly
of the incredible
yep so much fun
Carol Cohen let's go
a character look what did he look up
openings courtesy of Gotham chess and
one day I have no idea Knight C3 and
yeah he's already doing yeah like is he
gonna get both nights out and the bishop
and then like this and then like this no
chance right
dude Tyler wood grinding grinding
getting better again his live rating as
you know everyone is more than double
what his current rating is at some point
we have to set the graphics it is it is
a show that we got to get templates and
things ready and we don't always
anticipate that someone's going to pull
a pull an all-nighter and double their
chest strength it's a good question like
who is the all-time record holder of uh
of of rating gained in a tournament this
is considered a mistake by the way
because of G4 Knight E5 for the chat and
it's very tough to play uh yeah and and
obviously not found yeah if you want to
show the whole idea it's g495 and then
this bishop B5 check is really spicy for
white for the advanced players out there
this bishop B5 check is dynamite
um oh hafu for sure someone just said in
chat it's hot food not even close
actually although wait sardosh
hold on it is close
sorry yeah if we had if we had hafu
versus sardosh in a short span of time
probably sardosh actually takes the cake
but hafu's up there for sure isn't he up
to like 1800
dude yeah he's he's legitimately a very
a very good chess player
um I think at some point in the next
year half a year we are going to do a
super POG Champs obviously for those who
followed this event from the beginning
let me know that we had Sonic fox in
turns out they were way too good for the
event so we're gonna do a super POG
Champs with Sonic Fox uh probably some
Irena you know probably we'll bring
sardosh back we'll see if he's nice to
me then maybe Andreas we'll see how nice
you are in Discord just calling you out
um we'll uh
oh my God he found Bishop takes that's
ridiculous I thought he might have
forgotten about it with all the tension
in the center
the show why if Queen takes Knight takes
D4 show it baby yeah yeah Knight takes
before it's not even it's not even that
like it's just ridiculous that he even
because you oh my God I found it oh my
God
Tyler won
all right let's listen in let's listen
in to Big Tonka truck let's do it
wow
Tyler with the tactics
Tonk a truck Tyler Queen E3 is a fork
Queen E3 is a night four about this
fun fact big Tonka truck was the
nickname of my little brother
so now I'm gonna call him the big Tonka
Tonka man who's he here I'm not kidding
actually my younger my youngest brother
my family Dorian was obsessed with Tonka
trucks as a kid and we literally called
him Tonka Tonka truck
wow
he's actually he is a big guy uh shout
out to my brother Dorian hanging out
like this um
okay Alex missed his chance
all right let's let's we could bring it
back uh
yeah he escapes with his Knight
he just develops his position and I mean
Pawn to E6
and uh yeah I mean as long as uh
sir big Tonka
finishes up his development here he's
going to be in good shape he's setting
himself up for for a big long-term
advantage
it's crazy
sorry
um anyway yeah we're gonna bring up on
him let's take a look at what Alex is
doing
should I just move that so he can't
bring anything
I was actually literally as we speak he
was texting me because he's watching the
show
um
what's up what's up Tonka wrench what's
up Tonka you should be like one of those
people that like names their kid things
like Tonka you know Tonka Pepsi Cola you
know Tonka Pepsi marriage you know
Joanna will be the nickname I mean the
middle name
marijuana wrench oh my God crazy or do I
hear a voice are we listening to Alex is
that what we're doing we are we're
trying to listen Alex but he's not
talking much Bang Bang
let's crank up the volume crank it Jerry
I don't really want to defend it with
the queen I'm gonna push this porn I
don't hate pushing out Pawn because at
least the do I have any Forks don't have
any Forks push this Pawn Rook getting
the Rook into play
I mean this is just dodgy
what other moves he's right he's right
he's right he's doing his best but he's
100 right it's definitely Queen off a
bit bring the bishop out
get the Rooks facing that big pile of
stuff in the middle
is it he have any hanging pieces not at
the moment Everything Is Right
everything I love the Champions bracket
it's so close I'm not seeing my other
options
it's a good move too
tonight on G3 aggressively 74 where's
his Force he doesn't do anything
here he can't take so if I just move
that up
look at that moving that up either
oh that was you highlighting I thought
it was him highlighting the board
what else you got what else you guys
show me what else you got that's it
what else can you do is there a Target
Target oh I see it just does a little
thing okay you played around not brought
to you by Target by the way non-official
sponsor of this show
um let's see yeah but sponsor chess
y'all for real we got some I don't know
there you go uh Rook F3 a good move and
we're crying looking for sponsors for
chess always
they're really mad if he hangs this
night you know
dude if you and I could communicate just
with emotes for the rest of the show
that would be pretty awesome you you you
um you say emotes and then I'll
translate this inside your head I'm
thinking that when I speak with a
British accent I have a mustache and I
sound fancy that's that's my Italian wow
Queen b60 any danger levels
that is crazy what a move
yeah King H2 is safe Danny Queen B6
check was the top engine move by the way
yeah this man is nice big Tonka he is
the Cyber truck that's what he is this
this you know which by the way looks
weird AF
not that anything Elon Musk does these
days isn't weird AF but cyber trucks I
mean that is a fancy vehicle low
controversial
um all right Queen B6 check what a move
oh I just highlighted that oh my God can
we go to Tyler's stream does he see the
bishop move
let's do it
bring it up bring it up buttercup to
Tyler's stream we go am I do I am I
Really Gonna Take the one for a little
bit what do you say
I mean do I just say it and
just trade it I want to I'm not gonna
lie
but I'm better than him I'm better than
him I shouldn't I can do it
this is so huge he takes it with that
he doesn't see it yet
take his time D4 is also good by the way
Bishop C5 is the best but D4 also yep
come on Tyler
come on
it bro no
don't don't say that
I don't care no is he good oh no oh oh
it's still good he's still winning he's
up a pawn he's got a good position oh
goodness
that's crazy
well he goes from playing the engine's
Top Choice of Queen B6 to playing the
engine's bottom Choice trading Queens so
that that's fog Champs right there yeah
I mean I wonder what the worst move in
that possession was was losing the queen
but obviously I'm exaggerating but the
point is there were multiple winning
moves for black he unfortunately doesn't
see him
yeah I understand sometimes the
sometimes the audience will be like what
are you talking about there's no you
could worst move it was fun yeah he's
still winning he's still winning and and
he he got his night out and go Pawn here
uh he
Tyler is playing this game like a 1400
like like a blitzki you know 1400 who
just for some reason at some point but I
can go upon here
I agree and even though he missed it
living like he is seeing decent places
yep
he still has the castle though
ah put it down
don't do it
that's better uh but still not great if
if Alex sees Knight B5 yeah D4 is bad
you have to control your opponent's
piece play here which is a very tough
skill
very tough skill
and he should have played A6 first with
the pawn
Alex taking his time though doesn't
quite know what to do will he oh he does
see Knight to B5 it's a big moment
yeah this is tough
now he's castling
maybe we could add Tonka trucks to the
emo palette so you could put a Tonka
trunk on a square
we should do that I I don't I don't I
don't see why we wouldn't now what he
shouldn't do is he shouldn't move his
Bishop up because it's actually defended
so he could attack Whiteside he should
not move the bishop up because the
Knight to C7 would be a fork and that
would be really bad so please don't do
that don't do it don't do it oh no he
did it
the big Tonka truck is about to drive
off the cliff shout out to my brother
Dorian and the uh and the Tonka the
Tonka crew by the way oh
Tyler
is Alex going to see Knight C7 he
probably will oh the wheels are coming
off literally the wheels are coming off
the Tunica truck
the problem when you're 945 is that
you're just gonna be more accurate at
more moments in the game every move
Tyler has made since he traded queens
has been that a little bit worse than
fine it's fine it's fine
it's crazy because when when he played
Queen B6 check I thought we were about
to see the upset I thought we were about
to see your Bishop C5 and everything to
follow and uh unfortunately it fell off
and I I'm even worried that uh yeah I'm
I he's getting oh my goodness he is
getting double forked the double forkage
is double his double forking problematic
he just stole both of his Rooks he he
forked them on two he got double Fork
man
let's see how Alex is doing the double
forklifts
a double forklift on a Tonka truck by
the way that would be Tonka God stop
bringing in these pieces
clean
thing is should I threaten PA
I think I'll wear my get forked shirt
you don't want to try it here
it's hot in New York you totally can't
take off your shirt I don't think it's
against twitch TOS can we look that up
though is it
which job tomorrow it's just no shirt
[Music]
hold on look up bang is it okay to
stream shirtless on Twitch we don't
permit streamers to be fully or
partially nude including exposing
genitals or buttocks
we do not permit the visible outline of
genitals okay I should stop generals
even if they are covered we do not know
if the obviously broadcasting nude or
partially nude
is prohibited
um this is this is what we have to
resort to because Tyler's pieces are all
gone
what happened in this matchup you didn't
have to resolve Tyler was winning out of
the opening and now it is an absolutely
just wreckage well in the beginning he
was playing real well who wants to chat
to me who is this
I like it people are trying to talk to
me on chess.com and tell me the best
move to make I don't even need to know
the best moves I already know
uh
impressed for what's his rating 470 yeah
it takes an Australian man to say he
doesn't even need you to tell him the
best moves because he already knows the
best moves
that was a very very typical first game
and and as I mentioned the rating
disparity doesn't tell the whole story
between these two as I did a thing takes
a one-nothing lead but
it it does I mean there are different
elos for a reason and unfortunately just
Danny he was more accurate his mistakes
weren't as drastic and he was just a
little bit more accurate in the uh in
the mid game
yeah but it was it was this close to
being the other way right I mean Tyler
it was almost like a curse that he
already knew he was better because he
knew he was up a pawn so he's like all
right screw it he used an F-bomb word
but he's like I'm just gonna trade
Queens he didn't appreciate how much
better his position could have been
because he was already winning Levy
which often happens at this level
unfortunately
so right and he had it like right there
it was just a matter of puzzle solving
had he solved 15 20 more puzzles of that
pattern he would have immediately just
played D4 Bishop C5 so
it was right there
okay well uh
Big T big Tyler one will now get the
white pieces so he will have
the first move he will have the
opportunity to even the score and take
us to overtime I I think he's gonna do
it I think I think uh the Tonka truck
gets back
in the work yard insert metaphor and
drives up that hill lifts up the dump
dumps The Rock and
and okay
uh
we have moves moves have been we sure do
we sure do partner
boy do we have moves here partner we've
got a verisav if Tyler knows what he's
doing is he going to play the jababa
okay what's he gonna do Big T
okay
the London except with a knight on C3
who's who's Alex talking to let's turn
him up yeah oh he's got friends who who
watch him and ask him if he wants to go
spear fishing or something
I guess we haven't turned him up for a
beginning we're waiting for a beginning
I want to hear what Alex is saying
stand back a little bit
I was trying to make a joke but I
couldn't think of anybody I was going to
say move the make up a piece
just shut up you're distracting me shut
up shut up let's see if he sees this
what's this like
coming with the old uh
the old horsey horsey
I knew he was gonna say something about
an RC horsey like a kangaroo
a little rude yes
absolutely
I think I can afford to kick out of the
Australian accent I love it I'm not I
mean it's a kind of annoying isn't it
guys yeah thank you he doesn't need move
advice he's not getting move advice he
is the move advice
yeah I'm not worried about the other
friends being additives shout out to his
group of friends by the way if they're
watching no no insult meant but I I
would bet that Alex is probably the best
chess player in the room do I have a
nice movie if I go
there then porn comes in
push that up
what are you doing here he's cooking
it's going for that fork and then I mean
it's not worth sacrificing your your
Pawn there buddy your horse to make me
not be able to Castle
what other what else does he have there
does he have anything else take can't go
there can't go there
see what he does
I'll be very impressed if he sacrifices
his horse to make me not Castle
that's not the idea there was just a
free Pawn there oh there's something a
piece hell
I just love hanging pieces Tyler
let's go Tyler
there's even another Fork where's these
other folks if I come here
he doesn't have any Forks but he's just
won a pawn yeah nice and clean from
Tyler
in out quick kill
it was a good observation from chat
Tyler has been better in the opening in
a lot of his games though he's gotta
gotta stay on it in the middle game
yeah last game was tragic he kind of
lost the thread and Imagine This
with another thing thank you
it was a uh there was a delivery of a I
was gonna say shout out to whoever is
bringing water to a chess player you
know
I feel like that was just chicken breast
it was just she just brought him a tray
of just cooked chicken breast because
there's no way he needs so much protein
to sustain that body I mean that's how
much protein does he eat I'm gonna ask
him
I'm gonna ask it's called creatine bro
you just gotta take creatine and water
that's it
it's got to be a protein man like
there's no there ain't no way that that
man probably eats
I'm impressed seriously it's can you
imagine him chest boxing like imagine he
gets to a thousand bro needs to come out
lud has got to be working on that if
he's not already gotta get him chest
boxing
I'm gonna send another discount wait a
second no actually
the only struggle here for Tyler is the
fact that uh his position is a little
passive his Bishop is stuck yeah so now
he's gonna have to play some defense
which is a little unpleasant but uh
we'll see we'll see if he's able to
defend himself
come on Tyler
move the H Pawn
or the G Pawn or even the F1 at this
point
to have I mean anything just don't let
him take H2
here
he sees it
you should talk because it's quiet but I
want him to talk he's a very tense
moment
he's not talking
oh not that move no not that moved Tyler
no he could have just moved the other
Pawn
now he's in serious trouble
but the best move for black is to take
with the bishop not the Knight
if you think of the bishop
then the King has to move but the Knight
just gets stuck
oh
[Music]
you're right we should probably actually
show why Bishop was better because there
was a fork on F2 so we have a chance but
yeah let's bring it let's bring it back
to the uh the big bro I'm not gonna lie
whatever the going on here I'm
kind of over it
now he's talking
I love I love when he and xqc just say
things like
sideways beaked and and I'm just over it
like that's the analysis I'm just over
it and and Denny that was the best move
he got tired of the center so he just
he's just bulldozing the center
it's a great idea honestly legit and
Bishop takes H2 was the key for Alex now
now Tyler might win might give us some
overtime chess come on chat we're
rooting for Tiger I mean Tyler
I have a brother named tiger as well
I got you brother a brother named
nicknamed chanka and a brother named
tiger
I don't know what's real and what isn't
anymore I'm just gonna come and touch
this it's been a long day yeah Bishop H2
was better because it forces the king to
go here because if this there's Knight
F2 so King F1 uh and then and then what
just happened oh queen queen two was
played the Knight is stuck Danny the
bishop is about to get kicked out and
like Queen G5 is on the way but I think
I think Alex is going to play Bishop G3
all right let's turn him up what's Alex
talking about
beam me up Scotty
let's think let's think
Maybe
by the night over there it's free but I
don't want to break up the attack there
uh it's such a long move
okay I think we can just go here
push push I've just giving up the horse
the horse is hanging if I do that
uh
oh
on 25
there it is Danny
come on Tyler bring my other pieces up
E5 would be the most clutch move in the
history of fog Champs
that's right I didn't want to do that
anyway bro
I'm moving it I'm walking away
especially with Knight C6
E5 is still good on the next move though
can we uh let's let's bring it back to
to us uh yeah let's do it let's do it oh
oh he's walking into E5 E5 is money in
the bank right now E5 and and and that
might very well be it
come on Tyler
come on
E5
E5 he's walked right into it I mean you
literally you you don't have a move that
is more
direct assertive it's just right in the
center
just don't go Rook F1 Rook F1 looks like
it attacks the queen but it literally
Rook F1 is literally the worst move on
the board yeah literally you can't find
a worse move than Rook F1 can we zoom
into Tyler let's do it let's see if he's
gonna see it Tyler come on Pawn to E5 is
winning bro
no not the Knight the pawn no put the
put the pawn there man
you'll put the pawn there man to move
tonight though Tyler it's just tactics
it's all time dude he's looking he was
looking to Rook of blood for a second I
had a panic attack
oh no
the craziest part is Knight E5 is still
completely fine because after the trade
you can still trade queens and trap
Black's Knight which is the craziest
part about the position
that's true get out of my base
yeah what do you say get out of my face
I think so
but he could have done that with the
bond he just didn't realize
now oh it just takes its spot
no Queen to everybody plan that out
Queen G5 is also great
come on get the Queens off the board and
that Knight is trapped Queen F4 is
winning for white because it forces a
trait of queens or you lose the Knight
on H2
will he find it
above the edge of my seat
what
please don't play that move
wait no no that would be
that would be less than ideal right back
but the night back don't nope get the
Queens off
I don't know come on Tyler waste a move
one of these
that was not good let's show what could
have happened if he had done the move
you wanted Levy but it's not over yet
but quickly yep
yeah uh
one second I clicked off the window and
now I have to
get it back yeah Queen F4 was really
instructive uh yep I mean basically you
just hit the queen in the night
and uh
trade into a peace trap right and then
black she has to go here to get at least
one Pawn or else they would just lose
everything and this is totally winning
for white white gets this and
um
that stuff I mean queen F4 is a very
tough move and now he's losing after
Queen G3 so if black just brings the
pieces in that that actually is just the
end of the game
well Alex would have to see not just
that Queen G3 hits the currently
undefended Rook but threatens Knight F3
check oh no he played it oh
that is brutal uh
rookie three
maybe not totally over but
yeah rookie three would
would make it spicy
come on Tyler
he really could use some puzzles you're
not wrong because he's doing a lot of
things well his openings are fantastic
and he's definitely improved but he he
definitely has the potential to see more
tactics than he's currently seeing and
that of course we're talking about Tyler
one
I don't want this guy to go home
I know
as as wrong as it feels to root against
a man from Australia I am rooting for
for Tyler
I know I was really looking forward to
the upside I mean I'm just generally
cheering for the underdog uh Knight to
F3 is uh yeah is The Knockout but it
maybe it's tough to see I don't know
it's it is a check you always should
look for them even if you're being
attacked for example he could go Rook D2
and just completely hang the Hang The
Rook
all right let's turn up Alex what's he
got for us yeah what what's he saying
oh dear God this guy is I I did say
before the match started Levy and again
I'm not just bringing it back because I
said but I meant it that's why I'm
saying it I think this guy is a
legitimate threat to win the whole thing
like he's super underrated and I've I've
happened to have covered I think three
of the matches he's played
and look at look how quickly he spotted
that's the active Levy this is a very
good yeah this is a super good player uh
what more to say
no I gotta eat with the horse do I bring
the bishop in after or do I just bring
it in now
I love because I could bring it in just
now
and not even eat that
wait which way does it go though
um
I should eat that right I should eat the
hanging piece or do I come up with my
Rook
so I'm slightly scared of
slightly scared of that I could check
him again and then he wait is that
let's not checkmate
check he has to move back
check here he has to move back
I think I'm just gonna eat it
she's gonna eat it
now Tyler should take this because
otherwise his
King is in real Danger
yeah you have to think but I can stop
that with one thing and then if the
queen comes down
what are my options here I could just
I could start trading I could go check
and then eat the bishop underneath
is that or should I just push this piece
up
push this piece up
he sees that yeah
wow
[Music]
and then look up
no he can eat that there
Bishop is protecting that
let's just go that's what he's saying I
think let's trade some pieces here
traits and pieces what is he saying I
probably shouldn't be training yeah but
yeah
this why not
um Bishop he might be the best player I
could have continued so what I was
saying and you know we talked about
expensive flights from Norway if we're
playing if we're paying a flight from
Australia that's going to be the most
expensive flight we've done yeah I might
oh man have you checked if everybody has
a valid passport
uh no that was not we did not think that
far ahead although I know Alex was just
in La so I think it's okay okay
um yeah uh Bishop E2 was ridiculous I
mean and it follows the methodology of
uh always look for checks right and just
to see that is unbelievable
yeah it's unfortunately nice check for
all the lull fans out there the lull
um the low League fans I think we're
looking at the last moments of tyler1's
POG Champs and then Champs campaigns
behind it's not the worst Alex is just
too good yep there is one way to to to
to accidentally win here which is to go
Queen A5 thinking you're attacking the
pawn on A6 Danny yeah and then and then
with yeah
all right let's see what Tyler wants
saying tune in
I'm worried he's not talking too much
because he's down and out but we'll see
I think this will motivate him
it's a good move
yep still backering problems although
Alex can take the opponency too like
this game
my life
tough position night move Rook move it's
all bad
there's not much you can do here
you go
you move the Knight you might Checkmate
yourself on G2
I need to yeah
I don't know actually these all kind of
suck
truth
tough
it's a tough moment
oh
they should have taken the pawn to
protect the Knight it pretty much is the
same thing right
what
he's worried about his knife
yeah but Alex please
we still have chances for a back rank
mate let's not give up hope I'm not even
winning a rook here
I've gone from being the most hated man
in the League of Legends Community to
openly rooting for Tyler one
okay Alex will probably play check again
on H4
well the funny thing is he can actually
make a draw
that's true wow that's actually
unfortunate all he has to do is check on
H4 and check H1 and it's over yeah I
don't know if he's cerebral enough to
catch that but he definitely can
like he might just play for a win
because he can and he's supposed to
you know but
I don't even think he was thinking about
it what a good move there from Tyler
though look at that
I don't care what the computer says it
attacks the rug it pins the pawn on G5 I
like that move
by the way the clock is also now a
factor yep Tyler down to a minute but
but Alex not too far behind
we need someone's a great move
it uh it it makes things a little bit
delayed I think he's good uh and it's
difficult no he doesn't even have four
but he could just team the Rooks up
yeah and that's why it was given that
question mark from the computer is if
black finds that move and unfortunately
for Tyler Alex is just a machine take
yep Queen here I just try Dan then what
am I left with
so crazy clean here maybe yeah Alex
phenomenal just gotta go up
Queen where do I put my queen G
gee just go back to E7 and see if he
blenders the G5 Pawn
yeah I don't I mean
that's not a bad idea
Queen H1 yeah rookie two
oh that's fair but that's
you know they'll go here
I think it's it's a bit a bit deep to
make that make that play
yeah rookie two now is just winning
because if Rook C1 made okay plays Queen
G4 uh he loses A6
dude this guy is just so good
I know it gives a basics
it's Brooke it's made on G2
and just like that it's
like the Australian Queen the Australian
chess Australian for beer sorry that's a
weird one a Jess
Australian for dub Rook gets her out of
the way the queen at least this is so
wild it's made no matter what he does
yeah Alex is just he's a baller
crazy
Aussie Aussie Aussie oi oi
what are these moves here
I think this is looking like it's going
to be Checkmate very soon
oh he doesn't see it yet
no
no he doesn't wow
sick okay awesome awesome
he didn't play I didn't play that good I
I did not play that well
uh
Tyler's good though I feel like maybe
the uh the roids also help your your
your brain
[Laughter]
oh I'm so glad that Michael's live for
that moment we have a 2-0 victory by I
did a thing over tyler1 unfortunately
for all the league fans
the Tonka truck
is off the tracks
yeah that's a tough one that's a tough
one uh he was uh the runner-up in group
C and he went on the absolute grindest
of grinds the grindiest of grinds of
fuel Danny and he gained two or three
hundred points
but it just wasn't enough Alex was
unbelievable now Tyler would probably
disagree probably I thought things if
they run it back that he would get it
done but
for now well I wonder if he I wonder if
he did game review of that first game
and sees just how winning he was and
that was the match right there Levy
because I think he's also a player who
went confident plays even better I know
Tyler doesn't seem to struggle with
confidence but
you know
um he missed his chance in the first
game and then never got the truck back
on the tracks and I did a thing moves on
that's exactly right third out of fourth
semi-finalists
he now awaits the winner of our last
match of the day which is also coming
right up
yep we got one more match today we also
I think have interviews in just a moment
everybody so
oh man what a wild turn of events that
was I'm not gonna lie I'm a little
heartbroken a little part of me just
died inside with uh with tyler1's POG
Champs five campaign
but that guy
moves on in a 2-0 sweep over Tyler one
don't go anywhere we're gonna catch up
with Alex maybe Tyler as well on the
other side of this break POG Champs 5
returns in a few
foreign
[Music]
this looks so familiar
so he has to go to either H2 H3
I haven't been able to decide this one
but my 10 seconds pass fast yes yes yes
my feeling would be
definitely not H2 because H2 then maybe
e one night that's really a problem yes
so I have to go to H3 H3 Knight F4 PH2
my G4 check
then th1 Knight F2 check
very good
I know this one I'm just trying to
remember
so it's when the three nines get this so
King H3 Knight F4 Knight or uh
King H2 my G4 Chuck Knight G4 King
h19 freaking G3 right now King E3 the
stairway yeah very good
um okay let's
start with the King H2
kind of have to like this
um H2O would probably go E1 Knight
oh is this case of E1 light then Knight
F3
well yes but King history I will go
Knight F4
okay now I have to go to H2 Knight G4
okay now I have to go to H1 Knight F2
okay King H2 E1 light
and uh
attitude
oh Knight F3 another flicking G3 yeah
yeah Knight F3 Knight takes a three King
G3 very nice
I knew this one I was just trying to
remember the whole detail look you're
the only one that's uh remaining perfect
after
five studies last one why to move
yeah I've seen this one okay this one I
think I've seen before Queen G7 number
seven H6 easy yes yes
but what's the uh what's the puzzle why
the move
because you you saved the simplest one
for the last one this this is Queen G7
over here yes yes
wow
how did you get in here
so Queen G7 okay 7936 made yeah yes
that's it we saved the easiest for last
[Music]
foreign
POG Champs 5 rolls on this epic five
match Monday sees that guy who wasn't
even invited to the event ruin
everything and send Tyler one home just
kidding we like this guy he's got an
Australian accent at least he has that
going for him I did a thing Alex
congrats man
thank you thank you I plan to ruin your
whole event that's my that's my plan now
you're gonna give me a super expensive
ticket from Australia to go to La yeah
Tyler are you the most talented
Danny first of all I heard your comments
pregame
League of Legends is terrible you're
right bro no hard feelings uh what's
this guy
Gotham games yo bud I've been seeing
your YouTube shorts on on the tube been
helping a little bit anyway yeah I am
the most Raw
player here talent wise yes I have the
most Raw Talent at anybody here uh it
was a good game I I did a thing here uh
Alex great job bro he outplayed me I
wasn't good enough bro I've been
practicing last two days I should have
started last week if I started last week
and played like I've been playing the
last two days maybe I would have had a
shot he did beat me though unfortunately
I did when you lose in chess it's just
like oh I made a mistake but when that's
because the other person is making you
make mistakes you know what I mean guys
so GG tell her what's harder uh breaking
a PR
in lifting or chess
chess is not hard where's this little
fairy tale that you guys are like trying
to tell coming from is it a hard man you
gotta are they the patterns
if they move there I'm gonna move here
hard
it's not hard
Tyler did you know you were winning in
that first game as black did you know
that you had you could have won his
Queen
I lost winning
yes I knew I was winning I messed up on
like on uh What uh fork and then one of
my Kings Yes Man
you don't like League we're friends
we're friends
no that's not true I actually think
you're awesome and I tried to script
this whole thing to make sure you be in
LA and this dude from Australia ruined
it
you understand he wasn't even invited
how did he get here by the way
I didn't even know that God it looks
like a Greek statue there's nobody this
guy wasn't planted in the tournament
someone just sent me a zoom link and
then I joined and I was like oh I
haven't played chess now he's like oh so
what happened was lud I I told lud we
were coordinated everybody I told him to
invite daily dose he invites this guy or
then he tells never mind it was a whole
mix-up but either way Alex is here and
with jokes aside we are excited that
you're here playing chess even though
you sent everyone's favorite player home
so go win it bro go Win It Go win the
whole thing that way if
I lost to the best player okay do it for
me Alex do it for me or what we can do
or what we can do Tyler is if I were in
the next round and I get into the finals
you just turn up to the finals
that's great it's win-win
Alex the great news is if you if you
make it
I was gonna say Alex if you make it to
the final of pocket Champs you know
you're going to be the most famous
Australian chess player ever
are there any are there any no yeah
there are but they're very popular
totally yeah
that would be amazing there's like
there's like four of them yeah
and then I'll I'll make the Russians in
Australia so proud
would be great all the Russians in
Australia yeah yeah no my background's
Russian and I feel like there's not
enough representation of Russian
Australian chess players
oh well that's awesome that's why you
know we got some
one of the um one of the top young
talents actually is is Russia and
Australian so um that's actually that's
actually good good to know so anyway I
don't even know what else to ask you
guys you guys are both great Tyler we
are sad to see you go all all jokes and
memes aside you did grind by the way
rating
yep thank you guys nice to meet you guys
I tried guys I tried
you did you kicked ass it was awesome
that looks like something else
you guys invited this guy by the way
it was an accident it was an accident
we're never gonna get over the memes
um all right Tyler well um
I got nothing else for you tell Eva I
guess I'll leave bro I get it I'm kicked
out of the tournament my man fine I
understand
oh there you go Tyler's gone well I
guess I'm leaving as well Alex Alex I
know I know that I'm doing everything I
can to make you feel bad but we have
been super impressed by your chest Levy
and I said this guy is good and probably
a favorite to win the whole thing just
just so you know
what was the hanging my queen I'm just
hearing about that then did I did I did
he miss a fork on my queen
wait yeah when you block the check that
he gave with the queen he could have
moved you're gonna you can look at it
with the game review on chess.com he
could have moved the bishop and pinch
your queen to the king and he would have
it would have been really bad for you
yeah okay sick good to know
well it's okay it didn't happen and uh
our last question to you is your your
next opponent is uh the winner of the
matchup Sea Dog versus sapnap and I'm
curious if you've studied either of
their games if you care
uh or if you're just gonna show up and
get it done again
I'm honestly hoping that Sea Dog wins
just because he's the higher rated
player and I'm also mates with him so I
I would love to beat him you know live
yeah I love the amazing
in that win
stick around and uh stick around and
watch it
um maybe we'll bring you on as a
commentator at some point
um and uh
Alex
you crushed it good luck in the next
round whether it's Sea Dog or sapnap and
maybe we'll see you in LA
sounds great see you guys there first
class first class ticket to La daddy oh
hey hell yeah oh yeah
you have to cover half if it's first
class you have to go 40 hours later I
called it I called it
we may see in LA
uh seal that up
peace Alex
all right that was Alex the man from
Down Under gets it done sends home
tyler1 the fan favorite and um
he awaits the winner of sea dog and
sapnap and you heard it Levy he wants
his boy Connor to win
yeah I'm really conflicted on this next
match uh I've gotten to know uh sapnap
over the last few months
uh first of all we we have the same
management but also we've played a bunch
of just together uh and I've known Sea
Dog Sea Dog was one of my first collabs
Danny like 2020 yeah when chess first
got big you went through this I had to
go through this on the Creator side we
have to be like oh like everybody's
playing chess now and uh and I had to be
like wait a minute these massive
YouTubers and massive streamers want to
play chess with me so I was intimidated
so much when in my early days when I did
a collab with tier zoo or Sea Dog and
yeah he was one of the first people that
ever played chess with us and here he is
so I've talked magic for me
yeah no and he's uh sapnap is an OG so
is Sea Dog I think they both played in
pogchamps four uh whether they actually
played each other in that event I still
don't know
um or I'll have to I'll have to look
back and check but yeah Connor's an OG
um in the chess Community actually made
his debut in the chess Community with
tournament Arc which is an event that
was organized by our own uh R in Hawaii
o-o-g for those who've been watching the
chess category the last few years he
played in this event that was really
just for like anime anime voice actors
basically it was basically an anime
voice actors tournament called
tournament Arc there he is and uh
and uh Sea Dog made his debut sapnap the
minecrafter
now botez student
uh there he is drinking wine at six a.m
every day in Japan that's Connor that's
Sea Dog
here's the matchup card Levy what sticks
out to you yeah our tail of the tape you
know both weighing in at a nice uh 155
pounds Connor's standing at 511 and
sapnap at I think they're both about
five they're actually very close to the
same size physically I've seen them both
so let's just get them in a ring I mean
why are we even
anyway
um I don't know who my favorite is Sea
Dog is really solid but I feel like he
actually over relies on some of his
solidity and just being such a high
rated stable player uh sap dance capable
of some wild stuff uh and uh he didn't
believe in himself when he played
virtual Danny and he got two out of
three points on Virtual so
he's he also really wanted the really
wanted to be in the event just full
disclosure sapnap wasn't on the top of
our list to get invited because he had
already played and he was like begging
and and frustrated and even told Andrea
like they don't like me I don't know why
they won't like me but eventually we had
enough people to climb that sapnap got
in and here he is maybe gonna punch his
ticket to the semifinals and uh and be
in La so so we'll see dogs go ahead I
was gonna say well I know we got Sea Dog
I I was the first to message septap that
he was invited because somebody had
dropped out like okay that's right you
knew that he was also asking you why he
wasn't invited I was the one who tried
to get him in yeah man like I was like
trying to get in the nightclub and I'm
like yo I'm with this guy's with me like
don't worry about it and they're like no
we're booked right now I'm super happy
to see him here uh and uh I I yeah I
want him to win it's just a shame that
he has to go through a friend of mine to
do it if he has to do it you know what I
mean but I'll be happy whoever it is and
I'm super excited this is a really fun
Champions bracket this year you know
because I I feel like in previous years
we had an our eye on somebody Danny like
oh that person's definitely gonna win
and it does not feel that way I mean Sea
Dog almost lost two out of three to
Jarvis like anything can happen
I agree and we were just saying how we
thought that maybe the winner of Conor
and sapnap who were about to see is the
favorite but then after watching what
Alex did and just the tactics he was
seeing against tyler1 I mean maybe
that's the favorite right it's it's so
hard to call and of course everyone has
seen an xqc reformed and xqc reborn that
is playing maybe the best chess of his
uh of his POG Champs career so who knows
what's gonna happen all we know is right
now it is our last and final match of
the day thank the lord it's been
exhausting I want to throw something
here we go it is time for sapnap and Sea
Dog reverse order with Sea Dog playing
white first
yup and uh sapnap likes uh some gambits
he likes uh he likes to play the Italian
he likes to play the Blackburn chilling
okay so this is some some new Sea Dog
opening he's playing a Spanish instead
of a uh Blackburn chilling I mean
instead of an Italian so
I I have no clue what to expect all I
know is sea dog likes to do this stuff
Danny and Knight C3 Castle is a very
principled guy and then and then you
just play chess
and he's on he's on track he's also got
his glass are those blue light glasses
he's wearing
Maybe
I don't know I don't know Google Google
Glass I don't Google Glasses blue light
glasses you know to cut down on the blue
light I have a few pair of those I never
wear them probably while I'm going blind
um any Hooters um all right here we go
we're off to see the wizard and both
sides playing quickly right now yeah uh
sapdap employing A neostynus variation
of the Rue Lopez opening and Bishop D7
G6 Bishop G7 Knight F6 kind of thing
okay I was I was like joking but oh my
God
too
let's see what he's thinking let's tune
into sappy nappy Sad Panda
Snappers snappers just bring this
make it simple nice unpin that night
nice
there you go
he's calm he's focused so he brings this
episode
night move here we go
amazing
yeah okay should be some good stuff nice
and solid development right here I think
sapnap's strategy this game is
don't do anything stupid because Sea Dog
is a really solid player and I think he
thinks he can beat him as the game goes
on
yeah and Snappers has already won in
some type rates
um the attack that I'm trying to do I'll
explain myself
with against his opening his castle
bring this Knight back and storm that
this F Pawn I want to take control
because then once I have control here
all my pieces are coming I even want to
bring this Knight eventually I want to
bring all these pieces that are in the
middle to that King side and just come
and Ram him
is the idea wow we'll see how Levy did
you hear that idea he's gonna have some
tricks yes he said he wanted to fudging
Ram him
not that the stuff before that that was
dude that was stuff that I struggled to
get 1500s to understand as far as the
river structure going in the direction
yeah of your lead Pawn that I was like
let's get sapnap's voice out of here no
just bring them right back we want to
analyze something you just said
seriously we got to go back to the board
because that was deep go ahead yeah
sapnap basically just so clearly sapnap
has a strategy which is Castle on the
same side as a Sea Dog drop his Knight
back and use an f-pawn to create a same
side attack now what's funny Danny is
one of the first lessons I gave to him
like a couple of weeks ago we were just
like reviewing some games uh at uh like
at like 11 o'clock at night and I said
if you have an opponent that likes to
Castle quickly one of the strategies you
can employ because you're an attacking
player is wait for them to Castle and
then find a way to Castle opposite side
and then that way it facilitates your
attack so it seems like he's made like a
slight hybrid plan where he castles on
the same side especially if it's
impossible to Castle opposite way and
he's still trying to employ the attack
which for this level is like
ridiculously good I mean seriously this
is a slightly flawed approach you won't
see this at the World Cup of Chess but
you know whatever we have more viewers
than they do so yeah that's right no but
but no but structurally you're right
regardless of whether it's completely
positionally sound we see the eval bar
likes white this is a positional idea to
attack in the direction of your Pawn
chain exactly Levy's highlighting it I
doubled up on your highlight I just
triple stamped a double stamp Lloyd you
can't triple stamp a double stamp and I
did it oh I I wasn't highlighting
anything
but that was you hold on Magic
Levy whoa can you see this
oh my God
what's happening
has taken over the
I wish I had my favorite YouTuber with
me there he is he's everywhere
ah what are we doing okay sorry back to
the show any anyway this is a very good
idea to look to create space in the
direction of your lead Pawn again even
if it's not positionally totally sound I
was I was super impressed
and look at his time Advantage too Levy
yep what is a massive time Advantage
yeah Connor's thinking Conor plays slow
he's a slow player he really uses his
time uh but the good news is he he could
just take and and he will be fine uh but
people are much worse Defenders than
they are attackers that's just the
reality so sapnap's playing style is
really conducive to gaining ELO because
he might play openings and attacks that
aren't blessed by the computer but the
computer is not playing at his level so
yep this is a good strategy
well Conor is on the clock
and uh over a three minute difference
already
shout out to Joe Berlin
whoa check out Connor I'm checking out
A3 yeah let's check out Connor Connor
just played a random move I mean he just
he just played a move not to lose on
time basically
it no
yeah
I gotta turn that off what is he or is
it what is he drinking it's it's six a.m
Conor what are you doing six or is it
eight in the morning is it 13 hours what
time is it in Tokyo
what time is it in Tokyo oh right it's
13 hours
wow
819 yeah
nice little time for a little bit of tea
nice little bit of time for a little bit
of tea in it right hit the spot one two
three times already I've hit the spot
um
this is a park Champs game with 97
average accuracy right now
seriously
just gotta chop it down he can't let
sapna
plays in the center yeah then as as
sapnev himself said he's gonna Ram him
yep with an F with an F-bomb before he's
going to bleeping Ram him
are the guests can curse but the
commentators can't right is that it I
mean we can curse I just tend to hold
back obviously people who know me in
real life tend to tend to be aware that
I have a bit of a potty mouth IRL but
it's never been my brand to drop to drop
curse words I've cursed a couple times
on stream I've used up so much more time
than him but I just want to make anyone
can you know people
I generally try to keep it PG as the dad
in me but POG Champs is its own show
yeah we'll do what they do okay
oh yeah
good move from sapnap not the best but
it was the subtle differences are too
hard to understand
[Music]
I don't curse ever I I
I'm like Eric Rosen I think the idea the
cleanest brand which is I want to
utilize the fact that it's pinned
by attacking some squares
yes
I'm not so clear right now problem is if
I can't move this Pawn
[Music]
uh meanwhile I'm cheating because I'm
looking at the lifeboard but uh you're
about to see it on the Sea Dog stream
sapnap yeah knows what he's doing I mean
that man just played F4
yeah let's let's swing this thing around
right where you kick it into reverse and
you do that thing where the car flips
around in Fast and Furious before you
know it they're driving backwards dude
what a move these guys are playing chess
this is this is yeah this really I mean
okay we can get Peter leko here too can
you imagine Peter leko doing some POG
Champs commentary I mean God bless that
would be hang on
D4 one day I'm gonna meet Peter leko and
he's gonna tell me he's seen all the
clips of me doing his voice and it's not
gonna it's not gonna go well whatever it
is oh no Danny
Peter lecco loves loves the commentary
um
okay
we can highlight why we were so
impressed if we won F4 we were impressed
by because sapnap had a plan D4 is
literally the Thematic move to undermine
the pawn structure and Connor finds it
just is like this is high level chess
here
yep and it savtap wasn't patient and
it's not even that he's not patient he
he is completely lost like after 95 it's
a fork and then you remove the defender
of the bishop like the game is over
Bishop takes F6
it's not even it Danny it's not even
complicated because he wants this and
that's defending that so you take that
that's it no honestly the the one thing
that's catching up with sapnap is he
just played way too fast and that
actually is an Achilles heel for him he
had a great plan he saw the positions
well there was no reason not to take a
minute you're up five minutes on the
clock slow down now he's blundering a
piece
yep yeah I did see that yeah five
minutes is crazy I mean D4 by by Conor
is a
hit yeah him versus I did a thing will
be will be a crazy man well it's not
over yet no no I know that's white you
know yeah I'm just saying subtle
detailed moves like D4 really show a
person's chest skills okay you know
because sapnap was sort of playing on
idea on feel and queen F7 was just a
lack of concrete awareness that that
pawn is is capturable and
um he had to stay patient and you know
and it was playing too fast yeah he just
played too fast because he was so
obsessed with his plan Levy look why do
you play Queen of seven he played queen
of seven because he was obsessed with
his plan oh my God and now he's
blundering he's gone full botes never go
full botes oh that's yeah that's rough I
won't even make a joke about who his
coach is that's just tough yeah that
from bad to worse oh Connor is stripping
it down I mean my goodness he's going
skinny dipping and the E Pawn just goes
forward like it's not even
oh God
okay it's not over because sapnap gets
white he's a good player we know it and
he just played too fast but this game we
might as well ship it right I'll just
turn off the lights the lights just went
out yep I wish oh you know what I could
can I
yeah lights out there you go we're
commentating in the dark
I know man it's pretty sexy in here
lights on or lights off or whatever
you're into baby
it's lights out for sapnap which is what
I'm doing it's a metaphor everyone stop
freaking out
I'm just commentating in the talk don't
mind me I'm just going to sit in the
dark all by myself
don't mind me
and you can hear me right oh yep I can't
apparently
I'm flying solo for a little bit Levy
you're gonna take a break
seems I have lost any
no we can hear Levy but Levy can't hear
us
it's really weird hey Danny we're here
oh you're back
we're back with Levy
oh man well
um you're back it's good you're like
Danny you're like the kid in the class I
see you you do something bad and I do
something bad and then I I like I like
knock over everyone's science project
and then I get in trouble bad influence
bad influence Danny it's true that's why
they kicked me out of school and I never
went back
um
okay but seriously Conor is rolling
regardless of sapnap's mistakes and
maybe we should tune into sapnap he's
definitely
frustrated but let's see what he's
saying let's see if he can keep himself
in the right mindset when we have a
moment because he hasn't stopped talking
since he lost the queen
what you got for us happy
the problem is I go here
I'm just gonna go here
this is yucky very yucky
I go here he's gonna go here and then go
here
and then he's just gonna pin me
I don't even know
I know I don't want to pin The Rook so
you're just going to push again it's
fine ish I mean look at these pawns are
a little bit protecting right from like
anything like super nasty it's a rook
The Rook is hanging
I don't think Connor sees it does he see
it
I mean he can literally just just March
your Pawn down
he's uh
oh how frustrating is that just
blundering my queen and blowing that all
right we'll resign we go next we go next
game there's no point playing this out
yeah we go next game good call uh that
was really disappointing
it is too bad I feel like it's white
especially not to give up my early game
like my my where I'm at now I really
want to spend those extra minutes in the
start because that we can play fast at
the end
I just really want to really slow the
game down and make sure like every move
if it's not doing anything at least like
I think the problem is sometimes I get I
get in this thing where nothing's
happening like I think
yeah like I get to here
and I'm like okay I could try and make
something I could start something but I
genuinely think that I'm in a winning
position this is this is terrible
I think this is not good given the way
the way the board is if I just slow it
down I just let him yeah that was great
stuff by the way
Connor's analysis his patience his Poise
taking us through his mindset that's why
he's up one nothing Levy
yeah I felt bad he was like doing a big
analysis and we just said nope here's a
player card of today's scores uh yeah I
but I know we gotta we gotta get moving
to the next game uh yeah it's one to
nothing and that was really good stuff
uh we got to see into the mind of both
players sapnap did a whole strategy
Conor was affected by it he spent a lot
of time and then he was lamenting the
fact that he spent a lot of time and he
said I don't have to force things I
should just you know I should stop
overthinking it but he didn't he
both players
all chess players struggle with this
both players have slightly incorrect
self-analysis right like sapnap thinks
that he messed up really badly but
I mean he didn't hang the queen he
played Queen F7 that was the real
problem and then he he just played a
little too quickly and uh yeah I mean
Conor's like I played two he played at
96 accuracy like what do you want yeah
like like the best game of POG Champs
it was a super great game by Conor I
think that the patience shows his
experience I'll be honest I still think
against the toughest opponent if sapnap
doesn't blunder he's going to get
himself under time pressure Levy we'll
see what happens in game two but you
still have to applaud the Poise you know
what I mean his mindset was like Hey I'm
not gonna rush things he he put himself
in a bad spot with these passive
retreating moves and I'm gonna be
patient and so I uh I like it
I like it too uh and and savnap plays E4
sapnab has been playing uh the Vienna as
of late and wow Conor plays the Sicilian
Defense I have never seen him play this
opening that is crazy
and said that he's just working on his
chest sapnab's going for what I guess he
thinks is a Vienna although it you can't
play the Vienna against the King's Pawn
I mean against the Sicilian but now it's
a Grand Prix so he's playing it I was
gonna say maybe he knows the Grand Prix
at this point I have no idea maybe I
also don't know I I and but just for the
record anytime I teach somebody the
Vienna or any opening I say you cannot
play this against anything except this
but this is still a good setup against
the Sicilian I used to play this all the
time as a kid it's probably why I never
got to Grandmaster but uh you know it's
you get attacking positions and
all this good stuff over here
yeah I mean the the Grand Prix is uh
it's a ton of fun it's like you said
it's maybe not the best opening against
the highest levels of the Sicilian but
who cares like this is a great opening
for white
um okay but look at Connor playing G6
dude knows his openings right now
yeah it looks like he's playing the
dragon looks like it's which is the
easiest opening to play In the Sicilian
because you you fight for the same
square it's very easy to teach new
players this opening uh sap is going to
go here and he's going to Castle and
then he's gonna start an attack
wow
all right let's take a listen into Sea
Dog we know where a couple moves ahead
on the live four live board we'll get
caught up with uh Conor's perspective
see what he's thinking
does he know to play E6 to block this
one stop which is nine this way
that's true that's gonna be a big
question
oh
I get this here
or I could just do this and kind of put
an end to the system right away
and then gives my knight a few options
of how I want to expand it
that is so crazy if he is gonna put the
Knight behind him in a tight spot now
wow
we can we can we can worry about it
we'll get it out we'll get it out that's
so wild
now big moment is he gonna put his knife
this move which is good but I think I
want to bring this over here before I
try that
again
okay I'm looking for something as if
it's gonna help me
you know make sense of how Connor woke
up and he's in 1800 plus chess player
that
is worse does he understand why
it's worse to block the bishop and let's
see does he understand the difference
between the two yeah 97 is key here stay
out of the Bishop's way
dope with the Knight on F6
oh
[Music]
demons are kicking in
ah okay he's human after pushing here is
bad for me
okay yeah let's make this thing very
he's playing very fast uh what's funny
is the D5 here it's not necessarily the
best because it opens up the king and
then sapnap could get some
it's all fine obviously but he could get
some attack
no I think you're right though I think
castles is
castles is way safer especially at this
level first get the king out of the
center and then go back to D5 yep
like Bishop E3 D5 D4 very common
little four Little Fork job
well Fork job in the center you heard of
The Italian Job starring Edward Norton
and Mark Wahlberg that is one of my
favorite movies
really yeah great movie what makes me
want to get a Mini Cooper
yeah that's right just drive it through
the streets I have a Venice I have a
question for you
trivia question I had to set a trivia
recently how many Mini Coopers were used
in the filming of The Italian Job
give me an over under
uh what is that like over a certain
amount under a certain amount or yeah
like pick a number that's close in the
middle and see if I can get it right
because I'm never gonna guess the random
number
uh it it it's uh it's 10 to 20.
okay so I'm gonna get 16 Mini Coopers
you're right
are you serious yeah it was 16. holy
crap 500 just there you go pulled that
out of that there you go 16.
I thought it was three because I thought
it was like because you know there was
three and they used three so I thought
it would be three like it would just be
a cool thing but no it was 16.
wow you know how I got that because I
used the psychology you would have said
between 10 and 20 if it was at least my
brain went he would have said between 10
and 20 if it's at least 15 so I'm gonna
guess one more 16. that was literally
what I said in my head and just guess
16. you should play poker why why are
you why are you here on commentary you
know how much money disabled in the last
five hours wow
let's take a look at the sapnap while I
Revel in my random 16 number pulled out
of a hat yeah we gotta give credit to
sapnap Danny for playing E5 by the way
that is the whole reason that Sea Dog's
plan is wrong and safdap is punishing
him for it if he moves his Knight here I
take that would be very bad if he wait
this is totally right this is really
good he has to move his Knight and he
has to move it here
essentially otherwise I'm gonna take it
I'm gonna get a free night
well no it's here I'm being stupid
he needs to move it there or here's I
guess and then he can't Castle he's
gonna move it here
if he was here I push it
I
I just push
right
then where's he go
here no
just good good for what yeah
that's a good position
here take he's clicking that thing so
intensely
what is the right move I have time just
to sit back and think and look what he
can do
now this is good slow down use your
advantage on the clock find the right
move you might push the pause just take
and he takes
or something he's not thinking he's he's
not using checks captures attacks if he
just says reroute this night I don't
like this Knight in the middle that's a
good advice you remember
take this and then reroute this Knight
here I think that no
no
at least play the first move
in the middle it's causing me so take it
pressuring my Queens pressuring's Pawn I
don't like it I don't know if that's the
best move it's probably not it's
probably a more force it was literally
the best moment
no no no no now slow down Ah that's the
prop right there like he's not going
through your list Levy checks capture
that's also attacking this problem which
here
pretty stuff it's tough because I'm
cheering for the underdog I'm also
cheering for a close match
I'm sharing for overtime chess cheering
for uh you know protege
sap them
golf nap thanks for the 500 best so it
sounds better or goth nap gothnap
some dark makeup some dark eyeliner hit
the nap you become goth now he's gonna
move his Queen here
he's right Queen B6 is the best move
he's going to move his Queen there but
what do I do what do I do I need to keep
this pressure up I think I just go we'll
Conor finder that's the question push
push this I don't know I need one Queen
H4 it's crazy he saw Queenie one Queen
H4
but he needs to see that he can take the
Knight on D5 and triple the pawns yeah
that could be ugly ooh yeah going to six
playing
Conor finds him
crazy
what can he do can't take this
okay here I think you go here
not even not even considering taking
them come over here
he's just made it kind of permanent in
his mind
you
uh let's bring it back I feel like I
feel like I feel like uh we've got him
up there for for a bit Yeah taking here
is the best and Danny just to show like
this is so miserable for black these
triple pawns and then uh White is much
better much much better B3 Bishop B2
A4 A5 is also strong
while we have the analysis we're gonna
back up a moment and just show how much
better sapnap was if he had taken on D5
earlier because he found this E5 idea
you pointed out that the Knight on F6
was bad by Conor but he just didn't
follow through and just take everything
on D5 and
you're crushing it's just F5 like you
don't even you don't wait you just take
I mean you literally just butcher him
Bishop H6 Queen G4 Queen here King here
yeah it's a it's apparently a plus six
Advantage at that point like as you get
to H6
so wow but Conor just played A5 which is
a crazy move and again Bishop takes D5
is just positionally winning three
triple Pawns
but they both made it but they both made
in you know under the table agreement
that the Knight on D5 shall not be taken
like Gandalf
I shall not pass
yeah and and sapnap does this a lot uh
in his game against Gastly gasly played
a super random A5 but was already here
and he still responded but there was no
need to respond right now
um
yeah now night before I guess is what he
was trying to stop but
it's funny because they're both playing
great chess like especially you know the
brand of POG Champs yes we see where a
lot of players are new to the game right
no disparagement it's just these guys
are playing high level chess but there's
some critical ideas that are game
changing and now Conor are in a great
spot with that Knight on E3 I know the
eval Bar says White's still better but I
actually think sapnap has missed the
best of his opportunities already
now he has he has to take so he no
longer can afford Rook moving and
getting hit with this Fork because he'll
just lose a full Rook at that point
uh and then he has to find Pawn to D4
which is very tough to find that he's
better but he he will not understand why
because this Pawn is hanging and
it's very messy at this point oh tragic
just like that things are turning around
oh even if he had seen Bishop takes E3
like you said Levy finding D4 to follow
so the eval bar was already wrong from a
practical point of view black was in
control the moment the Knight landed on
E3 yeah
black was totally taking back the game
uh there is only one hope remaining here
for sapnap and it's the fact that he can
create an attack like he could play
Queen H4 and just go for it and just say
you know what I'm down a rook pogchamps
clock is ticking
uh yeah and I just gotta go for it and
and I mean look at Sea Dogs time by the
way three minutes on the clock
let's go to sapnap we see him talking we
know he's a little frustrated
um he just banged the table because I
think he only just realized how lost he
is with the fork
yep
just being an idiot
oh we're gonna lose it's GG
we have some ideas but
yeah you definitely can't resign though
like that just go for it get aggressive
yeah here you go he's gonna take it
there you go take him taking the uh page
out of Levy rosman's book by the way
check out the book How to Win It chest
by Levy Rosman already has 10 000
pre-orders yeah right here it's right
here it's beautiful beautiful book can
we just put this out of my image no no
no camera necessary I'll just there we
go
seriously do we have a link for Levy's
book when he's commentating we should
let's add it for chat for tomorrow oh I
I I I I it's very humbling
there's still a few signed copies
available by the way they're not all
sold out uh there's 400 left
I've been told today so
I just added the command book by typing
book that doesn't actually have the
command I know I'm not that twitch
illiterate but I'm just shout out to the
mods crushing it let's add a link for
Levy's book
any Hooters Levy he did play Queen H4 if
he plays F5 he's all in and it's not
over like you said
I don't see anything super cookie I can
go I'm just getting demolished oh very
disappointing I'm trying to listen to
something he's he is
we just swing this here we have time
it's the only thing on our side he wants
to go here
I can't really stop it but I see five
don't have five
okay Knight G3 is a fantastic move Danny
here
that's true dude if that night lands on
D6 there you go
uh here here we're F6 spring I mean just
go in
like if if Conor castles in this
position all his Advantage is gone heck
by the way I created a monster
everyone's spamming for the link to your
books
they have to ask the parents to buy it
stop it
every single viewer is breaking the
switch terms of service all right Knight
B3 let's go sapnap put the Knight on e4
yeah this bishop and C1 is trapped
so I get my knight in here
where can you set up still on the screen
like she's taking a pee break I want to
analyze the position can we please go
back let's do it let's go back here
let's analyze him here I uh I I I was
like I keep hearing sapnap talking yeah
Knight E4 okay wonderful
um
yeah
dude the night is coming to D6 and the
queen comes the d8 and it's me it's made
it's made on the board yeah Queen T1 is
a huge mistake Rook F1 and and white is
winning
yep
also castles Knight F6 Rook H3
it's a very tense moment here
you could kill the censorship with a
knife right now castling is fine uh a
move ago Black's pieces were a bit
passive so white had the luxury of
creating an attack but now black is kind
of arriving here
uh Conor might not Castle because he's
worried of the attack but it's actually
his best move
also Levy wow Conor's down to a minute
and a half this is It's not over it's
not over it's not a dooba no it's not
over Knight F6 Bishop takes Pawn takes
and then you got oh my goodness gracious
oh oh my God Danny Queen D1 Rook F1
Queen H5
is the only way not to lose
wow
dude
there's no way Connor oh my God oh my
God zapdap's winning oh my God Queen G5
King H7 and then F5 Queen H6 dude okay
is he gonna find this oh my God he
played Queen G5 oh my God
production I love you all sorry for
making fun of you please take us back to
slapped app now because everyone is
winning
the sapnap we go to the bat cave I just
crawl in
he finds out five he's winning oh my God
oh my God how does he stop this wanna
come back he moves The Rook over Dude
his only way is to bring in his Queen
and Sack the queen for the bishop that's
the only way to stop getting really bad
time to Castle oh my God I have life he
only has a minute to figure this out wow
he has to move the Rook it's the only
place to move the rock he moves The Rook
here
I think it's still he's gonna get mated
there's no way to stop this
he has to bring his Queen in somehow wow
the queen here I don't know I don't know
how he stops this
that's wrong that's wrong
that's wrong Rook F1
just block with the road it's over
and he's only got a minute too we're
going to overtime people
this is insane Queen H6 it's game over
it's mate it's Unstoppable man over here
don't chase him I think it's over on I
think it's over believable holy I
think it's over please don't get too
excited I mean what's he do he pushes
the pawn doesn't matter it's mate he
moves The Rook it's it's it's it's mate
in two moves
yes sir yeah
yeah holy shout I gotta go see what
they're saying now
I think it's over
that's crazy Lee bleep balls holy
forking shirt balls that's what I have
to say we have overtime in this match
God
damn I told you you could do it one to
one and if you want to be a level in
chess you cannot respect that level
Danny it was over he was writing himself
off and then we were saying the only
chance he had was to go create an attack
and he did he was down a rook and he
went for the king because the King is
worth more that was incredible you
called it too you're like it's not over
Queen H4 there's pieces coming to the
king side and it shows you a huge lesson
in development right black was up a rook
and freaking whatever but he wasn't even
using the pieces so unbelievable we have
overtime chess let's remind everybody of
the format and what that means it means
it's time for Blitz boys and girls
instead of 10 minutes plus five seconds
we have three minutes plus five seconds
white will be the player who had the
more accurate brand of Chess through the
first two games we don't know who that
is yet we will let you know shortly if
we are still tied after one more game we
simply switch colors and do it again
until we have a winner sapnap has just
forced overtime despite Connor are being
up a whole freaking lot of pieces in
that game dude that was unbelievable but
it's kind of funny because we saw it
coming Levy like you could kind of sense
it it was like Hey this isn't over and
sapnap goes for the kill
yeah and he sensed the two he knew he
had messed up he knew he was losing uh
but he said like all I gotta do is go
over here and just get some pieces
forward
um I think Connor will have white
because his first game was 96 accuracy
but I do think it's an it's average and
according to the game review I'm seeing
sapnap had an accuracy 14 higher in this
game so as long as his first accuracy
was not that far away
no Sea Dog was more accurate through the
two games by one percent it was 74.6 to
73.4 on average Conor gets white I don't
even know that it matters I think they
both you know are are very closely
matched
um but I'm gonna say this Levy I think
that sapnap is the favorite in Blitz the
fact that he plays so fast could have
hurt him in the rapid games because we
saw him blundering Levy I think he is
the favorite in the faster time control
yeah yeah Conor spends the entire a lot
of time of Blitz in the opening I mean
the last time that they had this game uh
it was yeah and look at Conor playing
two Pawns in the center very confident
he's gonna Castle I agree with you move
10 15 of some of these games Conor has
already spent half his time so
but let's I I think the better chess
player overall is probably Conor but the
but but in in Blitz specifically and
with the momentum I do think sapnap has
some I mean look at Connor up to 325
yeah
it's funny because sometimes the slower
player rapid does wake up and Blitz and
it looks like Conor's about to make me
eat my words by saying that I thought
sapnap was the favorite he's playing so
fast Conor is up on the clock
um
yeah but yeah
taking on C6 is just one of these
examples of like it's blitz so I'm just
gonna take I'm Not Really Gonna think
about it yeah H3 is a funny move rookie
one he's just making quick improving
moves he's lost his Advantage because
he's allowed black to catch up but now
F4 is good knight D5 is good
yeah it's a good position for white as
long as he plays fast am I allowed to
openly root for sapnap though so I don't
have a third international flight to
cover to La I've already got Alex
likely and then we've got virtual
winning the consolation if Conor wins we
got a boy coming in from Japan to like
can I just can I just speak real quick
as you know just trying to save a little
money maybe I'm not allowed to do that
on camera never mind I mean what's more
expensive Australia to LAX probably
right because he's coming Tokyo to LAX
is that oh that's right only one of them
can get there they play each other in
the next round okay never mind we're
good whoever wins wins all right
tremendous and anyway xqc will walk over
so will the boat test is you're saving
some money you know Hess and I are
taking a private jet from New York
that's right that's right that's right
um all right look at that we have a
trade will the Queens come off or will
we see Levy rosman's queen of three Rook
D1
Levy highlighting like a GM you may not
be a GM but you're a GM and highlighting
Levy in my heart I'm I I can read the
minds of these players better than they
can read their own minds uh they have
Rook D1 Conor doesn't trade
unnecessarily and the Knight is just
better than the bishop
just is there's no way around it there
is Bishop D2 but that might lose you the
game after Rook D1 so be very careful
let's take a look at what Connor's
saying we didn't get a lot of commentary
from him last round because we were
watching the comeback from sapnap so
what do you got first Connor
apparently nothing
no I agree completely wait stop let them
cook
this is like NPC waiting screen music
you know you just
like you're like a character that's just
waiting to do something you know in
Grand Theft Auto
like how they just stand there and
they're just like
um
wait my whole life is NPC Danny what
what was B4 this is a random B4 it just
came out yeah seriously it it was
exactly that a random before
by the way now Bishop D2 is money okay
you better stop it
yep
accidentally or purposely we don't know
this is so stressful
all right they're all coming off
everybody's coming off it's just
breathing into a microphone let's let's
let's let them let's let the players
have their time to focus uh black is now
better because this Pawn is on B4 I mean
that's basically the only reason
uh
and um
yeah let's bring it back maybe what do
we got here a queen end game
yep the Escape Square for white is the
same color as this bishop there is an
opportunity to get mated that is a
brilliant move and now sapnap has to
find Queen E7
we can go to sapnap if we want he seems
to be a little more talkative than Conor
but sapnap has to find Queen E7 or the
queen side Falls the entire Queen side
all the pawns come off
what is sapnap saying
let's go check it out hopefully he's
confident I don't want to treat Queens
think boom
oh
boom it's a draw boom
okay think think think I have a little
bit of time to think here boom boom
he's gonna he's gonna gobble everything
though in that time
he does have Queen C1 check if you don't
go here yeah is at least the draw
I think we go
I think we go aggressive we need to go
aggressive we have a check here and then
here that's crazy
I mean this is dangerous can you have
this check here seriously
check he goes here check Jackson gets C2
and that's mate
so this is me and two if he misses it
no
no no
cg3 but it's okay
it's the issue he blocks if he doesn't
defend the square I'm gonna check meet
him I'm sure he sees it though if he
does not defend the square he gets
checkmated well he doesn't he will get
checkmated because this there's there's
a meeting that here there for sure is a
meeting that
I have no doubt on my mind
go God with those Pawns
he doesn't see it's not me no
it's over
oh no
he can take the pawn
you can take the pawn still Queen C2 is
a really good one though
Queen C2 is at least the draw mm-hmm
here he takes takes
it's a good idea one square draw no yep
it's crazy
I think we attacked this point oh now
Queen C6 is very dangerous there has to
be something there
I can start pushing these pawns he's not
wrong it's very dangerous for white but
yeah threatening winning a piece here
okay night come on come on the winning
move
that's the only move can I can I show
that on the analysis board everything
else is
yeah we have to show it real quick no
everything else loses for Conor and in
fact he played a bad move yeah Queen C2
Knight D5 sacrificing the queen or going
for a Checkmate and getting into a
winning End Game Night versus Bishop but
he misses it and instead he goes Check
King H7 Knight D5 oh my God Danny oh my
God the only move here for black is
Bishop F4 hitting the positive what in
the world because
Queen F7 guards F2 he had to seal off
the queen that is unfindable
dude but Conor has to see it too oh
Connor okay he does see Queen F7 and and
this is it but oh by the way does Connor
see Knight F6 check as a threat yeah if
sapnap takes with the bishop Knight F6
is mate yeah yeah that's it Queen F7 is
an attack it's a defense Bishop F2
trying to set up a discovered attack
Knight F6 check you can't take King h8
any of these moves are checkmate
oh my God that's unbelievable and now
Conor is just two phones up in an end
game
sapnap has to take under two with the
queen in order to avoid the Checkmate
that still loses but he has to do it yep
you could go like Queen C6 but that's
just not I don't know that stops Knight
F6 but
oh my goodness yeah but there's there's
Knight E7 in that case okay either way
this is big trouble assuming the players
see all the ideas
uh oh yeah he goes Queen F2 again and
now Conor should just
bring his King
and it is plus five because black just
doesn't have any Targets and is just
losing a pawn race on the queen side
stranger things have happened we already
saw it in the uh the match with xqc and
papa plot
oh yeah King G5 King H4 hello yeah here
we go
Connor not even using his Queen side
majority no no luckily he can go here in
H4
that's true in fact black almost gets
himself mated ah there it is there it is
uh King G2 back don't just lose pawns
for no reason
okay that was bad that was a bad sign
for sapnap Conor finally realized he has
two on one as you're highlighting ah
snap that freaking out over there
no there's not much you can do you just
don't have the material required to
fight off the Knight
by the way there's a Checkmate if you
see 97 97
G5
that is a brutal way to go out
amazing
A6 not over Knight C7 Bishop C3 oh 986
guards before
no but still okay wow Conor playing high
level chess here not even talking much
he is zoned in both players can feel it
their POG Champs five campaign comes to
an end or continues right here
you could get stalemated Maybe
Maybe
like me your voice gets higher when
you're not sure
yeah I think that there
is
[Music]
me I can't do it any more than that
that was great oh man
okay wow Conor goes B5 but do you think
he's hallucinating dude he could lose
this
if he goes all in with A6 B4 oh okay he
took the pawn yeah he's gonna say holy
bejesus
I mean Danny I can I can do my my I can
do my uh
do it just do it the voice do it
you know what I'm about to do I know
what you're about to do and I want it
give it to me it's when people give me
their Prime subs and I go thank you
ha
she just do the whole commentary in that
voice
this is a pretty tricky position for
some
um Knight takes bishop and pushed the
pawn and it's just it's it's over
what's up
we gotta make you do a little giggle
okay
all right Bishop E3 played here comes
the eight Here Comes eight six yeah A6
hopefully neither player rewatches the
commentary uh seadog's got 18 seconds by
the way
okay okay okay
there's a chance Danny Danny Bishop C5
A6 kh4 A7 Bishop takes Knight takes kh3
black wins Ah that's the wrong way oh no
dude
that would have been crazy I I oh no now
he's all in he's just he's just playing
for stalemate is there a stalemate can
you possibly can you possibly say like
Bishop H6 and then get pinned it doesn't
work
uh Bishop G3 Bishop H4 hold on hold on
Danny hold on wait a minute wait a
minute hold on
maybe he's gonna get checkmated
H3
sorry you gotta go talk to your kids in
that voice and see if they uh see if
they they call the police or something
um okay Conor is finding good moves now
don't he's moments away he's moments
away G5 Queen G4
oh oh oh
is he gonna sack the queen queen F5
Queen F4
that's the that's the Chad move right
there that's the Shad dog VA right there
wow he might do it
that's crazy
Queen F4 is a huge move
that's just like eliminating all
possible chances
I mean obviously I can do a number of
things but that would have been
that would have been the uh um
the knights don't move that way
with blacks Bishop still on the board
stalemate is not possible so
so stressed
I love watching how stressed they get
with this like it really means
everything to them
no rain told me straight up Rayne
Wilson's wife from the office it was the
most nerve-wracking thing he'd ever done
and he's acted in front of millions of
people
that's how I feel playing my games
um
look at the poll from his chat will
Connor choke and lose
that's hilarious
all right he's got him right where he if
he if he stalemates him I am going to
lose it and if sapnap resigns before
Checkmate I will I will lose it too like
you gotta play it out here
yeah
no I think I think Connor okay wait you
go for a second Queen bad things happen
lucky for him the timing is going to
work out perfectly yep black has all the
dark squares
yep
don't play G5 okay I thought he's about
to play G5 and then okay that works but
you could just Queen you could just make
a queen
gave a king H7 and you get a queen it's
still Nate oh my God oh my God
oh my God oh my God do not Queen
he offers a draw hilarious
you can go there
except that buffers oh that's a good
move forcing him into a promotion check
wow there there it is there's like eight
mates in One now okay he chooses made
into because Christ
God damn it Connor why are you why are
you making this so hard
[Laughter]
I I don't like God
holy
that should have been the nice most
chillest experience for me holy moly
Jesus God
well it's sad it is sad it's a Sad Panda
it's panda in Reverse replace the D with
a p you get sapnap the Snappers are
unhappy Conor moves on
yeah
you uh you you know you you said it
better than I ever could have then
any writers or
journalists or authors or any you know
you I don't even know what you said it's
been a long day and
my blood sugar is low and I need the
fried chicken that I ordered like two
hours ago uh oh man Connor Sea Dog VA
getting it done versus sapnap in a
playoff
much deserved playoff what a fight from
both players and uh the top dog is still
in the event and that's why it's in his
name the top dog Sea Dog still stands
going up against the the guy in his in
his same time zone uh but they'll be
playing on our time zone when it's
convenient for all of us tomorrow that
Sea Dog Conor versus Alex I did a thing
of course Frank and xuc as you all
already know we're in the semi-finals so
that is it those are the last four men
left standing in the championship
bracket
what a wild day this has been Levy we've
only got a few moments left we're going
to catch up with these guys
with interviews and um I'm sad for
sapnap I'm not gonna lie
I'm got it
but I think we're gonna be joined by
them both
yep so
so don't go anywhere everyone that's
Connor he moves on in overtime fashion
two to one the final score against
sapnap we are going to be joined by
these two men in just a moment don't go
anywhere
yes
foreign
[Music]
makes shows like this possible which is
why our twitch subscribers will never
see ads on chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done a
hundred percent ad-free Bliss
forevermore whether you're following our
events on site or on stream type the
command connect in the chat and thank
you for helping bring these shows to
life
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
Masters can then lose 10 pounds and burn
6 000 calories just by sitting yeah so
I've actually been spending a lot of
time getting in shape wow that's great
what are you doing mostly like real
Clips oh I've never heard of that it's a
thing don't look it up
[Music]
no
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Champs five what an epic day five
matches finally in the books and Batman
Sea Dog was the top dog coming in and he
still
Stands Tall barely getting by in this
one by a score of two to one in overtime
Connor you uh you had us on the edge of
our seat I assume you were throwing for
content
ah obviously obviously that's what
happened
um yeah I think my I think I I just
heard like the Windows shut down noise
in that second match for my brain I just
I don't know what happened I think I got
too confident because the first game I
felt like I did really well uh but Sam
that was giving me trouble the entire
time I did not feel like there was ever
any point where it was like all right
I'm gonna win this except when you threw
the queen but that's you know that was
fun that that I I feel that pain so much
I've done it many a times especially in
tournaments live it's like God damn it
that was insanely close closer than I
wanted it to be
I don't sometimes it's hard uh like
Danny and I obviously we've played a
long time we've seen a lot of Chess I
don't think you guys either of you
realize how close that match was like
the match came down literally to two
moves in game three
like that was it and I by the way it
wasn't even throwing for Content I gotta
give some love here to sapnap like game
two you'll watch the commentary back you
took that rook in the corner and both
Danny and I went it's not over if sapnap
launches this attack and he was like I'm
gonna go launch this attack there was
nothing he could have done better like
it was it was exactly how uh a
one-on-one competitive event should go
it was it was really really close and uh
I don't know I'm like I I it's one of
these matches I didn't want to see
either play or lose like there's some
streamers in the event I don't know that
well they can lose but I was like man
it's really a shame somebody has to lose
here so it was a great match and uh
yeah I'm I'm gutted but good fight
sapnap we were we were yeah it was
depressing
I know dude I've lost a lot of chess
games I know I uh I've lost a lot of
games myself man it everyone's like
telling you it's like all good and
you're just like it's not all good man
it's not all good yeah but the second
game was was wicked that was a crazy
comeback and yeah I believe he said like
15 times oh he's gonna attack me on this
side now but I was pretty confident he
couldn't do it and then I just allowed I
just invited him into my house I was
like all right you know what let's set
up a nice couch let's put a bed here get
comfortable and why not yeah you castle
and I was like oh wait I see I have life
I was like there's there's some nasty
things about to happen I said it on the
stream like five times I was like I
shouldn't Castle here because this is
exactly what he needs me to do and then
I was like you know it all Castle
dumb my brain
the best part is I mean dude
yeah I was gonna tell Connor that but
what you know when you castled it was
the top move of the computer so that
just goes to show you how
how chess is a chess
because I I could I could see that he
didn't have the pieces in place to be
able to make the attack work if I played
everything correctly so that's why I
initially I was like okay I think
castling is safe here because you still
can't maneuver his rook and his Knight
into a position in enough moves to to be
able to do a Killer attack on me but
then I just decided to invite the queen
in and then I was like all right well
this is I don't know why I did this I
was one move too early pushing the the
pawn there was premature
yeah you summarized that that was that
was exactly right yeah Danny we're gonna
ask a question sorry I was gonna say
sapnet how you doing man I know this
didn't end the way you wanted we know
how badly you wanted to be in POG Champs
you played so great I know I was teasing
on the throwing for Content I want to
reiterate you none of you play
phenomenal dude we were listening into
your streams and the ideas you were
coming up with if I was to give one
piece of advice you were up five minutes
in game one and you played too fast into
the blunder in the second game right you
had great ideas I think if I was your
coach I would say yo take a breath
because the ideas you're seeing are
phenomenal and you're just playing a
little too fast in some of those moments
to be honest yeah my but my idea was the
same for both sides was just to kind of
like lock up like kind of lock the
position in a way where I can just bring
all my pieces onto the side that he
castles to and then just I mean once you
get all the pieces there it's over uh
but like yeah the second game is blunder
I mean the first game is blunder my
queen which is like really stupid
um which is unfortunate this wasn't
taking my time and then the third game I
thought I had it like I really did think
I had it like whenever I got my queen in
that back in the back uh but then that
one move he had that one that one bro I
mean not brilliant but the best move
just taking the pawn and guarding it I
just didn't know what to do after that
yeah well you guys whatever yeah go
ahead whatever happens in this
tournament like whoever wins it uh
sapnap you have the unique distinction
of being the only player to beat the
number one and number two rated players
like you beat virtual and UBC though
yeah so yeah I had oh what's up with
that you had the hardest the hardest
route out of anyone I think I had no
games where I was playing someone that I
was like yeah this is like I never had
any free games none I went in my group
was insane and then I got to go up
against Sea Dog in the first round that
is messed up yeah it's because they put
everyone else who was low rated next to
xqc because they they need yeah
who's gonna who's like 200 let's just
put you against X yeah they're like yeah
for the record access group is I think
the highest rating is like 300 in there
and then him that must be nice
uh for the record I get to agree with
you guys because For the First Time I
didn't make the pairings I see Levy
pointing at me I didn't do it don't
point with me
I just hey I just noticed I'm like man
this route looks a lot easier than us
yeah our side of the fact you're not
real tough
I'm not gonna lie you guys were in the
toughest group toughest I mean sapnap
your it's like easy to say but you're
not wrong you literally had a freaking
nightmare of an event as far as the
opponents you played and you played
great chess dude yeah I don't I don't
think there was a a harder group I don't
think I think I by far like I don't
think there's any harder route to the
finals than the one I had so I mean I'm
happy I took a game I was worried I was
about to get like wiped and not even get
a game so I guess I'm feels a little bit
good I at least got one game and the
third game was close so
dude you played great and I've you know
consolation I'll promise you an invite
to the next POG Champs right here live
as a way to make up for it because I
know we tortured you this time and kept
you out and you can hold me to it so to
make up for your tough road I'm on
record you're invited to the next block
Champs it's in the book all right who's
in your group you get some pictures in
your group I can't go that far you don't
get your fingers in the group but you do
get invited excuses
yeah well Connor um you go up against
Alex I just I want to be on record one
your accent is way sexier than his okay
your accent is so much sexier than the
Australia secondly we would much rather
see you in La than I did I'm just
kidding I'm having a good time memeing
on him so how excited are you to go off
the flight prices right it's ridiculous
from Australia it's like 50 now yeah
let's go to bankruptchess.com
exactly so so all right what are you
gonna do to take to take down Alex
tomorrow tell us about it uh
I don't know Alex messaged me the other
day and he asked me what's my favorite
opening and I was like why he's like so
I can practice against you and I was
like okay all right I don't know I I
like Alex Alex I think is he's like a
he's like a dark horse he's he's plays
really well I'm kind of scared uh he
doesn't make a lot of obvious blunders
which I do uh so it's gonna be hard I
think uh this side of the bracket is
stacked this is this is not like none of
these games are easy
um but I'm good friends with Alex as
well so hopefully it'll be a fun match
yep I I was just checking the ticket
prices it's four and a half thousand
dollars from Tokyo and where is Alexa in
Australia address
let's just check who's gonna bankrupt oh
listen Australia is cheaper Danny I you
know it's cheaper by like 3x I'm just
wow okay Sam we're gonna rig the match
all right well snap I know I know the uh
the campaign like I said didn't go how
you wanted but we are going to see you
already in the next pod champ so tell us
what was your what was your experience I
know you grinded I know you wanted it
and um did you have a good time
I I actually did I had a great time I
think like I'm happy with the way I
played except for every first game that
I played I just like threw I think I
threw literally every single first game
that I played which is a little
disappointing but I came back and almost
every single time except for this one
and the first game against Gastly so I'm
actually pretty I think I played pretty
well once I stopped just throwing my
queen away so I'm actually pretty happy
and I'm I'm excited I think I think I'll
win the next one I'll win POG champ six
that's my event all right I love it
I think you're gonna win I I I in my
mind I literally thought if I beat Sea
Dog today I've won like that's literally
what I thought I thought I don't think
anyone else is gonna stack up to the way
Sea Dog is so I think you're gonna take
it just don't don't blunder play your
game you play really good yeah you got
it
man
at the start of the day we kind of
previewed we said this is the last
matchup of the day but whoever wins it
is probably the favorite to win it all
so we we concur sapnap at least a favor
I'm trying to drinks you man not trying
to jinx you but I think I think you're
you're playing good chess and we hope
you keep doing it
I got nothing else guys you're both
awesome thank you so much thank you guys
all right it was fun bye guys it was a
pleasure see you tomorrow
see ya bye
all right on that note Levy those are
our four semi-finalists and um those two
guys were both great great interview
they're not wrong they were on the tough
side of the bracket and only one of them
can make it through to play Alex and
that was Connor today
yeah
and the ticket prices from Tokyo to LAX
are something like five thousand dollars
uh and that's economy so I'm just saying
you know the prize will pay for itself
yeah well there's our xqc celebrating he
took down his opponent in
uh sorry I'm breaking out for gonna be
played I know the virtual one against uh
saikuno xu-cb Papa plot I'm sorry in
double OT Judy also a big winner she is
moving on to the semi-finals of the
consolation bracket despite the uh the
tough the tough situation there she's
going through with and then we got Alex
Alex also won and he'll be playing Conor
our last winner of the day Levy this is
pretty awesome a ton of fun much love to
everybody tune in tomorrow for more POG
Champs five
and uh
I guess we'll see you then am I throwing
out am I done consolation bracket LOL to
plug Champs
oh we're still going
okay my bad
we're rolling the tape and I'm like what
are we doing here I lost track
um welcome to pog Champs that's okay
um I I had a blast uh I feel like today
all of the favorites won their match we
didn't have any anything really too
surprising uh but uh but The Underdogs
did put up a fight yeah uh I listen I
had told sapnap like there is a you know
you you can beat Conor and he did and it
was a very close playoff and Connor's
been in a few of those but he's had the
upper hand uh he's the number one ranked
player for a reason Danny I'm serious
when it said snap that beat the two best
players in the tournament already so I
you should hold his head up high well
he's already invited to the next POG
Champs and uh guess what everyone else
in the community is invited to Untitled
Tuesday how's that for a natural Segway
we've got Untitled Tuesday happening
every Tuesday did you know that or are
you only focused on the top players
playing in title Tuesday if you're not a
GM you can now get ready for Untitled
Tuesday every Tuesday you heard it it's
here you can compete for premium
memberships and all kinds of fun join
the fight on Tuesday instead of just
watching the top players use the command
Untitled for more information because it
is open to all Untitled community
members which means everybody who is not
Danny wrench and Levy Rosman
um because last time I checked we are
title players
love title Tuesday love Untitled Tuesday
love POG Champs and tomorrow it is
Tuesday uh and we uh we have we have
more pot jams coverage uh we are still
figuring out I think all the times it's
crazy we're done we're done with the
quarterfinals
we're done with the quarterfinals shout
out to everybody who tuned in thank you
so much to the team working super hard
behind the scenes all the mods all the
production crew we will see you Manana
on Tuesday it's a busy day in the world
of Chess title Tuesday Untitled Tuesday
and Pog Champs 5 continues we will see
you tomorrow I don't know why I'm doing
this tune in or Wham shadow box see you
then
peace we out for free
sniper boom boom wow nine
oh no he's always at him he's got it oh
my god
wow paper plate eliminated oh no crazy
I'm crazy oh I'm an idiot that was
unbelievable sometimes if you hit the
draw button don't miss clickets this
check right on the board
it's gonna be a problem going off yeah
right pick a move Jenny oh that's good
oh my goodness he got double forked man
he's a super good player and just like
that oh my God and now he's going full
protests never go full bow ties we go
next game there's no way going crazy oh
my God yes sir yes oh that's a good move
Christ that should have been the nice
most chillest experience for me holy
moly
going
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
three two one here we go
foreign
[Music]